[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
titans fell in heroes rose at the 2022
u.s juniors and senior championships in
st louis
with titles on the line limits were
pushed as competitors reached for the
ultimate goal leader sophie mora suzuki
rebounded in the girls junior with their
seventh victory christopher yu also
bounced back from a loss defeating his
opponent to maintain a one-point lead
over the juniors the legends however are
up in the air with an unprecedented
five-way tie for first going into the
final round
the finish line is in sight but who will
prevail round nine of championship chess
coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to the
championship round of the us juniors and
seniors chess championships held here at
the saint louis chess club we start a
day in the playing hall as we are
waiting for the players to arrive they
are ready to compete the fans are
cheering and you have the best seats in
the house so just sit back and enjoy the
spec
hello everyone welcome to the beautiful
city of saint louis where we are in our
final rounds of these championships the
girls the juniors the seniors we will be
crowning three national champions but
who will they be hello everyone i'm
yester sarawan along with doris and
derek shawnee dorset yes they're excited
for today i am so excited this has been
wonderful so many decisive games hello
everyone and thank you for joining us as
we are in our championship and final
rounds but who will seize the day who
will get their opportunities dorsa
do us the honors and tell us who's in
the mix let's go let's start with the
girls yes
exactly my thoughts so sophie uh sophie
wore suzuki has been you know having a
pretty good event seven out of eight and
she isn't a clear first and she
has an extra pointer on everybody else
so she only needs a draw to secure her
throat absolutely two uh players
jennifer you talia cervantes in the mix
and in the juniors
christopher you also had a very
interesting game yesterday very nice
interview he is
also having a good tournament six and a
half out of eight and he is a full point
ahead
of his closest rival who is andrew hong
and in the seniors it's a donnybrook
attack
it's a five way tie oh boy oh boy wow
dmitry larry vladimir alex
maxim all in the mix gregory on the
outside of the bubble you guys all draw
i'll try to win and it could be
six it would be amazing uh
and the format uh dorsal please so far
we've had a great uh tournament right
ten player nine rounds everybody plays
everybody it's a 90 minute for the first
40 move then you get an extra 30 minutes
after mu 40 and you do get 30 second
increments from the first move nobody's
offering
draws there hasn't been a problem in
this event that is for sure yeah and
you win you get a point you draw you get
half a point then you draw and you lose
you don't really
you get nothing you get nothing and
because of the possibility of a playoff
what happens if two
two persons tie for first uh throughout
two players high
results in a two rapid match
so two games and if there's still time
then go play armageddon wonderful and
what if they're multiple players tight
oh there will be a rapid round robin if
there is a steel type maybe a blitz
match or a round robin if you guys are
still tired we will destroy you to the
armageddon go enjoy absolutely and we're
very very fortunate to have christian in
studio to break out down all of these
ties and who's in the mix good to see
you my friend christian welcome to the
last round good to see you guys uh great
to be back in the studio calling the
action here calling the games of the
best juniors as well as seniors that we
have here living on american soil and
what a tournament this has been filled
with thrills and spills but finally this
is it the championship round the round
where kings and queens will be crowned
and let's take a look at where we stand
in terms of a critical last round
pairings and we're going to start with
the senior section well in that one i
have to say we have five players a log
jam at the top a copy on chabal of lugi
gurevich and christensen and i'm seeing
this bearing zakopian versus the fermion
a struggling deferment that is a big
discrepancy in their current score five
points against one and a half and also a
copian has the white pieces a big chance
for the rating favorite going into this
event chabala versus lugi that's a big
matchup shabbalov is coming off a win
against larry christensen and gurevich
versus larry christensen guys this one
is going to be a barn burner and let's
take a look at what's happening in the
girls section well there is one story
and it has been throughout the event one
story and that is the story of sophie
maurice suzuki she scored six out of six
she was this close to scoring a fabiano
caruana unfortunately for her was
defeated by jennifer eu in that
important round seven but bounced back
yesterday with a critical victory
against valea and these are the two
pairings that i'm looking at for today
velez versus jennifer you who is within
striking distance of sophie mori suzuki
but
she sophie mori suzuki needs to lose
against talia cervantes if any of these
players are going to catch her she has
the draw odds going into this final
round she draws she wins she wins the
coveted title and let's take a look at
what's happening in the junior section
as well well just like in the girls
section we have one player that has been
creating separation compared to her
opponents and that is christopher you
right now sitting at the top of the
standings one point clear ahead of
andrew hong who unfortunately for him
had a winning position yesterday against
a wonderly angle but was unable to
convert well today christopher eu is
facing with the black pieces of very
dangerous karissa yip karissa hasn't
been having the best tournament of her
life off to this point but she is in
prime position to potentially play
spoilers to christopher yu's tournament
and then andrew hung versus espinosa
espinosa has been struggling in this
event also he is the lowest rated player
in the event and let's take well guys i
mean
this are going to be some amazing are
going to be some amazing games uh in
this critical final round and we will be
here to call all the action what games
do you have your eyes on guys everyone
that you mentioned those are all of our
marquee matchups but for us
christian everybody we have just been
amazed by the incredible number of
decisive games yes dorset i mean this
has been one of the most extraordinary
national championships that i've ever
covered i'm used to seeing 20
30
maybe 35
on the upside of decisive games here
we're witnessing 65 dorset 65
and one day we had an 80
oh my goodness and that was nearly
nearly 14 out of 15 by the way i want to
say that that day was amazing
13 out of 15 in the round seven another
one of those days that could have easily
been 14 out of 15 decisive games and
it's extraordinary and they have been
fighting so hard and for what well quite
a lot of money absolutely so in the
girls section the first place does go
home with a nice six thousand dollar
paycheck and in the juniors the juniors
is a little bit more
almost double yes actually exactly
double twenty thousand twenty thousand
six hundred yeah yeah uh so the first
place does go on with twelve thousand
dollars in this section
and of course their spell is special
scholarships awarded to the soul winners
yes yes so the sole winner of the
juniors and the junior girls does end up
getting a ten thousand dollar
scholarship to the institution that they
choose and this is a very generous fund
by dwayne barber foundation and usgs our
shout outs to dewayne and susan barber
for all their support and in the seniors
what are they fighting for no
scholarship here
[Laughter]
uh but oh the first place does go home
with a nice twenty thousand dollars ah
it is called five-way tie yeah it's
called retirement padding there is uh
seventy-five thousand dollars in total
prize money and as the players uh come
and get ready oh
this is it
those are your five leaders
all looking very pleased with themselves
as they get ready for this round nine
wow wonderful job for our producers and
the camera crew and woof it's really
hard to get together
two grand masters together to get all
five you know like i mean uh applause on
that one
um
yes i cannot think of any tournament in
which uh the player going into the last
round that was placed sixth in the
standings had a clear shot at
potentially winning the event
and this is what's happening in the
senior section because kaidanov is only
half a point behind the leaders right
and we know that if a kobian maybe
doesn't win against nick defermion and
uh the two pairings the ones that where
the leaders are facing each other maybe
end up in a draw well kaidanov could
join the mix and then we would have a
six-way thai breaks this is just going
to be incredible guys
well yeah bite your tongue on that one i
mean
our goal is to call the action and then
rush over to the uh closing ceremonies
and uh congratulate all the prize
winners we could be here for a long long
day if there was a lot of playoffs and
they are underway oh my goodness a
scandinavian wow
now this defense is very very popular
at class levels but
for u.s championships it's kind of a
rarity um i remember varus e6 playing it
against
fabiano in a u.s championship but
otherwise
i'm just not used to seeing it well
magnus also played it against fabiano at
the 2016 olympiad in baku
he played this hunt in scandinavia
and i do remember
in the world championship match
between gary kasparov and viswanathan
anand that was played in 1995 at the
world trade center
on the observation deck it was 110
floors
above
the ground
and it was
really an amazing match
this move queen d6 in this exact moment
uh after knight c3 queen a5 used to be
it that was like the end of the story
everybody played queen a5
people who were kind of defensively
minded played the move queen d8 the full
retreat queen d6 kind of suggests look
uh now that i'm here go ahead and try to
take advantage of my situation in other
words are you going to play for bishop
f4 or maybe a knight e4 tempo and the
move knight f3 to my eyes it kind of
says well i'm not really playing for the
bishop f4 uh
of course we're in theory there's no
question about that but uh christian
what are the most popular ways of
needing this move queen d6 i mean
there's no uh you know refutation no
absolutely no reputation i remember i
looked at this line actually played it
back when i used to play one e4 as white
in my youth if you can call it that way
15 years ago now
generally from what i remember you want
to target the queen on d6 as fast as
possible really this idea of g3 followed
by bishop to f4 now you have to also be
careful because whenever you go bishop
to f4 you have to be wary of this move
queen to b4 so very often you see this
setup for white you actually start with
a3 first after g3 bishop to g2 castle
and then you go a3 and then you jump
with the bishop on f4 another way of
working things out for white in this
position is to actually take the bull by
the horns immediately with a move knight
to e5 jump in the center take advantage
of the fact that black doesn't have any
piece outside of the queen but that
doesn't matter too much because you
cannot take on e5 controlling the square
e5 and after knight d7 f4 is one of the
ways in which white can play knight to
c4 is another way in which white can
play or bishop to f4 a lot of ways in
which white can arrange their pieces
depending on
what the outcome of the opening he uh is
looking for as well as what the goals
are for at this particular game now we
know
five players tied at the top one of them
statistically probably will win right
you want to be that player that's going
to win if you are playing against the
scandinavian you have the white pieces
you're coming off of victory against the
leader going into that round that was
larry christensen going into the eighth
round well you feel pretty confident
right so right now what i'm seeing for
shabbalov is a potential to try to take
advantage of this very risky uh opening
choice by black by maxim gloogy try to
take advantage of that and maybe score a
victory still is going to be very very
complex and we know maxim bloogee well
he played the scandinavian so he
definitely knows what he's doing he
analyzed it with his students he
analyzed it for himself as well he's
looking for a destabilized game and this
is exactly what he's getting from this
one thank you christian dorsey do you
have any experience yourself with the
scandinavian as either side yes as white
i have quite a lot
i remember there was an asian um asian
championship yeah that i needed went to
secure my victory and um the opponents
played scandinavian and i did win it but
it was not that easy right do you think
of it as a risky opening defense i mean
for black or is it in your mind see
completely playable
i mean i feel like it's not as devilized
as sicilians okay and it's not as
you know that draw as four nights okay
so i mean it's i don't think it's
necessarily a risky choice but it's
it's gives opportunities okay and i've
told some of my students to play this
queen d6 and i know some of them loved
it some of them did not like it at all
right you're bouncing around with your
with your queen yeah in our other uh
featured uh keep matching the machine
because we get to that can we see what's
happening with nick the fermion maybe on
sure on the camera see him on the camera
that's exactly why i'm asking because i
don't see a move by nick the fermion so
maybe we can pan out to that game that
is game between akopian and nick
defermion to see if we have any moves or
if nick is even at the we've got
we've got
not not the scandinavian but the alakai
defense knight f6 uh nick finally we see
a move yeah knight f6
uh by nick the fermion and again it's
like one of those defenses like the
scandinavian it's kind of a rare guest
when it does make its appearance a lot
of people think to themselves oh my gosh
i forgot all my preparation right and
they tend to go for something that's a
little bit
safer
i've always felt like the four pawns
attack
was the most critical so he was late and
he decided to go with the alekhine wow i
mean
i have to say this is probably the ideal
scenario for vladimir akopian right he's
playing with the white pieces against uh
the lowest not the lowest rated player
in the event but the one that's
struggling the most only one and a half
points
for uh the furmian and also he's facing
the alkyne right what else do you want
from uh this type of scenario you are
primed to win this game and win the
tournament or potentially force the
tiebreaks i like copious chances out of
the blue out of the gun right now right
c2 c4 again
c2 c4 knight b6
uh f2 f4 in my opinion
has always been the most critical way
when you're black
and white comes with all guns blazing
and knocks your knight out of the center
gains a lot of tempe against your knight
i think that puts the most
challenge on black it's amazing for me
today
that
knight f3 is by
far
considered the most
i want to say common acceptable
way of meeting the alekhines
guys guys yes but look what's happening
in the kaidanoverse versus malnitsky
game
are we ready for this
no
gregory needs a win he's just no other
way of putting it he does no it's an
alike it's always a foreign kind with a
four pawns attack yes this is what it
was just
exactly
c5d5 and of course the most famous game
uh is this game of the day i want to say
lubamir leboyevich and david
brunstein it was like this incredibly
crazy game
with uh takes takes and i believe it was
queen h4 check and queen d4 it was like
sharp stuff yeah like that was like
triple edged and
lubo who is an amazing tactician got the
best of david in that one g7 g6
uh christian jump right in because this
move
i don't know
it has been played it has been played
quite a few times okay yes uh it seems
like
it's uh actually the second most played
move after the one that you just
mentioned
e6 which immediately targets uh the uh
overextended pawns in the center and
forces either d6 or take on e6 you
probably don't want to take on e6 g6 has
been played actually
at
actually it hasn't been played at the
top level very much i see one good
player that is maf session sergey and
one player that actually i do not
recognize his name but he has quite a
high rating 2592 francis andre
i have no idea i've never
heard of this guy probably he's a
correspondence player i have to say
g6 but then again obsession doesn't play
correspondence or at least i don't know
him as a correspondence player so i'm a
bit um befuddled by this situation right
now g6 knight to c3 most likely makes
the most sense right just simply develop
your pieces and then after the move uh
bishop to g7 you would love to have
another pawn on the f5
unfortunately that's uh no longer the
case exactly do you want to go knight to
f3 and allow bishop to g4 i don't think
so i think you have to wait for a black
to play the move knight bd7 and then
respond with a move knight to f3 so that
you don't have to worry about this spin
on the h5 d1 diagonal so i think the
best way to do things is to just start
defending the e5 pawn with the bishop
first that also prepares you have a lot
of space in the center so you have the
opportunity of potentially trying to
immediately take advantage of that and
how do you do that
queen to d2 cast along and then start an
attack on the king side because you know
that's where the black king is going to
go right they're going to castle uh
short and then that's going to open uh
things up for a potential kingside
attack very quick kingside attack uh
with the move h4 let's uh wait and see
how these players
are going to be playing and check the
boards out
they probably called each other last
night
and nick the fermion and they were like
okay we're playing against these two
guys that really want to win uh what do
you think we should do and i have no
idea how they came to the conclusion of
playing the alakin right oh my gosh uh i
have to say really shocking uh that's
probably why we have so many decisive
games dorset is like because of openings
like this
yes it's just funny for me um i've like
this is years ago um we were playing in
a tournament and
my opponent clearly couldn't remember
his theory his preparation yeah and then
i'm looking at like oh shoot the other
board is the exact same as this and i
started looking to just you know get
some ideas with what's going on over
there and my opponent also notices oh
that's the same one and they're like two
moves ahead so he just plays out what he
saw the other board doing right which
was kind of funny so i mean nick was
late maybe on the way he was like oh
that's fun maybe i'll try that today
that's where i'm going oh fantastic
we're going to keep our eyes obviously
on these marquee
matchups but let's uh jump to the ladies
let's just
we always start with our tournament
leader in this case it's going to be
talia versus sophie and this is
a queen's gambit declined a very very
standard queen's gambit declined usually
we're used to seeing this bishop on e7
but developing the bishop to d6 is just
fine queen c2 rookie 8 all well bishop
e6 now that's a little bit
off the beaten path as far as i'm
concerned i'm much more used to what we
saw with larry christensen's game knight
d7 oftentimes this knight gets to go to
f8 we'll keep an eye on this after
bishop e6
well
here's a
here's a
white's problem
the pawn on h6 is in the words of
christian a hook
in other words if i can play the move g5
i'm always opening up the king side
always there's nothing you can do about
it you played the move h6 i'm
so i could play the moves h3
g4 and castle long
putting my king in danger but definitely
i'm able to open up the
or
i could play it softly i could castle
uh a play for a minority attack with a3
b4 or rook b1 b4 and whoops
my arrows got i got the best of me there
and play for the minority attack so
you know should i take the game into
ultra sharp channels or should i play it
you know quietly and that's the problem
that talia has again a victory is what
it's all about for her
let's jump to the game of jennifer you
for
again jennifer's in the same boat oh my
goodness this is just so hilarious uh
look at what they're doing um
okay this is white
funnily enough i played this as
black whole career
now what jennifer did
and this is really funny is she's
playing a perk defense with the
variation of a6 and early b5 i had an
opponent back in iran when i was playing
in the national championships um
i had there was a girl who would always
play this so i remember the
back like 15 years ago i actually sat
down and i was like okay
i hate this b5 how can i attack it so i
started thinking about you know maybe i
can do a4 you play b4 i go knight a2 and
then i can start to tickle your pawn
with c3 at some point and i'm gonna
short castle
so that'll be fun and then like there
was a different way to like maybe i
could do bishop d3 first then do this
pontico link right but i really dislike
that pawn b5 because every time i wanted
to try to play c5 then they wanted to
guess like c4 or there was just so many
things mm-hmm
yeah so i kind of i had some fun with
that idea but it's been a while since
i've seen
this this time
okay so one thing about
this game first of all just a funny a
little parallel to that uh this uh game
uh this variation is called the
pseudo-austrian attack right
i i've never heard of that right
nevertheless now i'm jennifer ew and i'm
looking at vela
vela has one and a half points but most
importantly how did she lose those games
most of them in tactical situations i
remember uh the game against gracie
persona where she actually had the
opportunity to win a piece in a couple
of moves she did not spot that so one of
the weaknesses that i'm seeing in vella
is her tactical awareness yesterday
remember what happened yesterday against
sophie mori suzuki she played that move
knight to d7 allowed a two move very
simple tactic if you look at it
like that and this is the area of the
game of her game that i'm going to try
to target
this is what i think jennifer is trying
to do with her opening choice now at the
same time is quite risky of course we
know that but you do have the black
pieces you have to take some risks in
order to create the imbalances and
target the weakness in velaz play and
this is exactly what jennifer u is doing
right now
okay
i agree with everything you said
there christian
but
in this particular variation of trying
to
create play you should know your move
order inside and out because you're
taking huge risks with black so the
austrian attack
as you described it really is from this
move order of the perk defense where
black plays pardon me where white plays
f4 bishop g7 knight f3 and black has her
knight on f6 and she plays c5 so this is
long long long complicated theory and i
played the black side of this
again my whole career bobby fischer
played it with black against boris
baskey in the 1972 world championship
match so it has a pedigree
now when you don't play the
the the variation with
uh the perk with knight f6 but rather
you play it with bishop g7 and
you combine it with the move a6 as
opposed to knight f6 you don't
play bishop g7 bishop g7 is actually a
bad move
for this
line of play so for example you're much
better off playing the move d7 d6
knight c3
a6
f4
b5
why
because you can always play bishop g7
the moves that you do want to get in are
the moves bishop b7 knight d7 and a very
very quick c5 bishop g7
should take second
seat to bishop b7 and so what she did
however jennifer did is she put our
bishop on g7 in my opinion far too early
and if she's going to get punished
for this
transgression this poor opening play if
you will it's the move e5 so i don't
know if anna marie is well prepared or
not but it just so happens that this is
the right move e5 i think both of these
players uh maybe they know what they
should strive for but they don't know
the nuances that you just enumerated
exactly uh and she did play the move
knight to h6 and h6 is on the board and
this is a consequence of her play
uh that is to say jennifer's play is
that she has the developer knight to an
awkward square and
what this means by the way is
what you really really desperately want
to do you desperately want to break down
white center yes okay and you really
want to play the move c5 badly like this
is like almost
all important if you will
but oftentimes you have to be a little
bit worried about these types of moves
e6
knight g5 with ideas of knight h7
and bishop takes g6 as well as knight
takes e6 jennifer played the move knight
h6 and she's basically saying okay oops
excuse me uh okay uh i'm ready uh to
castle and then to play c5 the problem
is white has this move knight e4 in many
cases for example let's just put some
moves on the board and a big difference
is that white gets the opportunity to
keep her center
intact with the move c2 c3 uh this is a
very very double-edged game
you're right christian jennifer has to
take a lot of risk and she's doing it
and i said that vela's weakness is her
tactical awareness right i do believe
that jennifer's uh weakness is her
theoretical knowledge she usually shies
away from that she tries to get an
original game and then just simply
outplay her opponents and this is what
she's trying to do in uh this one well
jennifer uh jennifer's fortunes are not
in her own hands because uh well even if
she wins and talia doesn't win her game
against sophie maurice suzuki well
unfortunately she's not going to win the
title but she has to do
everything possible and that means she
needs to win this one to potentially
have a chance of catching up with the
leader absolutely by the way just going
back to the game of talia for a brief
moment i like the the decision that
talia came up with after some thought
in her game with sophie she played the
move knight f3 e5 and i like this
because it's that one of those cagey
moves it keeps white's options
open
i haven't committed myself to either
castling short or castling long
but we've seen it in the previous in an
earlier game of a wonder liang the
pillsbury attack remember where the
knight came to e5
and the pawn white's pawn went to f4
as andrew hong was putting a lot of
pressure on a wunderling so 95 f4 and
you're still keeping these ideas of g4
in reserve i could castle long i can
castle short
and i think that as far as the move
order is concerned in this play uh talia
has actually outfoxed her opponent a
little bit in these openings and it's so
difficult uh to catch your opponent
these days because everybody's got the
databases and the chess engines is this
move 95 uh christian
uh all common theory still
it's it's a move i don't think it's uh
the best movie in the position oh really
the castle is much better now castle
short or long uh sure okay the problem
is the move knight to e5 opens up the
possibility of a black taking advantage
of the fact that the knight is not
secured yet on e5 and i can start with
the move c5 okay now if you take on c5
then uh of course you lose the knight on
e5 you cannot do that now at the same
time i'm taking advantage of the fact
that i haven't developed my knight yet
via d7 f8 the maneuver that you were
mentioning at the beginning of the
broadcast the typical maneuver in this
type of situations so now i can go c5
and then play the move knight to c6 as
you are very accurately pointing out on
your board and it does seem like c5
equalizes at least from um
a um
well a theoretical standpoint in this
position nakamura versus kramnik seems
to have been a game i would expect this
was in a blitz encounter between these
two players
from the olympia 2016 that might be from
the olympiad yes
even though
uh yeah nakamura did play like this
inaccuracy inaccuracy and he got the
worst position
accuracy man it doesn't strike me as one
of those classical encounters in which
nakamura knows exactly what to do maybe
it was from the olympiad but i i i no i
do believe that it was from a blizzard
maybe a grand chester event uh with the
blitz and rapids
okay but one of the things uh christian
and i completely agree with you by the
way against knight e5 i i i like the
move c5 very very much the problem is
psychologically from
from sophia's point of view she's played
the move c7 c6 voluntarily earlier she's
setting up what she thinks is a very
very solid position and she's coming
into the game thinking i've got all i
need is a draw and i'm champion that's
it
so i'm going to play solid when you play
the move c6 and then follow it up with
c5
you're
you kind of have to change your
psychology in your approach to the
position because the move c5 is a
counter-attacking move absolutely
absolutely so it's not an easy decision
right that's exactly it it's not an easy
decision uh but one thing about sophie
is that it does seem like she senses
when these critical moments arise in the
position and she played it c5 on the
board
bravo bravo very very flexible thinking
she spent around seven minutes she was
blitzing out her moves up to this point
she remembered probably that castle is
the main line right and very accurately
understood the differences between
castle and this early knight to e5 and
took advantage of them c5 is the best
move in the position
wow okay what are those on her shirt are
those lemons
you should bring the lemons today
you sometimes uh you gotta squeeze the
lemons
exactly
nice nice all right we haven't uh seen
christopher you but uh he says hey guys
don't forget about me i i could be
champion
look yeah i'm i'm lead i'm carissa yeah
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa things have
gotten heated very very early as we're
playing a mainline
rui lopez system
christopher rook b8 a5 all of this stuff
has been seen before
h2h3 and gosh yes again i've told you
uh that door said that i have made every
mistake
in chess that you can make i've made it
but at least twice at least twice just
to be sure you know that it was a
mistake the first time and yes i have
done this my takes e4 i remember doing
it against vladimir puff nudiev
in the washington state championship
1975
porky bishop
and it was like oops now this is a
beautiful shish give up
oops
there's nothing you can do there's no
that i mean you just lose a piece and it
was just pretty painful i've played
knight takes f2 or something and i'd
lost
hopelessly badly that was but now bishop
b7 says
hey
i've got this threat what are you going
to do about it i'm going to ignore it
fair bishop e3 knight takes e4
and uh we've caught up with the players
but i'm not really familiar with the
move bishop e3 christian bale is out
this is a an accepted pawn
sacrifice is it's just it is it is
accepted pawn sacrifice now rook to e1
seems to be the more played move in the
position bishop to e3 has been played
quite a few times as well though and uh
actually most recently this was a game
between magnus carlsen and ali reza
ferrugia so
it's definitely one of the topical lines
knight takes e4 a rook to e1 and i'm
looking at this knight takes e4 did he
think about it yes he thought for like
three minutes so maybe still one hour
and 31 minutes so that points to the
fact that he was still uh most likely
within his preparation exactly at this
point rook to e1 this is what we have
right now i'm seeing against
a game between volo kitten and levon
aronia in a very recent game actually
from november 2021 so let's see how that
game actually played out i'm quite
curious no knight to e7
of course
after rook two e1 there's clear plans in
the position and that is to do and he's
about to make he's hovering with his
name
no i hate it
i am cringing
in horror well he does that this is
so bad this is like
bad habits are best cured early don't do
this if you're at home so be sure about
your move then play it with confidence
so
would you prescribe
just sitting on the hand yes he's
clearly uh in need of uh help
uh operators and yeah so you're rough oh
yeah no no no no you have to do this
that's that's why uh victor courtney
and he's playing with the thesis as well
are they this is why viktor korchnoy
would be like in this almost you know
like gnashing of teeth you gotta beat
the juniors when they're young
and again the hand hovering like if
you're not confident don't don't put
your hand over the board just
do it when you're sure the pawn thing is
definitely something that he took from
uh gailfund because yes i think they uh
did some trainings together okay so
boris is the culprit i'll write an angry
bird
you should write your name
right you should write him an email
exactly
now talk to us about this knight e7
because i see some possibilities of uh
of forks with bishop f7 and rookie four
and knight g5 well it very much depends
on what you do next right so now the
plan of rook to u1 you would expect some
sort of discovery attack but exactly
actually you have a big threat and that
is if you go castle i will go d5
taking advantage of the fact that the
bishop is not protected on a7 now if you
take of course i take back with the rook
and now you have two knights under
attack as you have to lose one of them
probably knight takes f2 but that's not
enough compensation for black so right
rook to e1
has a clear threat knight to e7 seems to
be the main move and let's take a look
at how this game
actually played out because surprisingly
aronian made a mistake very early on
once again i do think it was a blitz or
a rapid game we don't have uh that
information here bishop takes e3 rook
takes e3 and now he took on e5 this is
not the correct approach you have to go
castle short if you take on e5 after d3
you're close to being lost wow the
position yes the queen is having a very
rough time finding a good spot also
everything just comes with tempo so for
example if you drop back to d6 i will go
knight to g5 not even take the pawn
but rather knight to g5 and i think this
is what he missed um aronian that is
knight to g5 if you go castle then after
queen to h5 unfortunately you are tied
down
the knight is tied down
on this file by the rook and i have two
big threats queen takes h7 and knight
takes f7 and the hover continues
take a look at that yes sir do you need
a minute to go up there and just
no yeah slap everyone like stop doing
that like and stop playing with the dawn
as well so his defense his muscles are
definitely
oh
yeah that's all you need it's just a
little brownie point because well no
because he lost everything he lost the
cookies the everything prior to that
with the hovering but the way he
actually played it was impressive we
even saw a slight smile from karissa
when she came to the board yeah i think
she was following the hoveri
[Laughter]
it just looks so amateurish clear yeah i
mean
the professional is always
elan
dignity dignity dignity dorsa that's
what it's all about as we said and
singing in the rain
but 97 on the board and again uh take us
you were saying castles was the bad move
because of d5 christian 97 was none of
the castle was a good move castle was
casual it was instead of 97 yes that's a
problem of course but because
castle is the right move right um
actually no sorry bishop takes c3 first
of course right you cannot just give up
the bishop on a7 and here castle not
take on e5 because of rook to d3 right
that's a problem knight to c5 also seems
to be um quite a good uh option at this
point and the point being i mean there's
a lot of things going on right now
knight to d2 is one way bishop to c2 is
another way and
you need to start being very careful
about any potential sacrifices on h7 and
you have to take the bull by the horns
and allow them allow bishop takes h7
which unfortunately for white do not
work but it's not an easy decision to
make over the board if you actually
don't know what's happening in the
position very easy at this point would
be to just simply play the move f5 right
makes much more sense the problem is now
that you weakened uh the the king and
the diagonal the a to ga diagonal i can
just simply take on d6 you take back
with the knight i return
on the weakened diagonal and i'll take
advantage of the fact that i can bring
my knight to e5 or to g5 and that's
never going to get bothered by a pawn
coming to f6 because your pawn is
already on f5 overextended i have a lot
of squares like that i can try to take
advantage of and this is what i'm seeing
in this game christian break it down for
us in terms of percentage
how often does white win from the
position
from the position
right now yeah after knight to e7
there's only two games only two games
only two games and in fact white won
both of those games and they're actually
pretty significant games is volo kitten
versus aronian two great very very big
names also abdul satorov nadirbak abdul
satorov the rapid world champion from
2021 if i'm not mistaken
he won a game against maurizi marc
andrea who is in fact i do believe the
youngest grand master in france
right now so definitely a big clash a
big theoretical clash uh that one as
well but white won both games so let's
see whether karissa is aware of these
games and whether christopher
potentially could have and could face
some difficulties in today's game and
karissa could really be a spoiler she is
because she is ninth position against
number one if he comes up with the goods
today it would be fantastic
how many times have we seen that
yes the top level player going into the
final round or like the second seed
going into the final round plays one of
the lowest players uh in terms of
standings and they lose right
understandings it's kind of interesting
can we go back to standing just one sec
because i just want to say karissa's two
points even if she wins she's still
gonna stay the ninth exactly
likely yes
sad to say a win does not improve her
standings but sure makes her feel a lot
better about the journal of course
i just wanted to jump to the game of
pedro espinosa for a moment against
andrew hung i mean again andrew is
sitting there hey carissa you know i've
always cheered for you in all your games
you go out and win i'll be so happy
andrew needs to win
against pedro to give himself a chance
for a potential playoff now again we've
got this queen's gambit declined the
type of position as we've seen in
sophie's game with the pawn on c6 b7 d5
lots of differences in this one first of
all the bishop isn't on e6 has actually
ended up on f5 the bishop is not on d6
it ended up on b4 and pedro said you
know what i'm going to try to take
advantage of the fact that your bishop
is misplaced i'll attack the bishop
please give up the two bishops i'll take
it with the pawn and i'll chisel away at
your center and if the bishop moves yeah
i'm going to take this pawn on b7 andrew
had to play the move queen to b6 and
exactly at this moment i think pedro is
eyeballing the opportunity to play
knight a5 and maybe
in a sense a little bit discombubilation
of um
black's uh pieces like the queen on a5
the bishop on b4 look a little strange
the queen on b3 looks a little strange
but we've often times see
white playing for a3 b4 94 knight c5
andrew pedro i think is going to come
out of this with a slight pull
but we'll keep an eye by the way he did
very quickly pedro that is to say
against queen b6 he played the move
knight d2
and well i'm not a big fan of that move
but we'll keep an eye on
my god
that's always a question i ask myself
when i play a move like knight d2 i ask
myself the salient question where am i
going with that
virtually no i mean black has actually
put
his whole
development uh scheme of development
based on stopping the move e4 where
would you like to take us uh i would
like to take another look at their
seniors because they're okay let's do it
six way tie coming up
and crazy things are
happening in gregory kaidan of igor's
game uh where is vladimir
vladimirokopian
that
wow uh that was the alekhine but in this
particular alakine captures on d6 was
quite very good
by nick defermion in this position
it's amazing to me how often the move c7
takes d6 is played and i consider that
actually to be a bad move i think
black's best recapture by far is the
move e7 takes d6 i was preparing for a
game against kevin spraggett in one of
my last tournaments i was white and i
noticed that kevin liked to play the
alakine but he liked to recapture with
the d6 pawn and the problem for me is i
didn't think as white i was getting any
advantage in this particular line knight
a6 was not
on my
radar i was really looking at variations
with bishop f6 as well as knight c6
knight a6
a little bit peculiar earlier i know i'm
just trying to go like my 97 yes and
maybe
we just asked ourselves a question
when we play a move like night day six
we have to ask ourselves all right the
question where's our night going i think
nick is preparing for the
how do you say the fancy the fancy
knight c7 knight he says
when i first came to us and joined
sluchas team this was like five years
ago uh we had an internal bet
that's in when you play serious chess
yeah the person who naturally gets the
knight onto e3 d3 or e6 d6 yeah would be
owed a coffee
ah
very nice oh this is a beverage but i'm
good
with the favorite nice but it was it was
just um and you know when you're playing
a serious
team event you keep thinking do i want
to risk the
coffee for the beverage right so for me
because of white's pawn structure
white's having the a little bit more
space
i is black i'm looking for trades so in
my mind i'm looking to play a move like
knight to b4 in order
because the pawn on c4 is
weak or needs protection from the bishop
so i'm looking to play that and castle
c7 c6
knight g3 g6
i just got to ask
christian is this theory knight a6
no no no no there's no theory happening
no theory that's very happy um the small
laughter was no no no
in fact g6 it seems like was the first
new move rook 28 was played once once
again some players that i don't
recognize their names i recognize
panchevsky with the black pieces a grand
master from uh machodonia i
think
against lots of tony 2295 so not a very
significant game that was and of course
knight to g3 is not the only move either
you can play the move a3
aimed against the idea that you are
mentioning knight to b4 right but knight
to b4 doesn't make that much sense now
that you placed your pawn on c6 exactly
much more uh i'm drawn to the idea of
knight to c7 knight to e6 the maneuver
that you pointed out initially now
the question is
in
the game that we in the position in the
game that we have right now after the
movie g6 right let's say rook to e1 make
sure it's a very natural move open file
how are we going to answer knight to c7
because if you do allow me to get the
knight
to e6 with a tempo and then potentially
start hovering around if you do play the
move d5 with the knight on c6 on c5
maybe even g7 followed by knight to f5 i
have a lot of routes for my knight so
one way in which white can stop that all
together is to play the move d5
that gives up a pawn nevertheless after
take take take take take
i do have to move bishop takes g6 i can
also start with the move bishop to h6
first and it does seem like
white has a slight edge now i get it you
do have the two bishops and if you do
you have to play the move bishop to e6
on good terms you're probably going to
be fine the problem is after bishop to
e6 your pawn on b7 is hanging i also
have ideas if rook takes c6 and going uh
for that exchange sacrifice so it
doesn't seem like black has a clear way
of finishing its development in the
position now
it's quite important that after the move
knight to c7 you play the move d5 if you
don't do that it does seem like black is
slowly creeping back up in uh to the
game so this is what i'm seeing from
this one the one that you guys were
looking at
gregory
i mean what is malnitsky doing in this
one because
we were expecting this right bishop to
f4
he understood what he has to do gregory
kaidanov is a very very good player and
very uh technical player as well as well
as very classical players so this type
of situations and these type of opening
choices don't face him he knows how he's
going to approach it and he knows how to
tackle them and how to punish them as
well and this is exactly what he's
focusing on e6 punish uh this situation
as fast as possible take on d5 castle
along c4 and now this is the position we
have on the board but i'm looking at uh
the game right now i play the move
knight to f3 how do you continue your
development you've got to go bishop g4
no chess no choice no choice if you do
this okay i'll continue bishop to h6 i'm
sorry but the numbers behind you they're
high
yes they're frightening
i'm squinting
like wait they're pretty high yeah yeah
yeah dorset you're not supposed to look
good where is there yeah white is better
plus four are you kidding me the number
is pretty high yeah after [ __ ] page six
is plus four uh it's really bad really
really bad and that's the thing
the moves are easy to make for white
this is what concerns me for uh
malnitsky's position knight to f3 is
just such an easy move to make exactly
self-development
let's take a look at what's happening in
chabalov guys in chabalov's game versus
maxim lugi and it's exactly what we
anticipated this idea with g3 taking
advantage immediate advantage of the
queen on d6 try to tackle it and attack
it with bishop to f4 right this is what
happened and i said that generally and
you can prepare the move bishop to f4
with the move a3 now what he's doing is
actually inviting the queen on b4 and
then targeting it with a3 if you take on
b2 well after queen to d2 your queen is
having a rough time and if you try to go
back to b6 you have to do that otherwise
it's going to get lost right i think
even knight to a4 rook to b1 is a big
threat in the position so you have to
drop back try to get back home the
problem is after rook to b1 if you stay
on d8 and allow me to take on b7 i'll
invite that trade any day any time of
the day right because that strengthens
uh the control that i have on the long
diagonal this bishop is going to open up
get opened up with knight to e5 and
you're going to have huge problems
on the pawn on c6 so that's not looking
good for black at all and if you go
queen to a6 well i have knight to e5 i
have bishop to f1 coming uh along the
route and your queen is not feeling good
right now on a6 i'm seeing this as a
clear advantage for white so
maxim is trying to figure out what he
needs to do right now whether he can
take the pawn on b2 or not i don't think
he will take it i think he will realize
that after queen to d2 he's in uh deep
trouble the problem is that i'm seeing
for uh maxim right now you play the
scandinavian you try to get a very
imbalanced uh position in the game but
it does seem like white has a very
controlled position right now i have a
very safe king
i have space advantage in the center
queen to a5 is on the board
i don't think maxim got what he wanted
out of this scandinavian and as you can
see he doesn't seem to be very happy
either well let me just play devil's
advocate for just a moment because i
didn't know if max should play queen a5
or queen b6 he eventually chose the move
queen b6 uh
yeah queen a5 uh if black
is able to get a bishop e7 castles he's
got a solid position how are you going
to break it down i don't see the target
yes solid yes i don't see the targets
but i will still have the two bishops
most likely because i will play the move
h3 what do you do i go back or do you go
back go back you don't date no then i
will continue with g i'll go back that's
okay i'll continue with b4 i'm going to
take space advantage everywhere on the
board okay i wanted to go back
originally to b6 and now you force me to
go i will go knight to a4 i will
continue even with that so if i go queen
to b6 knight to a4 followed by knight to
c5 once again i'm gaining a lot of space
in the process
i don't like it i mean i understand
i am creating some weaknesses both with
g4 as well as with b4 but spacey space
coach actually told me that space is
probably the strongest strategical
advantage that you can get in chess the
most dominant strategical advantage that
you can get into us
interesting so there are five elements
in chess okay
so this is uh very very straightforward
our favorite element is material yes oh
we like to be up a pond we like to be up
a piece material
our next favorite is timing in chess we
love to get our pieces out in the battle
while our opponent is doing nothing uh
so material time and then we understand
pawn structure right we got all those
pawns
yeah yeah
exactly you know and weaken the squares
space
is one of those things where
i have my 32 squares
you have your 32 squares and if i can
pressure you that your pieces don't have
enough space
for them to be effective then i'm going
to have a a a very very big advantage in
the game so what you just said christian
i want to say it as well absolutely
space
the most misunderstood of the five
elements and it uh
i
i learned to appreciate space
unfortunately very late i had to become
a chess master before i got
i got the right memo
this was my coach after i became an
international master actually so
um and that is the moment when it stuck
with me this idea that space is so
powerful because before that sure i was
looking at space as an advantage but not
as such a dominant advantage after that
well i won a few games advantage and i
understood yeah it's really powerful
yeah and the the this great idea of just
kind of holding your opponent in some
kind of a vice-like grip that they
couldn't escape from satisfying very
very satisfying uh jennifer you because
she was suffering
a space disadvantage
how is she doing
well the position kind of blowed up
let's take a look we left it at night
age six we were thinking about the
players beginning to castle e2 i'm not a
big fan of this move i was happy with
knight e4
followed by c3 in castles queenie two
preps
e6 yes and it might have some eyes for
a4 ideas
because a4 i'm kind of beginning to
question hey you want to take that so i
can take with rook and start picking up
your a6 okay so she did play queenie two
castles inviting e6 hey if you want to
go ahead and play e6 uh it's going to
cost you some time
so for you
probably you should be playing knight
let me make a better move for you in
this position knight to g5 e6 is
actually
pretty darn good
she did not play e6 she went for castles
c5 again
jennifer is breaking down white in the
center
and you know i've i'm trying
to to put my pawn on e6 she played the
move bishop e4 well okay that comes with
rook v8
rook d1 now this is actually gone very
well
suddenly for jennifer because she's
actually kind of dictating the action
here a little bit now again i'm not
going to talk about what the engine
likes or doesn't like but it's all about
breaking down the center the the the
engines might say hey look
oh i could play queen c7 as well hey
look i'm material up i've got uh
material but the fact that
black has broken down the center is for
for me
an indication that jennifer's kind of
happy with the outcome of the opening
rook d1
jennifer to play not the only move of
course um
what's another decent move maybe
queen no bishop b7 wait a minute hold on
i'm having trouble making another move
if i take
take i could go queen b6 yeah queen b6
but i'm inviting knight d5
i'm not happy about knight d5 and or
bishop wait a minute just a second no
knights have fives
yeah i'm not happy with knight five
either am i i mean i might just play d5
and take this guy and i'll have a pretty
nice wait a minute i'm having a hard
time coming up with a good move for
black here uh oh and jennifer look at
her face stinking squeezing the head
yeah
okay uh
one of b4 maybe
is that a move i could uh
consider if you jump
jump oh
this is more or less trapped by bishop
[Laughter]
like this right
uh this is more or less where the tricky
tactics
uh
could be shown um i'm having a little
i'm struggling a little here
christian for jennifer no i think you
guys uh are actually following the best
uh
the best train of thought because you
started with c takes d4 and you
understood that after knight takes d4
knight to c6 might be a problem not only
that
but the second knight can get an
invitation into the center and that
might be
problematic right so first kick the
knight away
okay with the move b4 okay very nicely
inferred by you guys and knight wave
four knight to d5 knight to d5 you start
understanding it doesn't work because of
e6 that's a problem right so you have to
go to a4 but now finally that knight on
a4 is not landing anytime soon on d5 and
that's a much more improved version than
what you guys showed at the beginning so
now you just simply take on d4 knight
takes d4 and you have options bishop to
b7 is one of them you can also just take
on e5 and go for this exchange sacrifice
which actually is probably pretty good
for black for black yeah okay
nice
very very very good and let's just check
in ontalia's game because it's all about
uh these two players uh sophia is just
saying please i just want to draw
sophia
after c5 yeah
knight c6 takes takes
and telia did not capture
uh on c5 that would be that could cause
maybe
bishop takes eight look at this what do
you think about this
[Music]
i see a cheapo as well knight g4 check
and
uh whoops
no me gusta i don't i i i don't like
this for white so talia uh
reigned in her horns a bit she played
the move bishop g3 and we are up to date
with the players in balanced position i
kind of like it time is
talia is 59 minutes
sophie is
an hour 20.
so sophie has actually been the one
uh
faster with her moves
and
um
winner draw and she is our champion
we'll keep an eye on this and christian
i'm gonna throw it to you uh
what's happening in those juniors
and seniors well actually i was looking
at the game as well yeah as well so uh i
was following the same path as you guys
and it does seem like sophie is doing
just fine in this position actually c5
followed by knight to c6 was extremely
important well
not only uh because well you get some
speed and momentum into your position
but you're also changing the pawn
structure in your favor now you're
trying to get to this position for
example take take and later on i will be
able to get c5 as well first of all i
should focus on your weaknesses in the
position this newly created weakness on
d4 with the move queen to b6 now that
creates some problems right how are you
going to defend against that rook to d1
sure you can do that of course but
bishop to g4 comes on the board things
are definitely moving in black's favor
this is what i'm seeing from at this
position let's take a look at what's
happening
yes you guys have something yeah well
carissa
that's where i was going
do it exactly and this is what's
happening dxe5 was played on the board
following the game that we discussed at
the beginning of the broadcast the game
between volo kitten and aronian huge
mistake
huge mistake is dxe5 rook to d3 gives
charissa an almost winning position
objectively winning position so
big chance she did not play it she
played queen to e2 right away too there
wasn't
too much
hesitation about the move queen e2 queen
to e2 spoils the advantage not only that
but after knight to c5 it seems like it
is black who has the better chances i
have to ask it's not c5 a typical move
oh yeah oh absolutely i mean you're
targeting the bishop right yeah you're
attacking the bishop immediately so why
not by the way another etiquette error
carissa had played the move queen to e2
she had pressed her clock no question
about it she had completed the move
and then on her opponent's time she
adjusted
her
her piece you're not allowed to do that
those always really make me
uncomfortable absolutely bad bad
etiquette yeah don't do that goodness
what a missed opportunity and by the way
carissa did spend uh fif uh 12 minutes
on this queen to eat oh she's oh sorry
quite significant yeah we came in and
she played it right away now knight c5
plays itself another hover this game is
going to be fun for you yeah i know i
cringe i win it's terrible i'm whining
i'm crying playing a lot of yeah
it's it's a timid hover also it's not
like a very impressive power it's a
timid hover it's the amateur like i'm
not sure about this
but he has played it knight c5 so that
move rook d3
was huge big advantage white the move
queen e2 advantage black now uh
christian yes after knight to c5 it does
seem like uh black is taking over the
initiative oh i'm not sure what she
missed now
christopher bishop to c2 so knight to c5
bishop to c two e4 e5 e i'm not giving
you the pawn back anymore no
at least not anytime soon right i'm
going to make you work uh for uh to get
that pawn back so yes e4 absolutely why
not i have to ask what do you think is
going wrong with karissa here because i
mean she's a really strong player but
you know
if i had an answer i would package it
make millions and millions of dollars
right
i don't know i i mean it's sort of like
a combination of not getting in her prep
i think she's not done enough work she's
insufficiently prepared
um
bad time management we saw in she had a
winning position against andrew in this
tournament and it was a tactical moment
where she was down on the clock and she
had to make her move quickly she didn't
have the time
to spend in critical positions in other
words bad time management caused her to
lose points later in the game and then i
don't know
confidence
i think it's a confidence thing yes and
preparation gives you confidence right
it's good preparation
she doesn't seem very well prepared not
only that but i think uh this was her
last year in high school so she's
getting ready for college she's
writing all those college applications
giving her final high school exams she's
very busy with academics right now so
probably in the past year maybe half a
year she hasn't been spending a lot of
time on her chest and it shows right now
christopher you on the other hand he's
only 15 years of age we know that he's
been training and training and training
with the best coaches in the world uh a
week ago or like a couple of weeks ago
gary kasparov was in town and he
actually trained with chris
forget about what i just said what just
happened bishop takes an s7 check all
right i'll buy it
christopher that's unexpected right
giving knight ac5 i'm was thinking the
other one right g5
okay so knight g5 check the king
presumably is going backwards to g8 i
want to say or i don't really want to
get stuck on the open e file but rook
takes
lands
oh my rook takes land that doesn't
really seem like uh i just have to pause
because
there's no queen check there's no
disturbance in the force over there so i
do have the time to try to
you i've given you a choice you can
capture here you can capture here
um or you could retreat
oh my i'm
trying to break this down let's imagine
that you took a piece right
you've got to take
here let's imagine we're dropping with a
check king of eight
i'm missing it i know you're you're not
in time i'm not into i got no do i've
got no timing by the way i apologize to
our audience
the fifth element in chat oh yes that i
failed to say
and it overwhelms the first four the
fifth element is of course king position
oh yes it doesn't help if you're three
pawns up and you've got all the space in
the world when your king is getting
checkmated
and is christopher's king getting
checkmated no i wouldn't imagine so
but hey look when you're
when all you need is a draw and your
opponent is
throwing
you know like pieces at your king you
can get nervous uh what's going on
christian after knight g5 check is this
just a bluff she's completely lost it's
a bluff it's a complete total bluff oh
why is it such a bluff king g8 i mean
kg8 rook takes c5 and you don't even
have to go fancy with the move h6 as you
did but you can improve the position of
your pieces with knight d5 awesome
knight david five d5 space center
centralize the knight open up the
queen's action then i'm going to be
playing h6 next move once again you're
not in time you only uh are you're
attacking without two pieces truly one
and the knight on b1 and they're very
far away from the theater of this battle
h6 is going to come on the board that's
going to kick the knight away i have all
of the central files and uh central uh
squares controlled by my knight on c5 as
well as the presence of the knight on d5
this is just looking like a great
position for black and that knight from
d5 could potentially drop back to f6
later on and come back to defend the
king this is just looking like a piece
up for and let's not forget right now
the pawns are equal
you're going to take on e5 that's fine
you're going to be one pawn
for a knight that's just for a bishop
that's just simply not
not enough um
yeah christopher just needs a draw and
she's she's taking the full point home
yeah
she doesn't care about the draw she
wants the rating points as well
well she's swinging for the fences but
as you say that move knight d5 has just
taken all the steam right out of my
sails i wanted to say
that
boy i had tricks with queen h5 or or
things like that but that's nothing say
that h6 is a bad move by the way yes sir
i mean h6 is perfectly fine as well and
actually gives black a decisive
advantage as well but knight d5 is
actually even close it's just visually
cleaner yeah
so knight d5 c4 takes knight c3
again if i had two moves
only two moves rook e1 and rook e8
but uh um i'm trying to uh
get something going for carissa after
the move knight d5
takes uh uh c4 takes knight c3 i you're
you're not obliged of course to take on
c3
no trickies at all i mean no cheapos i
don't see them guys i i really don't i
mean knight g5 king to ga the king is
hiding you don't have a light square
action piece the bishop is no longer on
the border you just sacrificed it so how
do you get to uh the king on a g8 only
with the king oh a queen landing on f7
right but that's not happening anytime
soon right whenever you go for example
if you try to go queen to h5 i can go g6
right stop the option of that i have the
f3 square controlled by the bishop on b7
there's no way to hover around my f7
square it's the only square that you can
deliver checkmate from now
it makes the most sense that you
continue with rook takes e5 right but
once again knight to d5 the eighth rank
is controlled your many moves away one
maybe two and then finally you're ready
to play the move rook 38 and i'm going
to go knight f6 and that's going to be
shut down in the meantime i'm attacking
your knight with the move h6
it's just mathematically you're not in
time together also you cannot play moves
such as knight to e6 try to be more
aggressive because
whoops there's a knight landing on f4
with devastating consequences it's not
looking good uh and
it's even more worrisome that it's quite
easy to begin
there's the reach but
it doesn't seem like
the uh
the movement of his hand
g8 right right it looks more like look
at carissa
i mean
this behavior is disturbing
like
like do
do you uh have to
deal with this and the christopher's
looking around as well like
hey you want to help me
make my decision where is the king going
is it going to e8 or ga there we go yeah
and that's also the worst that's also
the worst is you're you're you're
nervous your opponent has this winning
move with the bishop yeah and your
opponent's hovering hand is around his
king oh yes okay and like you're
starting to think oh he's not moving the
bishop the king is a bad move and then
you grab the then he grabs the bishop
and makes the right move every time a
few times yeah apologies
every time andrew hovers it's like
then he finds the right move and it's
like so disturbing
it happens the best of us here and there
but
oh you have a confession yes i've done
that before my apologies
bad on you bad on you but um another
game that's i kind of uh we were talking
about advantage is going proof
yes i think
i think the kite down off game oh let's
uh jump to
seniors bishop h6 and i like that's what
about
the
we were talking about
well that was actually christian saying
yeah look let's play the obvious
developing moves night after you see you
don't have to
you're winning the game just think
thanks to your central pawn duo the
pawns on
d5 and e5 are so strong from a strategic
point of view you know you
you don't have to do anything crazy just
make normal develop
move moves like knight f3 bishop
exactly gregory said look i've got such
a great position
i can play the move knight e4 and is
that true
knight e4 and i believe knight e4 also
had a
almost a 20-minute thing
because gregory knows he's doing
something a little bit
maybe so what if i just attack the pawn
on an e5 how do you
uh i was thinking bishop f5
no no i was going to go with uh knight
d7 i apologize knight to
knight on on the eighth rank right just
because bishop f5 i was worried a bit
about knight d6
bishop d5 knight f5 bishop f5 knight d6
i was just trying to get my development
in this
as quick
i you know it's funny the knight on d6
is excellent it really is it's pretty
right it is it's a beautiful night and
nobody's says anything no doubts about
it but i was so worried about the night
getting to f6 it's almost a relief that
i persuaded you to go to a different
square knight d6 queen d7 advantage uh
white no question about it but it's sort
of like you know you're kind of
encouraging me i don't know to start
thinking about stuff
but you liked
pardon me christian knight to
i assume
i will defend the pawn with knight f3
after knight d7 yes knight f3 knight f3
and then what if we continue attacking
rook to e8 okay now
there aren't any
deadly
ideas of e6 right
um i don't think so
perhaps this is what he's striving to
achieve as white maybe the move e6 right
but does that work
i don't know it just feels like it could
be a knockout blow um
i don't have to take though right
oh i can go knight f6 maybe diagonal for
upon bishop is giving me some creeps
exactly yes what would you like to do
dorset not to open up not okay yeah
i got that part but uh you got to give
me a move
i also don't really feel that connected
to knight d6 because
i mean i'm i like that move what's wrong
with that move well
i want to find f6 okay
but i can't do that now either um
well e5 pawn is under attack might need
to do something
i'm not that's kind of why i'm like i
think knight e4 did a little bit of a
poof
but you're here you have to give me a
move
you can't just complain that you made a
bad move earlier you got to give me a
move
all right i'll choose knight d6 at least
knight d6 okay i don't feel e6
so you are worried about the diagonal
being open let me open the diagonal
knight takes e5 and if you take with the
knight
i will take with the rook
and i will
open
the diagonal
exactly exactly you can take with the
knight that is one way but you can even
start by taking with the ruler
i think this is even more powerful and
more potent yeah only because you're
forcing me uh to exchange this knife for
the bishop on c8 that's going to help me
to get the rook to c8 and then
potentially open up the position with
deadly consequences with the move c3 so
for example you can take take knight
takes c8 let's say rook takes c8 you
have really have to be worried about the
move c3 and you don't have enough time
to hide the king if you do go king to b1
sure i'll continue c3 i have all of my
pieces ready to deliver the checkmate
and deliver the devastating attack not
only that but if you take knight wave 4
queen is coming to b6 giving a check as
well knight coming to c3 you don't have
enough pieces that could potentially
defend your position you're still
playing without the oregon h1 without
the bishop on f1 and to be honest you
don't have any nice we hear this a lot
from coaches all around the world well
whenever you are under attack uh you
need to have a night next to your king
there's no nights
there is actually a couple of nights but
on the attacker's side you don't want to
see that of course this is just simply
devastating for white knight to e4 this
is the current position we have on the
board i have to say
this must be the thing that kaidanov
wants to see in the position he sees the
fact that after take take take you get
the knight coming to g5 there's this
open uh diagonal for example if you go
rook to e8 bishop takes c4 i think this
is what he's calculating bishop takes c4
you cannot take on c4 of course because
after queen to d5
yes sir we're going to see it we're
going to see it
we know this pattern everybody knows
this pattern
very beautiful checkmate he wants to
finish the tournament in this fashion
well
unfortunately i don't think uh his
opponent is going to cooperate in this
fashion and this is where he could
potentially decide uh sidestep from that
variation the one that we just
just saw with this move
after e6 just simply knight to f6 okay
this is what most likely we're going to
see on the board malinitsky
under some attack nevertheless right now
has his own chances but that is a
completely different type of exchange
sacrifice than the one you were showing
because in this case black's king is a
little exposed right christian you can
take on f7 and knight d6 check
and
white wins the exchange black has got
his own counter shots for sure but a
different position than
than everything
okay uh we're going to get uh dorso
getting ready for break and tell our
viewers what is on special for cue booty
well we do have something quite special
today so everybody knows bob the fisher
right of course and so this is the bobby
fischer ultimate chess man it's triple
weighted
handcrafted from boxwood and she sham
exactly now bobby fisher was very very
particular his
his tastes were incredibly accurate he
loved the stunt design which is what it
is but he also liked to tweak it a
little and i believe this was this maybe
it was the set that it was played on and
it's supposed to resemble
it's a yeah yeah it's a facsimile of the
icelandic chess set that was used in
iceland and that's 20 percent off oh
well actually as a thank you for
watching us
uh everybody gets 20 percent off of
regular price merch appeal chess sets
tournament everything you get 20 percent
off of everything
today only if you use the code champs
2020
wait nope not twice
sorry
[Music]
we're going to see you on the other side
of the break as we take a commercial
break
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states the st louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant central west
end has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique nonprofit
institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the us
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the u.s and world chess halls
of faint
cutting-edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the st louis chess campus visit
stlchesscampus.org
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
us juniors girls and seniors
championships well there they are
the fearsome fight fivesome as these
five players are all tied for first
in the seniors championships and who
will be champion because that's what
it's all about dorsa we will be crowning
three
new champions at at the end of today's
yes that is quite interesting because
four of those players are actually
paired against each other exactly
exactly and who will seize the day carpe
diem hello everyone and welcome back to
our live coverage of these round nine
games and i tell you some of our marquee
matchups have got us glued
including i was just going to say the
game of vladimir khopian versus nick
defermion
vladimir is one of our leaders nick is
doing very very poorly
but it's one of those positions
that is really really tough uh
from
a visual perspective white has a great
deal of space
also white was the first to connect the
rooks so from
from the point of view of space and
timing
blacks pieces are still
on the last rank they haven't even
gotten out of the barracks so you would
say oh advantage white all day every day
better
timing more space for white blacks in
trouble but then you look at it and you
say okay
where is black in trouble where exactly
are you going to attack
and you start looking around and saying
well maybe there aren't that many
targets conversely there is a very big
target
black has no doubt he's telegraphing
this knight is going to come to e6 the
bishop has already showed up on f6 he's
targeting this pawn on d4 and he's
asking questions himself so i'm saying
at first it looks like it's white all
day
but nick you know a little bit cagey
and you see on the
shot there
vladimir is digging into the board and
he's like hey man i know i'm better i
know i'm better i know better but where
is it how do i follow up how do i how do
i get an advantage and uh
he's
he doesn't look like he's ready to make
a move anytime soon so we're going to
keep an eye on this one we're going to
just jump to some of the other games
in the seniors yes we haven't taken a
look at uh dimitri garvich and larry
christensen that was a kind of a queen's
indian
turn bogo indian
with with this bishop b4 check at a5
and this is all theory players have
played this position for well i want to
say decades so
it's still theory um
yeah i want to say where's max uh
chavala versus max because that was much
more exciting much more interesting
queen
before a3 here christian was mentioning
all the reasons why white's getting
space and and the important move was
h2h3 and originally uh
christian was starting with uh moves
like g4 and knight h yes for going for
the two bishops as well as more advanced
more space
no
shabba said
let me let me hit your queen
but now that you didn't include the move
g4
uh
max turned the tables and said hey look
i'm not going to be my compliant self
i'm not just going to go back and let
you play moves like b5 and try to open
up the position no i'm going to be
uh ornery i'm going to hang around
and play queen f5 dorset thinking you
know when you're sure when you have
already done short castle and
like just playing g4 feels a little
lifting the command or exposing your
king yeah
i mean i don't know in this case because
the bishop is on g2 i don't i wouldn't
really consider that a pulling full for
fearless right you've got some
protection you got a second layer of
protection yeah i'm i mean i'm just
trying to come up with
why wasn't g4 played before
the move before i think it would have
been actually an important uh
inclusion i want to say play g4 and now
after the move b4 again as christian
christian
showed whether you go back to b6 or
whether you go back
to
d8 you're going back a little bit yeah
max said no i'm not going back i'm going
to hang around queen f5
and
after the move b5
max accepted the challenge he said
well
is that a pawn sacrifice you've just
made
i mean shabbat is noted for his tactical
prowess and he likes to play
these
i'm going to say coffee house attacks
but in truth they're quite deadly you
have to be very very aware
who was here yesterday who was saying
you know the great chess pl the great
player attacking players here
yes yes yes i think and he listed shabal
off larry christensen and nick defermion
all of these players are really really
capable of the attack
and here is a reminder
of our pairings and
what's going on dorsa yeah so then we
have three key match-ups
wow
right and
our people at five imagine they all draw
so we have a five-way play-off well
maybe even a six-way play-off because
there is one guy
our defending champion gregory kaidanov
at four and a half points if he wins
today could also get potentially a
six-way
uh tie for first you're not ready for
that
me either me or christian one play off
between two people is like the the max i
can do right now okay
okay we'll let them know that wonderful
uh christian what what's what about this
pawn sack well just to give you some
insights of what's happening in this
game
it does seem like taking on b5 is taking
a bull by the horns but unfortunately it
doesn't feel like it's the right
decision because
now this
long diagonal opens up instantaneously
and the bishop on g2 becomes a monster
and this is the whole concept behind
this pawn sacrifice with b5 all you want
to do as white is open up the light
square bishop now one way you can take
advantage of that is with the move queen
to d2 you uh would be wondering why
queen to d2 it doesn't seem like it's
attacking anything no but it actually
defends the bishop on f4 and now g4 is a
big threat you couldn't play g4 first
because queen takes f4 that's a problem
right you cannot do this
so first you defend the bishop with
queen to d2 and this almost forces
a reaction from black bishop to g6
knight to h4 that's very problematic of
course you take i take on g6 and this is
just pretty much a losing end game in
fact after bishop takes g2 despite the
fact that at this point you are two
pawns up with black after knight xb5
this is just devastating knight to c7 is
coming bishop takes b7 i'm going to
restore the material balance after a
death capture this is not looking good
and black has absolutely nothing and no
development this is the problem no
development on the king side huge
problem for black so queen to d2 well if
you have to take on f3 give up the
bishop pair and then how do you defend
on b7 it does seem like the only way out
or at least the only way to maintain
some sort of balance in the position is
to actually play the move g5 and seek
your own counter play
bishop takes b7 take on f4 give up the
exchange and pray pray that you have
some sort of an attack on the king's
side it doesn't look likely because my
knight will drop to e2 is going to
defend this i still
am ahead as white i have the material
advantage this seems to favor white now
quinto d2 is one of the ways queen to e2
is another way just to immediately put
pressure on the weakness on b5 this one
very very difficult for black
nevertheless still complicated we know
that shabbalov can make mistakes and if
you do make mistakes if you do give me
some time and
some tempes in order for me to develop
my bishop as well as castle get my king
to safety maybe i can get back in the
game as black
well christensen unfortunately it does
seem like uh the worst is behind him it
felt like it was much worse before and
as you guys were mentioning well maybe
knight takes e4 is not as
uh clear of a move as he should have
liked
play the move rook to c1 first okay keep
the tension as it is what is the bishop
doing on e4 not as much right now i mean
it's a beautiful piece very nicely
protected by the pawn and the knight
nevertheless keep the tension right
you're not in a hurry to exchange pieces
look to c1 and this prepares actually
knight takes e4 take on e4 and bishop
take c7 and then the pawn on c7 is under
attack so develop your pieces get uh
maximize the quality of your pieces
first you're not in a hurry yes right
this is what he should have done he did
not do it he played knight takes e4 and
now we have this position a lot of
things have changed this one is looking
closer and closer to a balanced and
maybe an equal position but
guys
what's happening in this one
carissa
has played and by the way they followed
the main line that we were discussing
right came to g8 rook take c5 and now
knight to d5 nicely spotted
by christopher eu and now karissa
responded with the move c4
and now we have h6 on the board now take
on d5 makes the most sense take on g5
and once again worst compensation
right i'm failing to see the
compensation knight to c3
queen to d6
b4 is a move as well i get it you have a
pawn and maybe in the best scenario
you're going to take another one on g5
that's still going to be a piece down
and the attack is not coming as swiftly
as you would like it to be because you
don't have pieces
so
i don't like karissa's chances in this
one it does seem like christopher you is
putting the final touches in his bid to
win the coveted title and he might be
going home with it now andrew hong on
the other hand he's trying his best but
unfortunately for him i don't think his
faith is within his grasp right now
absolutely he's looking back again and
going
oh dear oh dear oh dear oh things are
not looking that surprising not not
going very well what about uh sophie how
is she doing ladies please yes let's do
it
um okay uh talia
when we left it there was
the tension
between
the pawns and i was thinking that if i'm
in talia's shoes i'm ready to capture
this pawn and try to exploit the fact
there's a weakness on c6 uh sophie
recognizing yeah
i mean that is a day in danger uh played
the move uh c4 now these
this is in my opinion one of the most
difficult decisions
that a player gets faced with is after a
move like c4 do you play passively the
retreat bishop e2 which was chosen by
talia or do you say oh i know what i
want to do i want to play the move
bishop f5 and
i i'm an aggressive player
i am an attacking player and
i never retweet
forwards forward fours and i think this
is a very very difficult decision tell
you decided on the retreat bishop e2 and
what's going on in her mind she's
thinking
look
all of your pawns all of my opponent's
pawns are in light squares the light
squared bishop is a big pawn it's not an
aggressive piece my bishop on the other
hand on an ending can go and attack and
win your pawn so she's thinking
i don't want to play the aggressive
bishop f5 i want to play the retreating
move bishop e2 because in the long run
i've got the other bishop
this type of a judgment call oh you can
only make this with experience and study
you know you really really have to know
these positions she chose bishop e2
trade trade g6 b3 bishop queen d1 we're
up to date with the players
um i like white i think that white's
structure is very good long term
telia wants to target
these two guys sorry but no no i'm just
you had it
is this the type of position that
makes sophie happy because there surely
needs to
draw yeah to win the whole event
trying to figure out if that's something
that's how is talia feeling about her
position and her winning chances i think
talia's happy all right because uh she's
coming out of this with with these
long-term ideas her goal again if you
take
and i recapture her long-term goal that
is to say
talia who's white is to attack these two
pawns she's going to play rook to a6
queen to a1
and it's all about
attack
from
uh sophie's point of view where's her
counter play it's you it looks like it's
going to be based on the king side h584
maybe checkmate is it going to be based
on 94 in the center trading nights okay
you do
is
if you end up playing only the role of
defender
it's going to be a long afternoon for
her so you asked the very pertinent
question please uh yes sir where is your
attack right okay white's structure is
perfect right
right now it's going to be very
difficult to create any sort of attacks
if you take on b3 i take back with the a
pawn and that pawn on b3 actually is
going to be easily defended by a knight
landing on c5 right so
that was the critical moment when sophie
had the opportunity of creating a big
weakness with the move c takes d4 she
decided to go c4 which i don't think was
the right decision she takes d4 and then
follow it up with bishop takes g3 and
queen to b6 later on in the game so big
opportunity for her she did not take it
and right now the way i see the
structure it just looks damaged that
pawn on c6 is going to be the mark of
attack for white i'm going to double up
on the c file get the knight on c5 uh
corral that pawn with my pieces and at
some point well i think that pawn is
going to fall so
i'm
really liking talia's chances right now
despite the fact that maybe that was a
tame opening that talia employed and
maybe sophie did respond in the accurate
fashion with the move c5 right now right
it seems like talia is taking over
slowly
well again this is a game that jennifer
you is
looking at from the corner of her eye as
she says talia take care of business
let me try to take care of business as
well and boy what a game is going on
between anna marie and jennifer you at
the moment i'm
i
i didn't really like this opening choice
my life
for black
okay my
the way i see it valeo is having a bad
tournament yes
pretty terrible true and i i wouldn't
want to give my opponents the pleasure
of center and space and i would want to
make sure to play something that i give
her a lot of opportunities to make
mistakes right and if my opponents you
know just has an easy
center and easier developments and i'm
trying to find space for my pieces that
wouldn't be my ideal
way to um
i was going to torture my opponent
to win thank you that's
a better idea of winning yeah well as
bobby fischer famously said
to get squares you got to give them
that's the trade-off
as christian just said if you're black
and you need to win you're going to have
to take some risks so choose where
you're going to make your risk are you
going to play an open sicilian and risk
a double-edged position
jennifer whether she has a bad position
or a good position she's happy because
she's got
a position that's
you know full of fight well yeah not a
perk not necessarily a dream but it's
full of fight all the pieces the pieces
are full the borders full with pieces
there
there's a lot of things wrong with both
players positions this knight on h6 is
really kind of offsides but check this
out this knight on a4
is offsides
you could imagine i'm not saying it's
going to happen instantly you could
imagine a5 queen a7
bishop a6 bishop b5 and suddenly there's
a tickle
against this knight also if i put my
queen on a7 there's some issues maybe
maybe maybe with your so
what jennifer is going to try to do i
think is to exploit this night
let me offer another suggestion how
about this uh go ahead and punish
punish me or punish jennifer in this
case
uh i'll tell you
i'll telegraph what i'm trying to do i'm
trying to play rook a5 and yes if you
play b3
not asking uh a second question i'm
gonna sacrifice exchange i'm just saying
you know jennifer may not have achieved
her ideal but you know she's gotta win
with black it's tough she loves this
position guys she loves this she loves
this position in balanced position right
now anne marie velia only with 37
minutes again oh one minute oh yeah
there's some time difference as well i
mean look
jennifer this is what she wanted she
wanted a complicated battle and this is
exactly what she's getting it's a
complicated battle forget about the
engine eval right now it's saying 0.2
it's irrelevant right 0.2 is pretty much
just saying this position is balanced
right now but who has the better
understanding of the position of the
complications who has the better feel of
these type of situations and that
undoubtedly is jenny for you and even in
this tournament i mean there is a 300
rating point uh difference between these
two ladies but also in the score you see
anne marie vela as you uh pointed out
dorsa only one and a half points in this
tournament against a surging jenny for
you she won her last i believe two games
she lost and then she won back-to-back
games to get within striking this oh i
have to the leader sorry to interrupt
you valera only one points actually
only one point not even one point and a
half yes from what i'm seeing on um from
my end
it is yeah she she hasn't been having a
great event we know that at this point
she just wants this tournament to be
over and jennifer is saying no this
tournament is not over for you until i
say so i'm going to put as much pressure
on you from an early stage of the game
as possible and anna's eyes there boy
she's really looking a little terrified
i wanted to ask you also christian about
the most straightforward so i'm in
jennifer's shoes and the things i always
look at are checks and captures so
imagine that jennifer just begins with
the capture correct now if you take
let's start if you recapture with the
pawn i capture again if you recapture
with the pawn
uh rook to beat
four starts to look a little interesting
suddenly like this knight doesn't have
many squares knight to b2 and you start
to think oh
there
there are some cheapo tactics that might
work um
coming across the board
do i do it with
this capture like if i could get a
situation like this where i'm trying to
play knight takes e5 and get a check
along this
um problem is if you simplify the
position and you eliminate the tension
in the position as well i start having
my own play as well so for example after
rook to b4 all the way to
where we got it
now i don't have to retreat with the
knight i can play the move queen to c2
and that offers the queen trade do you
want to go there as jennifer in this
situation no
absolutely not because uh after that my
space advantage and the fact that
without the queens you cannot really
tackle my pawns as easily well it's not
going to be a good position no queen too
i'm not interested in uh trading queens
i like to keep the tension uh a lot
we'll keep an eye on this one back to
christopher you for a moment because
this could decide
this event right away i think it's uh
is it bad a little bit yeah
[Laughter]
just a little bit
and
uh when when we left it we left it at c4
christopher played h6 takes takes
knight d2
what to say it's a whole piece right
thanks
it's brutal no i'm sorry this is this is
this doesn't seem to be
anything anything at all bishop takes
take the pawn
cement the
cement the piece oh maybe even a rook h6
trip i was going to say just keep it
there for
come
but uh across
looks very very good for christopher he
seems to be cruising and again you know
he had that slip up but let's face it
it's a monster score
that he has in this event
and uh well you know without that slip
up that he had earlier in the tournament
uh
you know he he's put together a great
event against a very difficult field
featuring a 2700 player wunder liang
again this tournament
is a qualifier for the u.s championships
coming up in october later this year
where he will go up against
world-class opposition
and uh
christopher's feeling it i mean
he's almost got this in his grasp but
you know who else is feeling it right
now it's alexander chabalov he is right
now a lion on the prowl right now
because check this out
d5 was the move we were looking at queen
d2 queenie two some uh pre uh
tame moves right no no no this is alex
shabalov that we're talking about you
see this move d5 come your way as maxim
lugi so much pressure being applied by
alexander chabalov and you know that
he's in shape right now he just took
down the leader larry christensen and
this is his type of position that is the
problem alexander chabalov loves to
attack in this wild fashion d5 came on
the board
engine is saying this actually loses the
advantage but forget about that because
the best move in the position seems to
be the move a6 you're not even looking
at that side of the board at least the
way i see this position i'm not even
looking at making a6 at playing the move
a6 on the board with this pawn on d5
ready to take on e6 and destroy my pawn
structure
this is a very difficult defense right
now for maxim lugian any move at any
corner at every corner in this position
could potentially be fatal for him so
his uh he's in trouble
excuse me and thank you uh by the way
you
were looking at queenie2 and queen d2
christian i
say look i know this guy shaba very well
he's a coffeehouse rough rough
coffeehouse player
d4d5 is in his arsenal of tricks i liked
i i would have guessed that uh shabba
would have played that move you're
looking at this move huh you're yeah you
you're absolutely right if i'm in max's
shoes
i'm thinking bishop c5 and let's exit
i'm thinking development bishop c5 is a7
a6
not on my radar no way
and check this line out now you would
see d5 another
potential move is e5 right e5 yeah
are you looking at that movie five at
all uh
no
i would have been i would have been
fearful no rookie one no no no maybe
bishop to d6 and king to e7 and just
defend like that
uh so what
perhaps perhaps yeah bishop to d6 yes i
takes b5 and k maybe that's a bit maybe
that's a bit too much rook to e1 is is
decent but i guess
what about come on e1 forget about it
okay forget about what the engine is
saying d6
this is shabbalov right right right here
he says his position he sees the move d6
as an opportunity he will play rook two
you wanna have okay sure it's it's the
natural move the one that you see first
but then you see this move d6 we could
be seeing some incredible fireworks wow
this one i'm definitely going to keep an
eye on it well uh the brilliancy so far
the brilliant tournament so far in my
mind is the game that andrew
uh hanged one where he went like knight
g3 knight f3 he was sacrificing his
knights
knight f3 check knight takes e3 but if
we see d6 in this game uh we'll hold the
rew
we'll hold the trophy for just a moment
to see the outcome uh d5 and again the
move a7 a6
wow that's the best the best move in the
position it
wouldn't be on my radar
i'm just thinking if i don't if
the way i try to justify a6 is if knight
takes b5 it's being followed by knights
going to c7 and clear i mean i i hate
getting checkmated but i also hate the
prolonged death they're okay
so
if knight takes b5 knight takes knight
going to c7 happens that's just gonna i
i don't think there's any saving it
after that no of course not so that was
why i wanted to get my king out of a
dodge bishop all right c5 knight takes
b5 castles and yeah you can go 97 you
can do whatever you want you can go
knight d4 but at least for the moment
you know i've saved my
uh chinny chin chin and i got out of i
got out of dodge but a7 a6 that is greed
holding
and uh well a great game going by the
way great yes yes but uh after a6 rook
to e1
right and again guess what the movies
if you say long castles it is long ah
no way
i know castle and by the way long castle
is the only move right position to keep
the balance
good luck playing these moves a6
followed by long castle well check his
pockets if he uh plays these next two
moves arbiter
calling on the arbiter
yes
years ago when i was like
like a
second grade and i was just getting more
comfortable playing more chess um we
went to this tournament team events um
and
we wanted to make long castle but there
was a bishop on f4
and uh
square b8 was controlled so
i made lancaster and my opponents
stopped the clock and told the arbiter i
made it illegal i was like i no it was
not illegal
b8 square right but the uh i was forced
that was declared illegal oh the arbiter
said that you and she your your your
opponent was correct in her collection
so you castle scary
right
the the bishop
the bishop controls the v8 square the
rook yes passes yes through the control
of the square but according to the rules
the move castles is a move with the king
yes so it doesn't matter that the rook
passes through a controlled square it
matters if the king does and in this
case
you're right but by the way your
question to the arbiter is not unique in
fact victor korchnoy he was playing in
the soviet championships he's one of the
top grand masters in the world and his
opponent who was white had a rook on b1
and the b file was open yeah
so victor went to the arbiter and asked
is castling permitted because the b8
square is protected the arbiter said yes
and victor castle later his opponent
oh gosh i'm not too sure who it was uh
it was a little bit uh
annoyed
uh because victor had gotten information
from the arbiter like what i i don't
know i mean it was weird but yes castles
uh while your opponent controls b8 is
available no i just thought that was
hilarious that um
well then i'm glad i have the question i
started to back me up exactly you're not
the first uh d5 do we have any moves
christian uh no i don't think we do okay
and he moves right now he's still
thinking after d5 and take a look at
what dimitri guravich did okay
maybe you can maybe we can see on that
board or that's fine we'll i'll take it
over g4
he played the move gymnastics position
but
we have the hanging pawns we know that
the strategy generally revolves around
attacking the hanging pawns right and he
goes for g4 weakening the king's
position apparently this is uh really a
move in the wrong direction because h6
which was played yeah automatic
automatic move you want to weaken your
position even more with h4 i don't think
you want to do that between 8 queen to
b7 rook 38 for example and if you
continue then i just simply go knight to
h5 this actually looks really bad
for white you cannot do
such things for example if you go queen
to g4 g6 and guess what the big threat
is
knight takes f2 you have to be very
careful with that move so for example
rook takes d5 knight takes f2 if you
take on f2 queen to e3 king to f1
rook to e4 and we see the queen being in
grave danger right now in the position
h3 knight to f4 is coming as well h6 is
on the board
larry christensen 45 minutes and dmitry
gorevich really spent a lot of time on
these last couple of moves right now
with only 35 minutes four on the board
h4 is on the board he's going straight
into that variation nevertheless
rook f8 makes some sense right put some
pressure and attack this idea of knight
takes f2 that's a big one in the
position
i despise this idea of g4 and h4 it's so
aggressive
lifting the kimono
rookie eight is a great move there's no
question that rookie 8 has my seal of
approval is h5
i'm trying to punish white for for over
his transgressions if you will h5 h5 is
a move
yeah
he knows better than this he knows that
uh he's not just a
instead of g4 knight d2 would have been
the tame move that
everybody would play even including dima
g4
he's he's misjudged something here
because this is just it can't be good
for white and larry knows it
larry is beginning you see he's you see
him sensing uh something going on here
wow okay
um ladies yes ladies please increase my
mind thank you
getting excited
oh talia's got what she wanted yeah see
i i i b3 takes takes this is h5 doesn't
like could i just play a5 first so you
don't get funny or okay six stuff then i
play h5
either way you've got weaknesses on the
queen side that you're gonna have to
deal with uh a5 does stop rook a6 and
posting up and i'd like it from that
perspective um
could i
i'm trying to think should i
should i just get
my majors lined up uh on
the the pawn so okay let me play rook a4
let's just all right
and h5 right something like what happens
in the game queen d2 so i'm going to get
my majors lined up and i'm eyeballing
this guy you also have the b3 that's all
weak so might give up a5 get b2 i'm not
trading because i can i i can i can
defend
the pawn on um
b3 easily uh even i could have started
with the move rook a3 just to defend the
pawn and so i'm i'm really am targeting
but the the the bottom line is uh as we
say is where where is black's counter
play uh sophie is basically with the
move h5 has played in the game
intimating that she's looking at 94 and
h5h4
and to try to get the attack but
christian said it really really well
um let's imagine
i gave you this position and i said what
are
the
probabilities
of a successful attack
against white's king
in this position and the correct answer
is very low
there are a lot a lot a lot of defenders
there's a lot of palace guards around
the king so when you see what happened
in the game rook a6 rook c8 we're caught
up
what are the probabilities that this
attack will be successful
very low in the meanwhile well this guy
this guy that's what talia's going to do
she's just going to
take them
well
i paused
and see because the pawn is hanging she
can take it right away yes but
talia is one of my great friends and was
my slow teammate and everything right
so i want her to win clear but i don't
want to play
you don't want to play not a three-way
play-off oh
my way now maybe
okay but just remember dorsa in every
life a little rain must fall and you may
be here till uh
dinner time
let's say christian what do you have for
us guys yes i want to ask you a question
please
what's the situation in christopher
versus charissa's game because things
are not as clear to me we thought
christopher had it in the bag that's
what i thought as well but right now
check the last move made by christopher
and the opportunity that that
opens up for carissa he just played the
move g4
what
yes that's fine if you take on g4 i'm
probably going to continue with bishop
takes d5 support which he should have
done by the way instead of g4 bishop
takes d5 support the bishop with the
pawn on c6 and just have a completely
winning position
right
now he plays this move g4
but let's start looking at variations
after knight to d4
that knight is coming and it's coming
fast to f5 e7 and that's a check once
you see that check you start panicking
exactly because the king goes to the f
file i go rook to f5 you get check made
it close to it
how do you defend after knight to d4 if
you take on d5 bishop takes d5 then i
have knight to f5 once again and karissa
is looking up karissa is sensing
something is wrong right now right in
the position she's sensing that g4 went
astray and now she has actually her own
chances after knight to d4 i feel a
disturbance in the force
uh g4 and by the way she still works but
she's getting something right she's
getting some complications in the
position this is what she was dreaming
about when she sacrificed that bishop
exactly and she's getting it right
knight d4 uh
it's a hundred percent kind of a move
because just what you're saying uh your
piece down what are you looking to do
attack the king
how can you attack the king well you can
attack the king with rook
e8 check which just forces trades which
are not going to be in your favor or you
could attack the king by getting your
knight to e7 it's impossible all right
that knight that was on b1 but now it's
going to d2 f3 might come to d4 maybe f5
maybe e7
right
making a way to e7 that just
no way
and yet here it is knight to d4 i'm
almost even i i don't like it but i l
but that night coming to
fi that's so terrifying i almost
reaching for the g6 bond here correct
correct work it's terrifying forget
about the assessment right you are one
draw away from winning the title exactly
and then you see this night starting to
get around your king it is terrifying
and that's when nerves come into play
right i think this is what we're seeing
from christopher you may be a slippage
in his usual very calm demeanor right
now
okay and the times dorsa um
i believe curses 25 minutes uh
christopher's oh 53.
okay very significant as we've seen
throughout this tournament carissa is
usually behind
uh her opponent's on the clock is
very very common
for her
but
again
20 minutes see what she did against
brandon uh jacobson was go down to two
and critical moment and she just didn't
have the time to find queen d6 jack and
bishop a6 here she's got 20 minutes she
she's she's got time to play knight to
d4
does but you know she knows also that
the position doesn't finish after knight
to d force no it does to play fast
exactly she really needs to speed things
up because we're at move 23 there's
plenty of moves plenty of difficult
moves to make after knight to d4 yes so
let's wait and see maybe we can look at
some of the lines on your board yasser
and try to figure things out and let's
stay with this one until she makes a
move because i'm really curious to see
whether she will find the move knight to
d4 take on g4 which will uh uh be quite
submissive i have to say taking on g4 is
not going to be the right exactly as we
get ready for our break let's just take
a review for everybody our current
standings let's start with the ladies
and why our marquee match-up games uh
dorset it's so great yes sir well sophie
moore suzuki
isn't clear first she needs to well not
lose yes that's it she needs to score
and she will be our champion and she is
being followed very closely by jennifer
you and talia cervantes so she's got to
win her opponent today being talia and
in the juniors
and the juniors christopher you
six and a half points another one point
leader yep he's being followed by andrew
honk but see both christopher and sophie
they just need to not lose exactly if
they make a draw that's it their
champion they can go home pop it away
actually no never mind they're below 21.
no champagne for you
open the popcorn and in the seniors and
yes
in the seniors um
five-way tie very well
and um
two before the player i want to say
they're matching up uh
four of the players with five points are
matching up today and we're going to
take a break and we're going to see you
all on the other side of the break
[Music]
st louis university celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st louis
slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe
in 2015 slu partnered with the st louis
chess club to start a top-tier
collegiate chess team on the very first
year of the teen's inception slu
obtained second best university at the
pan american intercollegiate chess
championships
higher purpose
greater good
st louis university
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascensioncharityclassic.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri is steeped in tradition the
recently founded mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the university of
missouri and the st louis chess club
collegiate jess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of excellence
mizzou has always strived for the best
mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institution's
ethos of respect responsibility
discovery and excellence to the
chessboard
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and welcome back everybody to our live
coverage of the three national
championships the girls the juniors the
legends also known as the seniors here
we are in the playing hall at the
beautiful st louis chess club and
scholastic center
straight down the street on the central
west and be sure if you're in town to
visit as you see all 15 games in combat
as this is the final round dorsa uh
things are definitely
i'm seeing a lot of enjoyable games all
right and one game that's just throwing
me
you know off off my stride is the game
of carissa yep
versus our tournament leader in the
junior section
christopher u
as the position
blowed up after g4 we were expecting
carissa to play the move knight d4 we
thought after knight d4
well she is going to harass
um christopher's king she took a
different approach it went knight g5 i'm
not sure this was the right move by
christopher he captured the pawn and he
all this stuff happened very quickly too
before attacking the knight christopher
said i'm not interested in defending my
knight
took on g2
carissa captured the knight
uh christopher said i'm not interested
in moving my queen
bishop takes
d5
may i introduce a threat of checkmate in
one people
exactly karissa said okay in that case
i'm not going to take your queen i'm
going to play the move f2 f3
making it possible for me to play king
takes g2 queen is hanging
both kings are vulnerable
but
crazily enough after queen takes c5
check king takes g2 it might just be one
of those cases where black's king
is even more vulnerable than white's
king even though the h file please
what's the material yeah exactly i'm
glad you asked i've got two pawns you
got four if i'm
looking at from your point of view you
you it's short christopher is up two
pawns
but it's about the king position sorry i
i just remember christopher was up a a
piece
for one pawn and completely winning he
ate
four pawns right
and
[Music]
lost a number of pawns along the way as
well so here he took one
he took two okay he took three uh-huh
he took four well i got one he did not
take on c5 yet oh sorry he did not take
on c and is that the best move oh no no
this position is wild i mean okay there
are so many ways in which you can play
and all of them have
a very different details and nuances uh
queen takes e5 in fact is not as good as
65
king takes g2 of course and then
well a lot of pcs are still left on the
board you still have to worry about uh
that pin on the bespond d5 also you have
to worry about all sorts of rook to e8
coming at the right moment
it's not an easy position for
christopher with the title on the line
he must be beating himself up
about relinquishing his advantage just
like that he's still ahead definitely
still in poor position to take the full
point home
but it's not easy at all right now
should he be considering the move queen
h6 no as as desirable as queen h6
to h1 checkmate
you can't give up
your own uh back rank
checkmate and that was all these players
hovering around yes
the vultures would have been out in
force
if carissa lands rookie eight but again
give me some uh
best lines of play after queen takes c5
check king takes g2 should black just
stop and play c7 c6
no what no
rook to h6 seems to be the right move
rook to h6 correct makes not a lot of
sense
oh you're protecting you
go
g6 i think
so one of the
one of the ideas in carissa's position
is she would with the rook on h8
she she has this as a vision
and then with the rook on h she would
have the move queen e6
yep
so that's why rook h6
he took on c5 and she immediately took
on g2 the best move the only right
position
critical moment right now how are you
going to continue your defense so rook
h6 is a key move rook h6 is a good move
it's not the key move and maybe we can
keep an eye on him because
it did seem like he was uh hovering once
again hovering and trying to play a move
let's see i have to ask her
i see that hand he's is christopher
gonna get a quote-unquote anonymous
letter
if i had his address the answer would be
yes brandon is looking at the position
he's like what are you doing man i
thought you were a piece up right now
you're facing checkmating threats in the
position right like what's happening i
think all of us as chess players started
with the hovering
and then later as we matured we stopped
doing that
christian when were you told stop
hovering
well my coach was always telling me uh
the same story that you were mentioning
putting your hands underneath your butt
right pretty much uh on the chair and
just waiting until the last moment to
make the move uh sit on your heads
basically so you were pretty young when
you were i was never doing it i was like
yeah yeah
okay i was hovering as well a little bit
um but as i matured i indeed tried to
correct that exactly because it's quite
important to correct it um also from a
psychological point of view i feel
whenever you see your opponent hovering
like this being unsure about his
decisions it gives you a grain of
confidence right as your opponent and uh
i i didn't want to give that to my
opponents exactly see i was
i had a different experience because um
you know i was taught to be as tricky as
possible when i was a kid and
i later on i realized ooh that's not
very nice you don't
know your coaches are
ill-advising you it's
it was it was all about the win right it
was about kicking and biting and now
well ben franklin ben franklin one of
the founding fathers of the united
states wrote a book the morals of chess
the morals of chess by ben franklin and
in that book
he advised
to keep your opponent's wine goblet full
and to play with your back to the sun so
that the sun was always in the eyes of
your opponent so ben franklin a little
bit tricky he wasn't looking for equal
and fair conditions but i was always
about that equal and focused no i have
to learn my own way how to yeah i'm sure
that i don't like you know like
chew gum or why
the little things that bother me i made
sure not to do them to the opponents
later exactly exactly i was very very
lucky i had
in my career a lot of great teachers
shout out to colleagues fredrik nikolic
wolf anderson
john nunn
alexander beliavsky
anatoly karpov because these guys at the
board
were exquisite perfect manners perfect
they never ever ever
wanted to do anything that would disturb
their accounts because they wanted to
beat you fair and square that was their
attitude nice exactly they didn't need
tricks and if you if you had to use a
trick
you weren't a good player the one thing
that i remember always bothered me was
in like a wooden floor oh the creaking
wooden floor
but also the heels like sometimes you
know guys also have shoes that has a
little bit like the fancier shoes the
more formal shoes
female or male heels
i know and coming to the board and
leaving the board
and that's why we got carved because
guess what the the tony rich he's an
expert chess player
he says i know exactly what you're
talking about doors i don't want to hear
any of those heels uh on the floor uh
take us away christian what what of our
marquee matchup games has caught your
eye a lot of things are happening in all
sections and uh i was looking through
the senior sections
that move bishop to c5 that you were
recommending
was played on the board in this game
between shabbat and maxim bishop
and go for the castle right yeah the
king out of the center well
unfortunately that uh gives white the
advantage this is the position we
currently have on the board after castle
knight to d6 wait a minute not bishop to
d6 so this is what we were looking at
bishop to d6 right now if you take take
and at least you don't have this move
queen to d5 because that allows the
queen trade and i'm just going to be
nursing a better end game in that
situation better structure not yet a
pawn up but you have a lot of weaknesses
after uh this exchange b7 is a weakness
e6 is a weakness after knight to d4
knight on d5 is also quite unstable not
looking good for black so
uh he did not do that he played the move
knight to d6 but perhaps this was not
the correct move because now queen to d5
if you do take knight takes d5 this is a
completely different situation right now
you have knight takes f4 that you have
to worry about and you cannot move the
uh bishop back to d2 you're losing the
knight on f3 or the knight on d6 you
have to take on b7 but how is this
position i mean this cannot be better
for
white right now so a completely
different scenario queen to d5 is on the
board and it seems like maxine lugi
the worst is behind him and right now
maybe he's getting ready to take over
the initiative very interesting game
this one let's take a look at what's
happening in the ladies section as well
because
things have changed in the game between
talia and sophie maurice suzuki i think
we left it somewhere around here right
this is what happened h5
launching an attack on the king side you
have to do something we were wondering
and you were asking door signs well do
you think her chances are good to uh
attack on the king side probably not
right but she's trying right and she has
to do it because otherwise she would
just be losing on the queen side that's
the problem rook to c8 give up a pawn
sure but at least try to get something
in return knight to g4 followed by h4
has to be the plan queen to g5 bishop
takes f5 g takes f5 this is what we have
right now on the board 22 minutes for
talia she's falling behind on the clock
right now with 17 moves to go 31 minutes
for sophie mori suzuki and an attack
coming h4 is coming and you don't have
as many pieces left on that side of the
board that will be able to defend you as
white so you do have to be paying close
attention to what you're doing in the
next few moves this one is going to be
very interesting oh i have a question um
so i see that sophie doesn't she's a wfm
so i'm wondering would she be scoring
any norms here at w-i-n oh i'm sure she
is you do not start anytime
six out of six
without saying i've arrived uh give me
some kind of recognition that she does
have seven out of eight so i'm sure
she's scoring
yeah i'm sure she is scoring
would
a
norm
very nice for her right
i just wanted to turn our attention to
pedro espinosa versus andrew hong
andrew of course needs a win he needs
carissa to win and he's in there with a
shout the reason i'm making uh the
comparison is look at the pawn structure
uh that uh pedro has and look at the
pawn structure
that um
talia has it's the same one right
pawns on d4 e3
f2
g3
g2
the big difference is that black has a
lot more pieces on the board
then does sophie
white has not broken through
he hasn't taken a pawn on asap the files
are relatively closed that is to say
andrew has one weakness yes
you can double up against that weakness
but i can defend it with knight b8 if
i'm desperate in the meantime there are
a lot of pieces on the king's side and
andrew's chances of breaking through on
the king side are much better than a
sophie's
so i just
just saying keep keep an eye on that i
wanted to go to the carissa game
guess what
christopher
has mixed some questionable decisions
with some really good ones he's just
played the good move rook h6 we'll keep
our eye on that dorsa where would you
like to take us i think that kind of
changed the jennifer uga absolutely both
of our seniors please let's do it oh
that's the uh larry christensen's game
and the jennifer you game again this is
the game of talia we're kind of
expecting
well if i go
queen f3 i basically i want to bring my
queen over to the king side so that
every time you play h4 i take and put my
queen on h3 and i'll block the attack
i'm sure talia is also wanting to bring
her knight defensively but again h4 is a
move that you've got to respect yes
let's put it like that but you wanted
jennifer you what has happened okay i
said that that in anna marie's
shoes i would be worried about this
knight
on a4
jennifer decided to capture on d4
capture and bishop to b7
bishop to d2
okay anna's thinking look if i can
put my rook on c1 i'll rescue my knight
queen
whoa
knight b6 i am not a fan of this move
i'm getting a little claustrophobic
feels for the queen
well not just that i'm just sitting
sitting there saying
look your your goal strategically
speaking is not to trade off your
opponent's weak piece
and the move knight b6 is a real
concession there might even be a
tactical
refutation to knight b6 but i really
don't like the way jennifer has played
this christian uh this looks
to my eyes to be wrong it is
it is wrong yes absolutely well not
necessarily uh knight to b6 in uh
itself but the whole concept of getting
that pawn on b4 kind of stuck there on
that diagonal always a3 on tap the
center is still very compact for white
you don't have any way to destabilize it
you don't want to play the move f6
because e6 is going to come in most
instances
she hasn't done the right things she was
supposed indeed to potentially exchange
uh the b pawn but not the c pawns and
she
in fact exchanged the c points and kept
the b pawns on the board
it's not the right situation for uh
black that is and right now what we have
on the board i mean what if i just
simply go
a3 for example right well also i just
wanted to say that
as well there's a lot of ways in this
position the move c5 takes d4 is
egregiously wrong because just what
happened
uh this rook on b8 just
raised its hand and said excuse me
excuse me what is my motivation
precisely you you you were supposed to
play b4 take c3 so that
this rook on v8 it's extended the file
is extended and it it controls the open
b file when you keep the tension as it
is on the c file exactly and when you
don't
trade off the pawn then the rook on b8
is not as well placed
furthermore again tactically a2 a3
uh just ask the question
if you want to take
pause for a second because i've got both
pawn takes
as well as bishop
let's put this guy takes i assume
jennifer's gonna drop back
with her queen in this case
and takes and
if i'm in white shoes i am thrilled
that i've solved my offsite night i
don't know about anything else but i've
solved my problem and i came out of it
with an extra pawn
i've got to be happy after a tree
jennifer played bishop takes bishop
on
what is okay one more back oh excuse me
here so jennifer took bishop takes
bishop i'm
definitely taking that okay can i just
d5 and try to trade things off
very nice okay good good good good
because for a moment there i was
thinking that boy jennifer has has blown
it badly that's a big difference i have
missed this i have a flat out missed
this i agree with your assessment that
you know the work on b8 kind of got a
little um
shaky yeah it wasn't uncomfortable a
moment ago it was doing great things and
now it's less so but even so uh thanks
to this move queen d5 i thought that uh
that uh you which kind of begs the
question that after the move b3
uh
in knight b6 why she just
didn't say okay thank you for helping me
solve my my problems and moves have been
made bishop takes queen takes
and
well
i still think
in this case thanks to queen d5 that's a
such an important move gosh
long broadcast but do you want to play
queen d5 when you have to win no not
necessarily not at all uh christian
they're forced to win right now and
she's right
she's only playing for first position
she doesn't care about anything else
exactly exactly and trading queens and
trading bishops
wasn't on her agenda but i know
something went wrong right
right that's that's exactly the way i
feel let's go just again did they tell
you tell your game for a moment
knight b
one okay i have to ask okay is that my
trying to go like d2 f3 e5 but even if
it gets to e5 my other knight is there
oh h
h4 so black's entire
play
is based on sacrifices
as well as the move h4 and if i could
magically teleport this night to the
oops gosh darn it if i could put this
knight on h4 it's game over
strategically you resign
it's so bad because your pawn structure
you're upon down black is upon down and
your pawn structure on the king's side
is doubled and split and ooh isolated
the knight on h so everything is based
on can
black
get enough play with the move h4 now i
think
as much as you would like to play knight
f3 in one move you definitely don't want
to reach this position this we've all
seen and uh
in our puzzle games we
don't go queen h2 check we first go
queen takes f2 check and then we then we
go back and chase the king
probably
i was wondering if you can make a direct
checkmate probably
maybe
you can see why i'm not good at puzzle
rush
something very close to me
you can see why i'm not that great at
puzzle rush but
i think that uh that talia is ready and
able and willing to play the move queen
f3
and
uh if you for example wait just half a
half apply i've got this defensive move
queen h3
i don't see any breakthrough moves for
so let's go king g7
oh i like that i like that that keeps
that keeps the action going
that's where i want the checkmate right
yes can i pressure you with queen f4
[Music]
it looks like the queen h5 yeah okay so
now i can take take i've got the square
covered and you've got to take otherwise
queen g5 and maybe g3 take credit
okay so
how is it
ooh
f3 allowing me to
well at the moment i'm not allowing
united takes e3 your queen
would be hanging
rook h8 i don't see them there's not a
follow-up there's not the i
i
i'm like the cold-blooded machine you
know the the machine doesn't see
checkmate the engine says uh so but that
was important uh
what you pointed out there dorsey though
very nasty
little move queen f4
so let's try to find something better
for black right besides if there is
anything better well maybe there's
something similar
so what's the difference right now i
don't know i i i i really don't know i
think uh
there is no difference maybe i know but
let's let's keep going so king g7 queen
f4 we we need to find something better
queen to h5 felt like the right decision
but it did okay now and i've got a huge
big problem i would love to play rook to
e4 but exactly
such an annoying move exactly and if we
did go
for this our queen a moment ago was on
f3 but now
that it's been magically
uh
put on the f4 square i can defend
h2 and play the move f3 uh everything is
by a tempo christian it's it's just
checked it i just took no cigar we
such a difficult calculation actually so
we uh did go uh for the best variation
in the position now the problem is we
stop too early rook to e4
oh
well i take and then i get the other
rook to h8 and you don't have a way to
stop me from well you can indeed after
rook takes f7 king takes f7 and in fact
this is some sort of equality
not with queen takes f5 because king 37
seems to be blocking all the checks and
after that you're lost so looking to e7
queen f7 king d8 and this is a problem
uh you cannot stop me from check meeting
you so you have to go point to c7 and
this is just a draw after king to g8
queen to c8 we have some sort of a
perpetual crazy variation wow crazy
variation to see this from all the way
up and maybe this is what she calculated
after this knight to p1 maybe she looked
at this she spotted this queen to f3
queen to f4 very nice maneuver and she
thinks she's in time now this is a big
moment for sophie if she manages to
calculate all those variations well then
she's in good she's in a good position
but if she doesn't then knight to d3
knight to f uh three knight to h4 is
coming and it's coming quickly right
next move if you make rook to e6 for
example knight to d2 and that's it your
attack dies
your attack dies on the spot and you are
still upon down let's not forget that
exactly i haven't forgotten
i know you didn't i know you didn't yes
i'm not enamored with the move knight b1
that doesn't do anything
of merit
for the king side and in fact um
it does though it's just because you go
90 tonight f3 i mean you have a clear
plan and sometimes look it's better to
have a plan than a bad plan than to not
have a plan at all bad plans are better
than no plans and if a bad means that
black has to calculate everything and
see rookie four at the end right sure
i'll take it you know i'll take the
chance of you calculating perfectly and
going all the way to rookie 4 and making
a draw good luck if you can do that
bravo congratulations you won the
tournament but if you cannot
well you're running out of time slowly
but surely 23 minutes for sophie
17 minutes and she needs to find a move
right now well don't forget that talia
is the one who needs to win yes so if we
get the position back but i'm in a
winning situation right now if you don't
do something major because i'm a pawn up
and i have the better structure exactly
but instead of the move knight b1 a move
that
i just find
discouraging let's say uh how about
queend f3 now that just puts the kibosh
completely on h4 you're going to take on
e3 there's no question you're going to
take on e3 absolutely knight takes e3
and
wonderful and
this
f takes rook takes
queen takes queen takes rook takes
somewhere i can imagine in
a world
of four rooks uh we're going to make a
draw but how about after knight takes e3
i just moved my rook i'm not even sure
where i want to move my rook i'll move
my rook let's say to the square b1 and
if i can play knight to e2 to f4
strategically i've won the game it's
that's what it's about i go back to yeah
i give up the pawn
i give up the bond and i try to
uh stop the attack
you don't i go queen d2
yeah i don't stop oh this is sounding
like
oopsie doopsie
so you have to take on f5 and then
things get complicated oh my gosh so i
have to go queen f4 instead oh but
that's not what you want that's not what
i wanted to do not what you want no look
i was trying to get my knight on c3 to a
better spot but b1 is a good move you
like it trust me it's a good i'm not a
fan i i don't think so
sophie has a very hard task ahead of
herself to find all these only moves and
if she doesn't knight d2 knight f3 is
coming dorsal this is your moment to
bail me out and say you're right yes sir
i feel your angst i'm naturally
connecting with knight b1
but right thank you there you go this is
not the type of position i would play to
you know to go for a win but okay
uh again you guys are ganging up no no
no no i don't like this h4
let's do this again h4 queen f3 king g7
these are huge moves here uh
queen f4 queen h5 let me take the pawn
threatening you exactly hugo queen ticks
i go f3
because i see that rook is coming and i
want to eliminate the knight so that
i've got king f2 you came up with a
stupendous idea it's ridiculous of rook
here
and
it feels
ridiculous
like like how can this exactly be and
you make a draw because you take on f uh
a seven at the end and then queen to c7
so i don't want to make a draw i don't
see this rookie 4 from afar that's what
i'm trying to make okay how about this
rook takes f7 check
king takes f7 i have to take
queen takes f5 check
king has to guess that no no no no go on
the other side
go on the other side oh sorry i guess
king seven thank you so i mean king e7
okay so you're ready for this this is uh
yeah right you're you think you're going
to have an easy
no this doesn't look what am i then i go
through each a then i have everything no
then i i i
somehow i i
i lost everything hold on i've got to be
able to do this in a nice way rook e4
you're rocking my world here uh
christian i have to say rook e4
it's a big move and that's what my point
is and that's why i like knight to b1 i
don't think is an easy move to see from
afar
and that detracts you from uh playing
the move h4 all together once you see
this
because you calculated you see the queen
coming to f4 by force and you're
starting to see ghosts and you're like
okay this position is actually just
losing
right if you don't see rook e4
strategically losing tactically because
i'm upon down i'm losing as well right
and so rookie 40 you're busted yeah your
material down strategically your your
pawn structure is is mangled
and destroyed
and
suddenly you have this tactical blow
rook e4
that not only keeps you in the game it's
it's crazy forces a draw force is a draw
right now which for uh sophie is all she
needs
is gold
that's always a 10 000 scholarship a
seed to the
us women's championship
first place in the tournament and a
little piece of history too chess
history now there was another game that
uh i was looking for seniors this game
is a little too quickly for me i need
that right
many breakfast the other sections
seniors senior oh by the way this is the
christopher u game that's crazy crazy
all right seniors uh if we could go to
the kaidanov game
i think he had a missed
missed opportunity a little bit yeah
up
down there
this is it this
wow this is a monstrous game
crazy
that that rook felt like i could eat
that
just a second yeah we we saw we
okay hold on i i was complaining
i gave christian a rant
i was complaining i said
for the better part of 50 years gregory
kaidana has been teaching generations of
american
players
really an extraordinarily great teacher
and in every lesson he ever gave
bring out your reinforcements reinforce
your attack
white has a lovely strategic position
bring the pieces out why are your guys
on f1 and g1 and h1 sleeping you know
play knight f3 play h4 play h5 i don't
care timing development
94.
wait a minute that guy's already
developed and by the way that knight on
e4 it's not like the king has a lot of
guards once you play the move knight e4
you're always susceptible to a potential
c4 c3 he doesn't take his own
advice seriously and he put his knight
on d6 and sorry we're going to get to
the position where
god where you dorsa was saying
crazy things say right now can i eat
that yes it's legal eat it take and i'm
sure
igor was planning to sacrifice a
um exchange yeah so
um igor had a
six minute six minute
thing so here after rookie eight he had
almost 19 minutes okay um gregory here
had 25 minutes okay and he spent about
six minutes and he played bishop to h6
he didn't take that exactly
so he was probably thinking that this
bishop on d3 was
great great uh i agree but
it's not like that bishop is going
anywhere with bishop h6
uh the way that was played in the game
so i'm
i'm a little baffled but
i don't know so i just wanted to guess
your opinion
uh i think igor was under some pressure
and he had to sacrifice some material
to
um deal with this pressure i like the
move rookie eight i'm not a big that's
fair um i don't like bishop h6
okay cause let's just try to catch up to
the players that's about it and we're up
to date and
i must say uh gregory's play i find
confusing as well christian not uh not
uh
no absolutely not it's convincing it's
baffling to me as well but he's not the
leader right now no that is true let's
get to the left if he wins
well there's other players that could
potentially win and if larry christensen
wins at this one right rook takes g5
this is what we're seeing
the white king is in shambles right now
it does have a beautiful defender the
knight on h2 but that's about it right
this is the position we have right now
king to h1 and i see queen to g6 and i'm
seeing the business coming down the g
file right because route to g1 that's a
checkmate threat in one move you can
give a check that's fine i'll cover it
up with the knight and it's all about
who's first you would love to be able to
go rook to c8 and you be the one putting
the pressure but you're not because you
have to defend against checkmate you
have to defend first with rook to c1 and
now i can just continue building my
initiative i can go queen to f5 or queen
to h5 start creeping in around your king
you're one move away from seeing a queen
land on either f2 or h3 that's not a
good sight right also if you do try to
transfer this game and uh go into an end
game the problem is first of all i can
take it
even that endgame your structure is
worse and your knight is completely out
of play right so that's a problem i
don't even have to do that i don't even
have to exchange it's going to be a long
grind and it's going to be a grind in
which you as white have very weak king
and you need to keep this knight on h2
stuck to the defense of it and that's a
problem my knight is going to be mobile
i'm going to be able to go knight to g6
follow it up with knight to h4 knight to
e5 i have i'm playing basically with an
extra piece from what i'm seeing queen
to d5 for example the quality of the
pieces once again who has the better
quality of the pcc in the position
despite the fact that material is even
it is black and black has a great
advantage right now larry could be
looking to bounce back after a difficult
loss against chabalov and clinch the
tournament victory or to clinch a
playoff at least
i was about to say this is an amazing
amazingly
bad idea that
dmitry played this g4 h4 g5 because at
the end of the day
the vulnerable king king position one of
our
five elements
white's king's position is way way way
more vulnerable i think white
basically committed suicide i don't even
have an another explanation for it this
is terrible
i just want to get your opinion on so
you know a lot of people talk about the
soviet chess school and how they were
like this is how you should evaluate
first you look at the material then you
think about the king safety then you go
center development pawn structures
bishops
everything so
how do you feel about that
well that's a classical school of chats
uh it really wasn't soviet's goal of
chess
this is all a myth a complete garbage
that was created in america and in the
western world this idea that the soviet
union had a soviet school of chess and a
soviet way of doing things
no no no no no you go and visit the
soviet union as i did uh multiple times
the soviet union was not this monolithic
robotic communist giant you go to the
soviet union people said i'm georgian
i'm ukrainian i'm russia
i'm siberian i mean
they
the latvian school of chess was very
very different from the armenian school
of chess and somehow
latvia and armenia
and georgia all got mixed into some kind
of a soviet union no no no no those guys
were competitive and they hated each
other
they when they had their spartaki ads
man they just went after each other
and so this idea that you know all the
soviets had one way and one way only of
teaching their students no talk to
alexander shabala who was in this
latvian school of chess with michael
tall
talked to uh lavon ironian who was in
this armenian
school of chess with tigran petrosia
they were very very very different but
the classical way of treat
of learning is what you described and
that's very very common and you know
again uh nuances of the culture
for me the she vishy anand
is a really remarkable player because he
likes knights over bishops
he goes against every convention
for a hundred years like bobby fischer
uh believed that it was almost an
exchange sacrifice to give up a bishop
guys bob
there's a lot of things let's do it
right now first of all
sophie mori suzuki is frozen she didn't
play she hasn't played a single move
she's down to her last nine minutes
with 16 moves to go this is not an easy
decision right now she sees this move h4
follow it up with queen to f3 and she
cannot spot that move rook to e4 right
now if because if she would she would
play right now she's frozen and if she
doesn't find a way to stop this 92
knight to f3 she might be in trouble but
check this out
carissa actually seems to have even
things come out
second
even now the question is maybe this is
what christopher you want it right
because he only needs a draw we know
that with the draw he clinches the
tournament maybe what he wanted was to
simplify the position
he understands the fact that maybe he
doesn't have an advantage anymore
nevertheless he knows that also with a
draw this is game over this tournament
over and uh i have to say i think i'm
agreeing with him and his
decision-making process right now
because i don't see
any ways in which white can make any
progress and we should win this one uh
bad habits have a way of infecting
others
and when your opponent starts making a
particular behavior like
squig you know squishing in their seats
or
or hovering
then you start picking up their bad
habits that's why you say that's kind of
typical buffer right
for allowing maybe rook takes d5
correct that is a draw off very close to
a draw but i i i don't think you can
escape with it i thought carissa was
about to play rook g3 with the idea of
queen
to g6 she yes she did g3
queen g4 of course uh sorry rook to g4
and she does it again she should do
after
making the move
um
[Music]
maybe you should uh
you're too much of a perfectionist no
i'm not i'm just asking for like common
etiquette and so on i had a
dear friend grandmaster miguel quinteros
and he was playing against jay whitehead
a junior player from
and jay had this very annoying habit you
make a move and you would say jadoop and
the movie you just played he would put
it on the square
and you'd make another move and he'd say
should do so you start putting your
piece perfectly in the center well this
is what quinteros did he moved his piece
to the center
hovered over it put it directly in the
center like made absolutely sure press
the clock and immediately should do
right
wow so what did miguel do
miguel said to jay
if you should do
any one of my pieces
for the rest of the game i will hit you
and on his very next move he put the
piece off the square
jay was frozen he didn't know how to do
it
so don't shadoof the peace of my time i
don't think hitting is legal i don't
think it's allowed in the rulebook we'll
have to double check maybe in chess
boxing uh christian
yes she still hasn't made the move
sophie maurice suzuki down to her last
six minutes oh
let's look at oh my goodness right now
and maybe we can see the camera and see
what her reaction and what
sophie
right italia is in trouble okay just a
second when talia
five minutes and 55 seconds guys i'm
counting help me out here when when
talia played the move uh
knight b won how much time did sophie
have 25 minutes
so she's been thinking for 20
minutes on one move exactly wait
uh um actually
she needs to make a move she had
actually 31 minutes 31 minutes oh my
goodness wow okay she has really got she
doesn't see the move rook e4 and i gotta
tell you that is a very
camouflaged hidden move it's not
it's not yeah i mean the computer finds
it but it wasn't on my radar i didn't
say oh rookie four a great move
and the body posture tells everything
right now i have to say it's confident a
sense of discomfort on sophie morris fu
suzuki's
well look at how terrible is black's
pawn structure if you don't play h4 and
and dissolve one of your weaknesses it's
gonna remain there knight d2 knight f3
knight h4 talia can say okay that's a
win i don't even know four minutes and
30 seconds right now still
suzuki she's still she's not sure
oh my goodness she's
if queen f3 just take g3 take back or
rook e6
yeah okay and then you you say well
knight my opponent will play knight d2
knight f3 and i'm lost but the queen is
on f3
no all the queens will be on cheese oh
you would take it yeah sorry sorry my
apologies yeah but if sure comes to e6
but you you're making a good point no
you're making a good point because
what do you do after that knight to d2 i
go rook to h6 knight to f3 i go queen to
h5 you have to so you're making a good
point in that regard take on change h4
is a must if you don't play h4 then
knight t290 you can't stop the knight
from getting to h4 and that's uh so this
is one of the
i don't know i i mean it comes with
experience you can't just sit and spend
your weekends i have to ask is it
possible just thinking about rook takes
e3
perhaps she is because i can't think of
anything else except that she's reaching
that's that's terrible that's not good
terrible
not good
long think wrong thing that is terrible
that is not good i would have rather
seen her play rook takes e3
i mean first of all you just play
forcing move if i capture your queen
you're going to recapture that is the
worst decision she could have made h4
was an absolute necessity but if you
wanted to play rook takes e3 and go a
little hog wild i i'm with you i'm with
you i mean like i that that makes sense
to me but rook a8
sorry that just is a terrible okay taya
will take logically
and then knight d2 yeah that's the same
thing and she's she solves all of her
problems instantaneously
knight f3 game over knight f3 quincy
one all of your pawns are falling game
over this is game over guys
i i actually don't see any way in which
sophie mori suzuki can come back from
this no sophie made a terrible decision
oh for sure for sure
i mean because talia has got this game
as soon as she goes knight rook takes a8
and knight to f3 strategically unless
she makes a howler and it'll have to be
a massive one at that
she is winning she's winning
strategically and she's winning by
material as well rook takes a8 92 game
over can jennifer
somehow magic good question guys let's
go to that game yeah get herself
in
the uh in the funds
we did leave it with and she did find
the move queen d5 that was a necessity
of course
and
crazy things still going on
in this game as well a6 is hanging
well i'm telling you what a time for
anna marie to play the best game
of her tournament in my experience that
this happens whatever i would give the
opponents like two thousand around two
thousand two three hundred points below
me
the the chance to get centered good like
comfortable development and space they
would always make it really hard for me
that's why i didn't like this choice
that jennifer you played
because
it's not about the uh the like how she
can play it it's about how uh valea
could play it and that's like the most
comfortable setting you can get as a
2000 rated player is just you have the
center you have the development you're
not really struggling to figure out
which side to castle
yeah well
that's that's okay we will put the
opening behind us for now
uh but i'm sitting here saying wow uh i
always hate those
90 percenters because it's like somebody
says there's a 90 chance i figure it's
going to happen
it's like 90 percent chance is always
almost 100 chance anna is playing the
best game she's played in the tournament
for luke for many many rounds now or
never yeah well yeah it is the last
round after all the question is
and i'm gonna throw this to you
christian is there
i mean how on earth is jennifer going to
create a favorable imbalance here i i
don't see it i don't either i don't see
it the only thing she can do is just
keep exchanging pieces the problem is
maybe you're not even looking and
probably it's a good idea not to look at
what's happening in taliyah's game
because if you see taliyah is winning
and you start beating yourself up for
not having a better position than you
already have psychologically that's
going to be a defeating mentality
but
let's see what what leah is going to do
knight to d2 this is the biggest puppet
this is terrible
and she played
okay we do have knight to d2 bad news
for her sophie as she's
realizing wait a minute this night gets
done this is bad news for her i have no
breakthroughs
white's position is super super solid
i'm running out what else is going to go
wrong for her right now this is
i mean she's played a wonderful
wonderful tournament
seven
wins from eight games and this is so
painful for her and her fans because
guys she was two points ahead with three
rounds to go
wow
yeah right now potentially talia will
catch her with a victory and jennifer
you also has a chance at catching her as
well
and that would be a three-person playoff
yep that means that we're going to see a
playoff today and how is she going to
recover and we don't want to put a
result already in the bank right now
there's still plenty to go
but
how is she going to recover
from that psychological blow well i
remember famously we had a three-way tie
here in the sinkfield cup and we were
all very anxiously looking to fabiano
lavonne and magnus carlson playing a
three-way playoff those those guys
looked at each other said i'm tired i'm
tired i'm tired let's split
and that was it it was like what what
what we we were all excited by this
three-way play-off and we were denied i
do remember that they were all holding
the trophy together exactly knight f3 on
the board and now it's all about this
weakness on f5
uh for example if you drop back with
your queen on e7 intimating that you
might sacrifice one day against the pawn
on e3 no no no i'm going to
chase you away i'm going to take this
rook or i'm going to take this yes and
peter guys you were asking how is
jennifer going to win and
has actually answered that question by
leaving her pawn on d4 the weakness on
d4 day on e5 just like that and now i
can just simply take on b3 you take on
a6 i go knight to f5 and i have a target
well true that and cheats
don't tell me
no very good oh she didn't have
this my turn into a three-way tie break
for the championship guys
she takes takes munch munch
and knight to f5 with ideas of knight e3
why not or knight to g4 i mean i have a
lot of things to play for knight to g4
and threatening almost a checkmate right
the king is kind of
an awkward situation uh i like knight to
f5 just to keep contact with the pawn on
d4 and put a lot of pressure on you like
that but you do you make a compelling
point here uh knight g4 is not
and potentially even you could start
maybe even with rook be one check
oh sorry no no
my apologies i see in the sophie's game
um
queen e7 yeah and if queen b1 does
happen yes
that's another pawn bloody bloody
that's another pawn thank you very much
queen okay sorry i i did something wrong
oops that wasn't in my intention i go
through all the games and i i get back
by the way we do have a result
our apologies to
zoe
and rue yang yen as zoe
tang has won her game we've been focused
on our marquee matchups because they're
going to
decide
to decide first and sorry you were
saying queen b1
yeah if clean b1 happens that's what you
were saying
falls and give me this feels like a
i mean it's a handshake after that right
and tell you
oh queen b1 played on the board and
[Music]
um
[Music]
time
time uh i mean this is over there it
doesn't matter the time doesn't matter
anymore sophie has three but
that time doesn't matter anymore i'm
taking the f5 pawn i'm taking the h5
pawn everything is hanging everything is
falling right
this is over this is over guys right
wow wow when you think about
how far ahead of the field uh
sophie was a two-point lead
this is
quite the shocker
fall from grace yes yes wow
oh painful championship round oh my
goodness we are at the same lewis just
club i mean this victory by talia is
just going to
blow
the standings apart and allow her to
catch up but also jenny for you
potentially and we do have a result this
one
is balaji draw and one
they won the day because they wanted to
get out of the tournament as fast as
possible but there was a third
possibility of a loss
you draw a lost one
and then
it's sort of like a partial take
whatever suits your fancy
christopher you carissa yep
who's i mean i see they traded queens
off oh that's a big
result for christopher because i don't
think you lose yeah those types of
position where you've
got two pawns those b and c
but i don't think they're going to go
anywhere far i don't know
is it that easy i mean
i get scared guys is is it that easy i
mean i'm not i'm not trying to scare
christopher
scared you guys i know i cannot do that
but you could scare me
i'm easy
i'm frightened by passports but how is
is this for black
well
he's going to go
b4 b3 and your king is gonna
you may have to cough up the f3 pawn
that's okay i'll i'll i'll give you the
f there is there is
there is a rook g5 coming up because
attacking g7 and keeping my eye on the
d5 bishop that's a good point okay so
you've got rook g5 rook g6 ideas you've
got king okay so let's do it we go b4
you go king e3 can i start with
directory five
[Music]
you
are a risk
you are you're you're you're
a thrill seeker
uh here b3
uh are you going to take the pawn
or
because eventually you're going to have
to go check and behind fair so do you
want to take the a pawn or the g7 pawn
when you're as you're doing this i feel
better eating the apon okay so you're
gonna start with a check
and you could
you could eat the pawn
and i'm just i'm just telling you i'm a
little bit terrified
that okay you could push this guy
i'm going to push this guy and i'm going
to push this guy okay
maybe i can throw a rook b5 somewhere
did you want to win my bishop now
let me
uh
i think you got to go over with the king
but you're saying christian if i if i
hear
the intonation in your voice properly
you're saying wait a minute carissa
might have chances
okay chances might be a bit too much but
there's something to play for yes
because i do go king to e3 yeah i get
close the problem is look if the a pawns
would be exchanged then the game would
be over right this is right drop but i
still have that target on a6 this is
what i dream of correct maybe i can get
to that pawn on a6 i'll give you f3 no
problem
if i manage to get the pawn on a6 and
create a pass pawn that will be
problematic and i see look
psychologically christopher you right
now
he knows that with the draw he makes it
right
this is when the blunders and the
mistakes start happening you're just you
get tense you're close to the finish
line you're almost close enough exactly
you you stay you stumble at the at the
very last hurdle
exactly but guys yeah i'm not sure if
andrew hung uh is winning or even better
anymore he might actually be just much
worse
and we're just
we're seeing a very uh similar yeah it's
like echoes
of the um
sophie
and talia game because again andrew
threw everything against a very
good fortress
and
well why i mean first impressions
andrew is ready to take on g2 and
sacrifice and oh sorry it's
white to play i apologize it is why to
play the last move was h3 now so knight
takes
g6 is the start starter move g6 is is is
a question
okay so if i take with the pawn
i'm threatening maybe queen g5 do we
play g3
after queen g5 no i i'm saying knight
takes g6 is the starter move right and
do i take
you probably want to take back right
yeah i think things sick i think so take
back
and
and now the big question is what if i go
e4
oh dear
[Music]
oh my goodness guys breaking news it
seems like jennifer you is actually
winning and this is what i was talking
about
simple tactics
missed knight to d5
that's a simple double attack and right
now she is crashing through jenny for
you that is guys we're going to see a
three-player tie break in the girls
section i think it's inevitable knight
g4 by the way a much is it too late for
a coin flip
[Laughter]
right
much more aggressive move and okay anna
is recognized oh dear what a blunder
rook c7 she could have played rook c5
and jennifer would have had a still a
big fighter on her hands and right now
after knight takes c7 followed by rook
to c8 followed by exchanging on c1 if
you move the bishop away this is over
guys correct rook and what did you say
if you move the bishop away trade
and drag it to her doom
oh my gosh and let's just go back to
italian's position queen
b1 was met by queen a3
uh
sophie has moved completely away from
her king side which means that queen
takes f5
knight g5 and who
who is having
the fun
on the
king side well tell ya knight g5 and
i've got
mating prospects everywhere i look
oh dear
not to mention by the way another pawn
would have been hanging too
uh
it's it's over it's it's over this is
over this one is over
i
just
say it same okay let's get to seniors
i'm done with juniors
well what this is going to happen is
talia is going to
win
making a tie between herself and sophie
so that this for sure playoff there but
if jennifer wins then it's going to be a
three-way play-off in the ladies
we don't know about christopher you
he could clinch with a draw and we think
he's got close to we said that in an
event of a more than two-player tie
they're going to play a round-robin
of game
10 plus two
and then if it's still tied then they
play a round robin of blitz
number one and two play together number
three weights
we're looking at the three ladies we
think will
will tie uh on our left we've got talia
and sophie and on our right we had
jennifer you as the black
side in that game that's if two players
are tied but this is the one a rapid
round robin that means everybody plays
everybody game 10 plus two second
increments
if two players emerge
tied or more then they play blitz
and then if they're still tied we've got
armageddon
uh
we've got an armageddon we got a playoff
whether we like it or not
uh we're doing it and are we going to be
doing it in the juniors um
christian i look i don't think we i
don't think we will based on not only
this game but also the andrew hung game
but this one it seems like christopher
is doing the right things and that is
pushing the pawns trying to create don't
wait don't just sit and wait for white
to do something rather try to push your
pawns and create something yourself so
for example right now king to d4 is
going to be met by bishop to f3 and it
doesn't seem like you're getting
anywhere if you do this this and rook to
g5
hinting at the fact that you potentially
want to go rook to g6 and pick up the
pawn that you're interested in right
once again you're not in the in g7 but
rather on the a6 pawn now i will
continue with my passers keep trying to
create your own counter play and it does
seem like this is going to be enough for
christopher i don't think we're going to
see any surprises in this one dorsa what
about our seniors what are you seeing in
the seniors i saw a lot of advantages
from whites blacks
but it was no i meant in the marquee
match-ups of course
how's larry doing because when we left
it we thought he was contagious he's
upon up
how much of it we might need to ask
christian
but it is advantageous
uh well that's a point up right
right so that's as good as it can get um
about our other games uh
larry's nursing
um
i don't think he's getting anywhere
right now from what i'm seeing this is
an end game equal pawns i understand you
do have uh these double pawns as the lag
that could be a potential problem but
this bishop is a bit out of play on b5
it's not on the right diagonal for
example if uh you would have a bishop on
e3 that would be a completely different
story for example bishop on b5 i don't
like it i feel like black has enough
activity with his pieces infused in his
pieces for equality in this position and
it does seem like the engine is agreeing
with me as well i don't think we're
going to see anything but the drawing
this one larry christiansen of course
that's a big one but what's happening in
uh
versus
and nick sacrificed an exchange for how
many pawns that's three pawns to the
game and the fourth one is coming as
well
queen to f6 defending the f7 pawn
attacking the bishop on f4 this is
starting to look really good for nick
guys absolutely and this could just
simply take a copian out of the equation
right now
it's looking good for larry i have to
say from what i'm seeing in all these
three important matchups this is looking
really good for larry christensen
i can't believe that i just saw what i
just saw i mean
i have played i am not kidding hundreds
of games well i want to say a dozen uh
tournament games with nick i've played
hundreds of blitz games with him and
even in blitz he doesn't hover i mean so
we are seeing uh you know the juniors i
think the juniors are corrupting
everybody just letting go this is modern
chess yes or no pattern suffering is
part of modern chess hovering is part of
bad habits what can i tell you
bad habits it sounds like a good
if you do hover for just i will half a
second i will excommunicate myself you
will be excommunicated exactly i'll go
to the confession booth and you know
pray for for forgiveness right yeah
those were fun thank you right yeah i
mean am i the only one cheering them i
like them and by the way um
uh vladimir just made it an awkward
decision he's decided to trade queens
and go into this ending where he's
probably going to have to give up his
bishop to collect this pawn for example
i'll go king g7 you'll go rook to a c8
i'll go knight to d4 you can hit me with
the
oh i went a little bit fast there you
could hit me with a check i was a i was
thinking you were forced to play bishop
takes d4 but you can hit me with another
check uh oh
so
does that mean i have to no i cannot
play bishop f8 wait a minute
did nick
did nick grab the pawn in the
at
the start in an ugly way
um
no i do
wait a minute what's wrong with king h7
uh bishop e5 pawn g5 okay bishop e5 pawn
g5 and you're you do get escape and
that's a guy unfortunately yes breaking
news yes talia has blown her advantage
no way
she did
no way that was an impossibility i
thought so too rook takes f1 right now
knight takes f1 and put the queen on the
first rank is going to tie down
black tie down white excuse me
so the defense of sorry not put a queen
on c1 or a1 on the first rank but rather
on the second rank keep contacting the
pawn on f2
and now if she plays the move queen to
b2 or queen to a to keep contact with
the second rank so that the queen is
immobile on the file that's just going
to end the game because there's no way
to get out of it
she played it
queen to b2
there's no way there's no physical way
in which white can do anything right now
i'm going to go queen between quincy two
queen b two quincy two
well you're not gonna go queens not
queasy
maybe queen e2 we need to
try to play b4 to kind of trick you into
taking that that's okay i'm not gonna
take that oh i'm not touching that
it's not backgammon that you have to
take
guys there's no knight h2 because i give
you a check there's no 92 because that
square is mine
how do you make any progress i'm stunned
i am absolutely absolutely what are we
seeing right now guys this makes
wow
italia wow
uh
that's
crazy
that's crazy it is crazy it is
completely insane what we're seeing
right now in this final championship
round i think it's nerves
it must be nervous
i i can i can put it i can attribute it
to so many things b4 that's a good trap
that you recommend the dorsa and i'm not
going to touch that of course but
that's a good trackers
b4 king g7
she knows that
italia has blown it she knows that look
at his face
oh my god tell the problem is white's
queen is frozen to the f2 pawn yep the
knight
as as desirable as it might be to trade
knights anytime the knight moves there's
going to be a back
a check on the first rank and the knight
will have to return
to its current square so
the queen can't move the knight can't
move the king
well the king could move but then
queen goes to the first rank or f2 is
hanging
and she's stuck it's a draw sophie
sophie uh
sophie uh makes her the draw and she
will be the winner
wow
what a turnaround queen to f4 that's
okay king so you got your desire no
playoff for the ladies technically i was
split because i wanted taria to win you
know teammate spirit all those things
all that good stuff but
i'm not ready for a three-way playoff
now fireway playoff now
that's a different matter right
i am stunned uh
i mean there are so many things she
could have done even the moment when she
played queen takes f5 she could have
played
knight to h2 in that moment whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa guys
we have king g6 on the board which once
again gives talia a chance no no no no
she can play e4 now because when you
take on e4 she can take back with the
queen with a check this turns the tables
one more time
giving talia another chance to
potentially take the victory incredible
e4 right now
why did she put her king on jesus that
is a really good question she just
just f6 leave it alone king g8 king g7
queen b2 queen c2 queen b2 anything king
g6 allows
talia
one final bite of the apple oh my god
and she knows it because for a moment
there she
is she gonna go for it of course
of course you got a win
she sees it oh it's on the board now
that wasn't hovering she was keeping her
hand
far from the board it's sort of like
she's she had it near her shoulder and
then she made the move and sophie must
be stunned right now let's see why let's
look at her situation right now because
she only has 40 something seconds and
queen takes d4 quickly played but now
queen f5
um check
makes sense i feel like my i can also
take on d5 yeah right yes
that that's something queen is perfect
for me
why did she allow this time trouble
that's that's all i'm gonna do by the
way what are the claptons um
sophie has a minute and thirteen talia
has two minutes and
how many moves
uh five more i believe okay these are
difficult moves so
queen f5 check and
e4 takes d5 are the two options which is
the better of the two christians
i think she takes uh he takes d5 yeah
doing it she did it it's the best move
because if you take on f4 and then take
on d5 you have the b pawn to contend
with and you're not catching that that
is a runaway b pawn
so she has to play queen taking queen
takes e5
but that's
and that will allow me 93 amongst other
things i'm kind of liking pawn f3
just kick that that kick that night away
pawn f3 i've got my my my vote as well
there's no check on the darks where's no
c5 no d4 checks so the knight won't have
to go away and then your king is
perfectly safe knight could come out to
e3 uh knight to e3 also uh
attractive queen ending upon up uh
what's the
what's the uh engine the valuation of
the position now it's uh close to a
decisive advantage close to the decision
yes like it's it's still not easy it's
still not that easy 1.5 the material is
very limited it's 1.7 if she plays the
move f3 f3 f3 is a very important move
in fact how about knight e3 93 is
probably not enough not enough the extra
pawn and the queen and finally not
enough
by the way i'm just kidding and she
played f3 she did good we're getting
news that andrew is on the back foot in
his game against pedro espinosa if
andrew doesn't win
then
the resulting christopher gay game does
not matter christopher you will be the
winner of the junior so no but this is
starting to look pretty much over right
now knight f6 followed by knight to e3
correct um all of my legs are coming
into play nicely knight f6 wow
i mean
we came on the show the dorset and we
were just saying the extraordinary
number of decisive
games and in this game between talia and
sophie we have seen the pendulum
swing
hugely uh back and forth between a win
and a draw and a win and a draw
what's your prediction are you going to
are we seeing another decisive i don't
think my hearts can't take it
and we're we do have knight f6 on the
board
responded by uh very very quickly the
the problem that sophie is facing
is if she were to allow for example
let's go queen a2 if she allows queen f5
check it's immediately decisive
because we check check and pick up the
knight so sophie has to
maintain
control over the f5 square maybe with
the queen b5 but
now why is this with the queen and
knight ending so much superior than the
queen ending christian
uh well the problem is the knight and
the queen can deliver so many mating
threats against the naked king on g6 for
example think about the queen landing on
d2 right now queen to f5 is immediately
going to come on the board and then
you're going to have huge problems
the connection between the queen and the
knight is so potent and by the way that
move was played with seven seconds on
the clock
i see the 37 seconds that is to say
sophie she makes her move she gets an
immediate bonus of 30 seconds that's why
we know
she made the move with seven seconds on
a clock 37 and we have seen here in st
louis a lot of the world's top players
making moves and it says 32
and 30 31 and we're like
uh i think alexander grisham is the most
guilty of anybody who's ever played in
saint louis in terms of
watching his clock run down to the very
last second i didn't have much fun with
the delayed system no i hate that
that was especially coming from
coming from international i've played
internationally and then i come to you
ten seconds for sophie guys
she's doing it again
but that opens up the b-pawn that indeed
opens up the b-pawn knight takes d5
might just be
a technical victory right now
for talia cervantes because knight takes
d5 followed by b5 however
no it gets to b6 there's no stopping the
pawn from getting to b6 and we can hide
our king i think that's incredibly h2
that might be it guys knight takes d5
and once again
that pendulum
that pendulum is like wait a minute you
came on the show no playoffs we've had
these long broadcasts
and now your teammate gets into a
playoff and a three-way play-off uh
because
jennifer is winning that see i've never
seen that i've never you know been a
part of a three-way playoff so i'm very
curious to see that two-way play-offs eh
boring but now you will now you will you
will be a part
of this three-way play-off because you
will be a commentator
and you will call all the action and get
it perfectly
yeah let's see we will we'll fake it
till we make it right
what a moment right now guys that's what
that's all we did
that takes d5 and b5 that's the money
movement
is thinking about maybe
should she play the no i think she's
thinking i think that's what she's
trying to figure out whether knight
takes d5 and she's just trying to make
sure that there's no checks yep there we
have it knight takes d5 and played with
confidence no hovering let's no i i've
got i've got this move this is my move i
feel like you're giving talia your stamp
of approval right oh absolutely
absolutely and by the way i just took it
as perfunctory i never even
would would discuss it ever because none
of my opponents did that
you quite a very nice environment nobody
was trying to trick you nobody was
trying to kick you under a table
i come from a whole different world
absolutely not i mean no the science of
chess was
very i want to say gentlemanly but that
would be unfair it was etiquette the
well-mannered good manners were expected
when you go higher up that is how it's
fully because people respect the game of
jazz people respect their opponents
absolutely b5 on the board
and sophie
i mean she's going to be looking
desperately for for for checks and stuff
i'm thinking that her trick
is that when you play the move b6
somehow h no you can
nothing works guys i mean you also have
to worry about whenever you play h4
just queen g4 check i'll tell you what
i'm gonna do i'm gonna play f5
okay so when you play b6 i play f4
if you take it with the queen i'll take
this pawn but if you
take it with the pawn i've got a
perpetual forties
that's a good trick that's a good trick
hey man you know like when you're down
to
you
i get it i i like it you you need a
cheapo come on that's the way to go yeah
she did not go for that she went forward
lean to d6
but okay that's a little bit passive for
my taste because i think talia is going
to play the move king h2
to defend the pawn on g3 ella tempo
maybe she doesn't even need this pawn
can she get away with trundling her pawn
up the board b6 b7
it looks like
both right both
should
should be good enough but i don't think
you want to go for that especially when
you end up in this position you just
defend the pawn of course no king h2 is
the lazy
lazy person and the problem is that for
example king h2 let's just put that on
the board sure and let's assume that
somehow you lose a tempo um i don't know
you make some sort of a triangulation
and then you not not that because then
go king h1 yes so king h7 king h1 king
g6 king g1 okay just lose a tempo for uh
white so that is black to move or why to
move excuse me
okay
now you go b6 okay and then you think
okay this is my cheapo i go h4 right
but i still have queen to g for chuck
oh that's nasty and you take the pawn
with change you don't have or king you
can go king f6 but i take on h4 with the
queen you can go king on the h file that
allows me to take on h4 with check you
don't have any cheapos anymore no more
cheapos
10 seconds for taliyah but then no
they have they've already played the
40th move
oh good
yes they did
our producer said four three two one and
ago tommy time control he's like what
nobody told me i also where's dennis
dennis
that dennis is taking a vacation come on
he's got to earn oh no he's so nice
sounds good dennis is catfishing
[Laughter]
yes sir what is happening in the seniors
uh christian
do you actually think that i was looking
at it no
at all i was just throwing it to you
baby well thank you very much
wait a minute
there's a rookman there's a rook and
there is no rook for black correct uh
yeah i'm not going three connected
passport apparently is winning okay but
who knows what's happening in this movie
that was gregory kaidana rook takes yeah
yeah okay the engine doesn't even
actually understand so it says rook
takes p7 plus four now he jumps to plus
two plus zero but
nobody actually knows what's happening
in this one gregory kaidanov will have
to figure it out by himself let's see if
larry christensen has made any progress
the way i see it with this move f5 and
g6 the king became a bit exposed um i'm
not liking the progression for black in
this one i'm starting to feel like maybe
white is getting closer and closer to
potentially restoring uh the balance now
let's take a look at what chabalov is
doing nothing has changed
this one
we don't think
shabalov or maxim dlooky is going to win
and uh
definitely not winning this one that
means a lot of people involved in the
play we might see
five five
six-way playoffs five-way six-way yep we
might see a six-way play-off if dorsa
has never seen a three-way player oh god
so why not producer
how about ice from three to six nights
i told you the story of i have i've had
coin flips and i could i never really
said those i lost the coin flip i lost
bronze and world's youth alphabetical i
lost alphabetical uh
annie
you're telling me gregory kaidanov has a
chance
to defend his title championship and
defend his title correct
he was a minus one after seven rounds or
like six rounds you know it's
non-believers like you
don't believe in miracles
you know oh boy that's also another song
i believe in miracles hot chocolate
loved it
grew up with it in fact my goodness
wow
by the way we do joel benjamin has won
nobody was paying attention to joel's
game well that was because it wasn't a
marquee matchup and our
congratulations to joel
he is on four and a half but he is uh
not going to make 50 percent yes 50
our congratulations sir what was going
on in that gregory kaidanov game it's so
rare to see
three connected past pawns versus a rook
but if
is gregory shouldn't gregory just be
bringing his king over and
dealing with these pawns
what's going on uh christian industries
shall be bringing so he did take on a b7
right okay and we're going to go
g5 let's say all right g5 right
right and
h4 let's say h
h3 yes sure let's
go rook to that one ah this is the way
it's so small
they're so slow
that's the problem i guess you're too
slow so let's g4 h4 was egregious i
should have played g4 uh
i think that would still be this no h1
was fine but
you mean h3 yeah g5 is good so why don't
we go a5 why don't we try to save the ea
pawn okay
let's try a5 it just feels like the more
natural way right right because once you
take the a pawn you have a runner that's
you don't want to see that on the board
um how do we progress with white rook to
c7
okay it makes some sense right yeah g5
you take on c4 and we get another runner
um
[Music]
where
the hover
the hovering king f3 where do i put it
let's go here three all right
take take let's go h g4 g4 or yeah g4
let's do it
check
king
uh and now king d2
what h3 let's go
king e2 h2
c4 check first
oh you don't you dirty dog oh my
goodness oh my goodness so why don't you
go here rook to c1 g3 is met with king
f3 if my king were on e4 i'd be i'd be
shouldering you out of the action this
this is a one-tempo and game wow and
it's pretty much impossible to calculate
without an engine wow um
rook takes b7 on the board we believe
gregory might be winning this one but
it's going to be close exactly and we
think that the the loogie versus
shabballah
matchup is more or less heading towards
a draw not that much has happened in
that one i don't think and if that is
true and if larry doesn't win he larry
is is better he's the one nursing the
extra pawn but if larry doesn't win
we're going to be having a massive
playoff
going on and lastly let's just check in
on christopher you because all he needs
to do is draw and he's our
champion
did he do it
what do you say
what do you say
carissa's just
chris has followed your line uh
christian and i don't think you actually
completed the thought well
it's from what i see correct wherever
you go with the king rahi three you move
the bishop i pick up c4 is it so simple
if i go king d6 so king d6 yeah can i
just go attack the other pawns too rook
e3 bishop to d5 sorry which one would
you like can i go with g3 at that end
oh oh sorry i'm sorry i i no no no the
line that you continue
bishop d5 can i now that my king is
active can i go poke the other guy
what move would you like to play
sorry where's the g3 thank you
g3 okay i go see three let's go i want
to go see two and then
go go go
come on christopher get those pawns up
the board
check the problem is bishop e6 is a move
right yeah i i i defend the
defend the king and he plays king v6
he's done it yes okay
now
but i like kind of what uh
dorset is saying but maybe you should
just start with rook g5 uh
i thought my rook was on g5
was it really oops no no i think i think
you're right i think it actually oh it
was on h5 never mind the the option of
rook g5 was there but we chose
not to go for it it's just yes
oh and she had like she did play rook
three five nice
she did play rook g5 oh i was thinking
maybe rook f5 he moved the bishop then
rook g5 but she played rook street
fighter media statue okay so this bit
guys yes this one i i don't think we're
going christopher is going to have any
problems not only that but it does seem
like andrew hong is not winning his game
but let's go to jennifer's game because
i think we're going to see a resignation
in that one all righty jennifer ew uh
versus anne marie vela uh knight to g5
was the last move but now i can just
simply pick up the bishop on d8 that's
that should be right right and she's
give to me the bishop exactly thank you
okay and there again a little bit nice
that's a spike check and that's about it
king 38 followed by the rook coming to
b2 this is pretty much oh or maybe
bishop takes e5
or bishop there's still angry absolutely
anything can happen
look you can play e6 and
that's game try to amount for anything
but unfortunately this one is is pretty
much over
three way touch and uh
we have to stay with with this one just
to see the resignation
uh once again you've got to see the pain
guys you gotta see six
look to be doing jennifer look like
she's in pain oh jennifer is bossing
right now
i know
and she knows it and i don't know if she
i have to say i haven't seen jennifer
get off from the board today she's been
very
focused i want to say the board uh trade
rooks rook b rookies rugby but that one
rupee two go for the kill guys check
mate yes
checkmate yeah and that's the card
designation and jennifer for you wow
jennifer joins the fray she punched her
own ticket as we said
uh she did not have destiny in her hands
and she's probably really happy she
doesn't know that the talia game went
back and forth and back and forth and it
was only this move king g6 by sophie she
was at the
she was at the winning post and it was
that move king g6 that allowed e4 and
talia
are we sure tell you it's winning
i mean i don't
[Music]
yeah the parents watching our broadcast
must be you know like hating us
for her
uh for for the back and forth going on
in this game she set up did sophie for a
trick she wants to play h4
okay so she played she her last move was
the move after king h2 f6 i see and
you know like there's only one trick in
the position
h4
as an answer to b6 where's the trick
b6 is on the board and b6 is i'm
expecting h4 g4
and can i move my king to
uh f7 there's a7
b7 b7 thank you
that kind of clears the cobwebs
dope and you know what the problem is
you go queen c7 i can just simply take
on h4 you cannot
that's the problem yes
this is over
right
okay talia is making us work overtime
guys
every day what's changed about today and
are we seeing the same number of
massively decisive
games as we have in the previous
rounds dorsa
i mean from what i see
we have a
we have a lot of wins we have two draws
well here we'll play catch up on our
results take it away yes zoe tank did
win her game that's one beautifully done
and
we do have yep
okay there is a gibson and justin wink
okay
okay congratulations one more
oh yes rochelle who did win wow close
close close for rochelle but no cigar
it
seven was the points that she needed to
get into a playoff she got six and a
half joel benjamin another decisive game
i think
one more
game and that's it that's the game we
just saw jennifer with seven hoping for
talia to
[Music]
win so that she can get into her playoff
and everybody is got their eyes on this
one uh i think she did play h4 and no
she didn't oh pardon me that's my that's
my um
i just wanted to mention we i i'm seeing
repetition
in christopher u's game and that's what
make him clear first okay and perhaps we
can go to that one just to see oh there
we go go fist bump
a repetition and christopher is the
new us junior champion punching his
ticket to the u.s championships later
this year congratulations to christopher
said sarah congratulations this is so
fast yeah they were ready
right
twelve thousand dollars in prize money
and the ten thousand dollars scholarship
from the dwayne barber foundation and
u.s championship that's a that's a big
ticket right wow that's a big ticket for
christopher remember those us
championships about two hundred thousand
dollars or so and prize money
for the players there and i think the
last row yes five thousand so even if
that's basically another at least 5 000
for christopher that's nice
and an opportunity to play against and
test himself against the bachelor's
players in the united states absolutely
and some of the best on the planet
absolutely wonderfully done for him
truly uh congratulations all around
i'm sure we'll get the crown ready so we
can bring him crown him here
i always liked it i i
when i was growing up and they as a kid
and i had these books of the world
champions they had these wreaths
you know these uh leaves these
greece that they would place over yes
and i always thought oh those were
really cool
they don't do that anymore for the world
championship yes ah yes yes but for ow
no
that took me about two hours ago exactly
get something
we'll make it work we'll make it work
and again i'm just looking at the game
italia do we have a move or no they've
made time control
no worries
it's all about right now it does seem
like that one might be going into a tie
breaks and i don't think we're going to
see any surprises she's going to be
thinking and she's going to be trying to
find something but unfortunately there's
nothing on this one now
what is the situation in larry
christensen's game okay how do we assess
that end game that is my question to the
panel to you guys
oh night ending okay
i have one
night and four
versus night and three and uh rather
convincingly
this
one
three versus two
i would say it's much closer to a draw
i'm just thinking i can't remember
having had nights and nights like this
type of positions in a tournament game
like i've had rooks that i managed to
draw hold or or um couldn't do another
draw but i can't remember having knights
that often in this type of end game but
so let's imagine how larry is supposed
to win
like if you look at this
you know
the only way to win is to play
g5 and f4 that's the only way you're
where you're going to win this game is
you've got to put your
g5 your king here and you play f4
whenever you're playing f4 we're gonna
go down to two versus one i just think
you're running out of firewood that's
just the problem of the position when
you play uh let's say um
it's white to move let's say white plays
here here here and black is all dressed
up and ready to play f4 well i'm going
to give you a check
and i'm not going to make it easy for
you uh to be able to play f4 let's keep
going in that position okay for a second
so you give me a check on c6 i do i go
king
d5 i'll give you a check
so you don't go uh back to d4 that's
important yeah i just i mean i'm kind of
waiting i'm kind of waiting for you to
play knight to d3
and f4 so that we take it
and maybe just to show that uh why you
please want to go back to d4 because of
f4 right
yes
uh i want to be when you play the move
f4 i want to be
ready
uh to capture but although
can't i play king ji for here christian
just you can yes the game keeps going
definitely keeps going i see i see so i
think
uh this position is
much a greater chance
for a draw than for larry to win we do
again have one result in the senior
igor novakov lost to joel benjamin joel
benjamin climbs to 50 percent but he
will feel like he left a lot on the
board what about
the game of deluge again this uh
the reason i wanted to go to this game
is because
uh
shabba has
tossed away his a pawn
in order to go whole hog
with the f pawn f5 f6 f7
um
can't blame him
but we have a champion with this let's
go for it okay dorsa over to you
christian thank you guys we are indeed
with a 2022 us junior chess champion
congratulations christopher what a
performance your initial feelings after
uh this clinch of the title
i almost can't describe it
i don't think i've ever won a tournament
as big as this before
absolutely you came into this event with
what ambitions
christopher just to play good chess
and see what happens i definitely didn't
expect to
win with this score or even or win it
let's say
well uh at what point in the tournament
did you feel like you're starting to
dream about a potential victory
maybe
right before the rest day when i was
leading the tournament by a point i
started to think about it
but the main focus was just on making
good moves and not too much the final
result and that is definitely a
champion's uh mindset now
in the last round against carissa with
the black pieces you know that the draw
is sufficient what was the strategy and
what were your thoughts before the game
started
i knew that it would be pretty hard to
force a draw because of the 30 move
rules so i just decided to play normally
and not in particular play for a draw
absolutely now take us through today's
game because in fact at some point it
felt at least from an objective point of
view that you were in some danger did
you feel that way at any point
i did but i also saw that i was winning
at some point absolutely you are
definitely winning at some point when
she went ballistic with this bishop
takes f7 but this was the moment so
let's keep going a few more moves
you guys exchanged on e3
knight to e7 was indeed the right by the
way when did your preparation finish in
this game
um
i i think it finished at like
bishop e7 or something
perfect okay okay so quite far back all
right bishop take c3 rook take c3 and
now you took on e5
did you spot this idea of rook to d3
knight to d6 and the knight to g5
i did not spot this idea
and after castle queen to h5 taking
advantage of the fact that you're all
tied down
did you feel or did you speak with her
after the game did she mention this move
at all or uh you don't know
i didn't speak to her after the game
absolutely so
rook to d3 might have been an
opportunity missed but she went for this
queen to eat when she was thinking for a
very long time at this point after
knight c5 came on the board almost
immediately she sacrificed the bishop
were you shocked because because we were
here on the panel we were looking at
bishop to c2 and all sorts of like
normal moves and then she blasted bishop
takes f7 on the board
i was definitely shocked
i definitely i didn't i definitely
didn't think there was enough
compensation for this piece sacrifice
and the engine asks pretty much
everybody didn't believe karissa
knight to d5 that was a very good move
centralizing the piece opening up the
action of the queen as well c4
now
at this point instead of h6 did you
consider a move knight to f4
i did
i think i
was concerned about queen e3
queen to e3 and knight to d3 knight c to
d3
now we're getting some wild stuff
happening on the board well the position
is wild
yeah
in in and of itself so
but you decided to go h6
now at some point it it felt like the
trend is starting to buck a little bit
and you're on the defensive uh queen to
d6 knight to f3 yes bishop d5 was indeed
the right move but let's keep going with
queen to d6 and now you play the move g4
and she started thinking she had a lot
of options what was the option that you
were mostly worried about
i think what she played actually knight
g5 knight g5 and what about knight to d4
this was the move that we were
considering and we were very worried
about your position right now
maybe g6 is possible just try to stop
knight f5
g6 yeah and uh
queen takes g4 you weren't worried at
all about the king getting a bit too
exposed or
maybe queen g4 i was definitely a bit
worried but i did think i should be able
to defend with good play
absolutely absolutely and she played the
move knight to g5 i really want to
commend this move uh and first of all
the calculation that went on with this
uh
queen sacrifice potential c queen
sacrifice with this bishop to d5 of
course if she does take the queen
there's a checkmate this move wrote to
h6 i really like this move uh by you and
we were starting to be a bit worried
about your position but when you played
this mover to h6 we really liked your uh
your process now
and after that i don't think you had any
problems did you feel like you have any
problems after this no
absolutely not
christopher
big victory for you you are the u.s
junior champion not only that
you're gaining quite a substantial
price but you're also punching a ticket
to the u.s championships coming up in
october how does that feel
amazing
what are your plans about that
championship about facing fabiano
caruana wesley so and all the superstars
of american trust
i really don't have anything to lose so
i'll just
come into the games with
just try to be prepared and play good
chess
absolutely well you will definitely do
that and we cannot wait to see you at
the us chess championships once again
big congratulations christopher you are
the 2022 u.s junior champion
congratulations and our congratulations
to christopher very very very nicely
done twelve thousand ten thousand he
goes to the world junior
he goes to the u.s uh championships
world junior oh
absolutely absolutely where is this
gonna be held
you're asking the wrong guys you gotta
coach my apologies we've got a coach he
knows all these things because he's
recruiting from these world junior
championships wait excuse me what was
the question right now where's the world
junior championship going to be held
i have no idea
i've been fl i've been i believe it's in
uh in greece and now to answer your
question i do believe it's in greece but
i'm not 100 sure because
they used to have world youth
championships uh all sections from uh
under eight all the way to under
eighteen nowadays they separated right
it's under from 10th to 14th and then
from 14 to 18. so they have like
separate tournaments and it's kind of
confusing um and i know the players that
i'm having my eyes on and generally they
don't play in this world of these
championships anymore which is kind of
weird
and the 18 to 21 year olds don't they
play in the world juniors well that's
the world junior yes yes that was the
one we were asking about not the world
view not it got it
yes the world juniors i'm 100 sure where
that will be you know what let me just i
was thinking that you would be going
and you would have your little mizzou
booth come and become a tiger
get your scholarship i told you i told
you this before you should be a promoter
i'm doing my best i'll i'll have you
i'll find a job for you yeah
move to columbia missouri
from the netherlands why not bring your
shirt i'll bring you a nice tiger shirt
from mizzou we'll reunite the band in
colombia missouri yasser i'm waiting for
you all right
uh okay good good good good good good
[Music]
um italy italy yes i believe it's
fantastico
and it's
late in october wait that's eight
october it sounds like it doesn't
interfere with us right probably not
probably not october 23rd well we'll see
we're going to take a quick break we're
going to see you on the other side of
the break stay with us for this
championship saturday
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
coverage of the us championships the
girls the juniors the seniors we have a
champion
a dorsa and his name is christopher yu
wonderful wonderfully done beautiful
event for him and he just gave a really
cute interview too right great christian
yeah twelve thousand dollars in
championship prize money
10
000 in scholarship monies and a ticket
to the us open championship and a story
that's being written in the girls event
is this one talia with the white pieces
on your left up against sophie
sophie coming into the game had a one
point lead and all she needed was a draw
and she's not getting it as talia is the
one in the driver's seat they're in a
queen ending talia has the extra
material and and basically sophie needs
a miracle yes and should tell your win
then we will have seven
upon me three players with seven points
uh including jennifer you and they will
have a playoff
and
uh
and the seniors i'm gonna leave that to
you christian to explain because
that's going to be a long explanation
the explanation that i didn't get the
notes for because nobody expected that
we're going to have six players okay
five sure maybe but six players seems to
be the case right now if everything
happens as we expected to happen uh that
is kind of and we do have a result in
that game between
nick the fermion and akopi and i i do
believe that that ended up in a draw
oh okay so that would mean that's gonna
be five players no no no no no that's
one oh pardon me that's a copian that is
one kaidanov needs to needs to win okay
is winning so he's going to join
accorpion on five and a half points now
larry
and dimitri are fighting it off right
now yes kaidan of winning
kaidanov is winning yes i don't know
he's definitely winning he was the one
with the rook versus the pawns yes uh
maybe not after his last move
his last move was maybe not after he's
he just made the move yes
uh just came on the board maybe he's not
winning anymore
g
b3 well i got rook h4 chat yes right
in fact that's the only move otherwise
they just resigned that is true but
rook h4 check why isn't that winning
well the the problem that i'm seeing is
you can just go king the middle of the
board king e5
and i take upon an f4
and now f4
oh boy and in the face of g2
push push push push
why isn't my king on d2 that's a good
question why is it my king that was the
winning move
the silver lining okay so rook check
on h5 85 is the only move so let's see
if he if he plays it he's played rook h4
check
and he's got to take after king e5 rook
h3 f4
then on our analysis board i go rook h5
check how do you go if you go king e4
my intention
was to play rook
to g4 with the same trick
as rook g5 with the same trick as before
rook g4 check
and i stop your pawns so you have to go
back with the king
after rook h5 do you go king f6
yes i think so crickets i think so well
otherwise i
go rg5 and i don't think you can move
your paws precisely let me ask how easy
is it to find king e5 he played it okay
of course
is igor a grand master in part i'm sorry
igor might be surviving this yes
no
um no i see he's an international master
i believe he is he is an international
master yes yes yes he's the only
international master actually in the
event
okay so king e5 rook takes h3
f4 and i'm facing the brutal reality of
g2 if i go down
g2 i go behind
f3 now if my king were on d2 it would be
easy pz i would play king here but after
f2
igor wins
so
i tried rook h5 check and then you went
king f6 and stopping me from
freezing the pawn
and
can i do i give another check then i i
think you have to give keep keep keep
giving checks and that's just going to
be a draw
and uh i think we will be watching for
some handshakes in the game of sophie
versus talia because right now g4 was
played queen to d7
guarding the second rank the very
important second rank and then b8 is
going to come there's no more checks
this is it
there's no more miracles coming
talia is securing a tie breaks not only
for herself but also for jenny for you
king to g7 after queen c2 check just
being and i think we can just get a
second queen on the board make it
by the way making that second queen also
denies this queen f4 check
no checks on the diagonal nope that's it
and it's on the board
see how she made the move
no hovering
it's not no no no but it's not the
correct way to actually put the queen
first you have to move the pawn all the
way to the eighth rank take the pawn off
the board put the queen
they changed the rules recently really
yes it used to be that you can put the
queen on the board also and not anymore
wow you see
a lot of people mistakenly and there's
the handshake right there a lot of
people mistakenly believe that chess
1600 years old the rules never change
the rules are always changing i never
knew you had to move the pawn yes
to the eighth rank or the promotion
square only then remove it and put the
queen on the board i always was taught
put the queen on the board and pick up
the pawn and press the claw not anymore
yeah dang
okay and hope
and and
and the result is we have a playoff
everybody
three-way play-off between sophie
jennifer and talia
um who picked whom
i had talia i had jennifer oh my god get
out of here
get out of here
your predictions
a true confession
so how will this work for three ways
okay so basically these three players
will play a round robin with one another
uh so italia will play two games
jennifer will play two games sophia will
play two games they do not play
themselves obviously game ten plus two
seconds now i think chris bird was
explaining there's not going to be a
drawing of lots
but it's how they
finished on their tie break so
somebody's going to get an extra white
somebody's going to get an extra okay
yeah
no did i say that right no i think it's
even because they play two it's even
they all play
they all play two games white and black
and if there's a two-way tie after that
then they will play around robin blitz
correct and uh what is our timing on
this everybody it's 5 30 now i think
it's six o'clock i believe so these
games are going to start at six o'clock
so the players will have a 30-minute
break prep
coach
what would you tell
your student if they were in the playoff
what advice
uh would you give them stay calm it
actually happened recently uh during the
american cup uh maisie and tahir janova
i think was well she actually played
quite a few uh at this of these
tiebreaks and she ended up even in uh if
i'm not mistaken maybe an armageddon
against alice
lee or something along those lines but
either way um there's a lot of pressure
involved and the only thing you can do
is prepare before
the games start do not think of too many
things right before that try to take a
walk
take a what clear your mind and just
pretty much get ready to fight it's
going to be a fight the outcome of the
opening
is not going to be as crucial as in a
long-form game a classical time control
game so don't put too much focus on that
i think energy is the most important
thing motivation is the most important
thing and for sophie right now she just
needs to understand that this is it a
clean slate forget about the fact that
you just squandered a two-point
advantage in the last three rounds
forget about it easier said than done
easier said than done after such a
difficult loss it's uh not easy to just
come and play a game of chess but this
is what she will have to do i have to
say from a psychological perspective
talia and jennifer to my eyes look like
the favorites going into this cyberbreak
absolutely by the way that we have four
decisive
uh games in the ladies section doris
have more results coming in yes yes
vladimir koppen and occupant did draw
his game against
nick
for me
and vladimir by the way i think is the
only one with five and a half points
he's waiting to see if anybody wants to
join him yes and tell ya
look at those sevens seven seven sevens
yes uh talia has one and by the way uh
once again the decisive number oh sorry
oh and this is our playoff
between sophie jennifer and talia which
will start in about 30 minutes
uh not to jinx sophie in any way but uh
did she make a norm of a gm norm with
that incredibly nice seven out of nine
that's a big or is it just good enough
for an i am
well i guess we'll have to wait for our
arbiters to tell us that because
i think at least the w i am but i'm not
so sure if there were enough title
players to
make that happen for a
um
actual wgm
norm but i know she gained a big chunk
of writing she sure did
uh by the way four decisive results out
of four games played in the girls and
it's a hundred percent to my eyes that
alice
lee
is going to win
to make it five for five
i mean of course uh you know they're
fighting
to the very very last moment let's join
the seniors as you see there on your
screen dmitry gurvich with his back to
us larry christensen
nursing an extra pawn
but at the time we left it we didn't
think larry
could do anything has anything changed
uh christian no no not nothing has uh
changed in that regard um absolutely not
again you still have to pay attention to
the fact that black at some point will
want to go f4 right clear um
this is the key idea in the position and
then put some pressure on the pawn e3
you're probably not going to take back
on f4 so
this is the question that he needs to
answer himself
dmitry that is how do you progress so
yes that is
and that is a big problem right whenever
you go f4 you allow the king to go to g4
um now
let's take a look at that chabal of game
as well guys because okay because that
was getting interesting both sides
exactly both sides have passed pawns uh
the f4 pawn and the a pawn and uh but i
actually think we might be seeing a
repetition why did we have uh so rook
283 was played bishop d5
king d3 and rook to a3 and
shabalov said no king c2
i tell you i mean
they are showing enormous fighting
spirit uh the seniors it's like uh
i'm here for the i'm here to win the
senior championship i'm going to exhaust
every possibility seniors don't get a
ticket to us championship right no they
don't no no no and they're relieved
[Laughter]
that they do not because uh
that they will be uh marked uh i assure
you
the problem is we we we've seen it on a
number of occasions
uh five hours the seniors can hang in
there it's that sixth hour of play like
we saw by larry christensen the other
day uh with this match against chabal
off by the way he just he just ran out
of gas ran out of energy at the end
i'm kind of amazed that uh shabbalov has
got all of this energy because he's been
playing
very long matches very long games
and i don't see why he's playing for the
win uh can't max just play for example
rook h3 and start hoovering off
the remaining pawns
christian but the question is who's
who's playing for the win maybe maxim is
playing for a win as well that's that's
the thing right about this position rook
to h3 does seem to be more than enough
for a draw right right unless we're
missing something big which i don't
think we are no um
rook takes a seven rook takes h4 and
that's pretty long yeah now there is
another opportunity for black right
now that he moved away with the king i
can maybe go king five king g4 and try
to pick the h4 pawn with my king he did
not do that he played the move h6
wow
okay h7
h6 but how is white winning this one i
have no idea this is what confuses me a
little bit with a with a passive king
you know put the king on e5 put the king
on e7 put the rook on h8 and i
understand how i win i i'm pressing you
and i've got a check but i'm not going
to just win the game with a rook and
bishop against this kind of blockade
against the f pawn and i only have the
f-pawn that's my trump i would not say
the c pawn is going to bring me glory i
don't think the h pond is bringing me
glory so my king needs to be on e5 it's
on c2 forget about it
and i think right now by the way guys
yes um
i do think that we're going to see some
massive simplifications in the game of
dmitry guravich and
larry christensen because he did play
the move f4
it's on the board after f working to g4
on the board
that's not yet on the board but right
now it is uh oh pardon me
it's a my
my
uh
board i was ready i was ready let's go
i'm assuming knight d3 is what larry's
got to do right
right knight to d3 should probably be
the move but what if i continue just
simply taking j5 yeah i'm going to take
on f2
and i'm hoping that your blunder
f4 takes e3
and what if i go
king sorry knight to
c6
check that looks like a good move i'll
go
d6
again
my dream
if you go night here i guess i can go
back right knight to d4 if i take you've
got to check and that's pretty obvious
draw if i go f3 you've got king f4 and i
think that's the obvious i think on f3
yeah you take on f3 so i have to play
king to d5 but then i think we do
and you go king takes that f4
fair fair fair fair that's it
that's going to be a draw yeah that's
what it's all that seems to be it
and igor what about kaidanov is kaidanov
that is the heartbreaker right there
because kaidano was winning this one
knew that he's winning this one and
again that's just not anymore one of
those games where again you're talking
about a senior player running out of
energy and it was really pretty simple
just at this moment after the move f5
it's clear that those pawns on the king
side you got you you need to keep an eye
out for him and king d2 would have won
the game yes
on the spot gregory thought
let's just go make a queen i can deal
with this because i have this wonderful
move rook h4 check
as soon as he puts his king
in front of the pawn i'll go rook takes
and i'll win
igor said what about this well i got to
take the pawn and what about f4 and
suddenly
gregory
man what a hard break he on the back
foot he won the last two games and could
have yeah this one yeah clear the hat
trick but also make it to the tie breaks
and unfortunately falls in the last
almost the last move painful
i mean uh these championship rounds i
mean winning the last round of a
championship
um is so fulfilling but
maybe even worse
is the loss i mean it doesn't even the
loss
is greater
than the victory you it's so painful
and uh for gregory if he loses this game
because he he's not going to lose
there's no way he loses how well how
does he draw sorry
check right check check check check is
it a check check check check check yes
check i go king yes i didn't see the
draw sorry maybe what did i continue
track king g4
now i go uh to h8
correct because rook h1 g2 and i go
push king d2
you're trying to lose right i'm trying
to lose right
am i trying to lose i think i am
why is my mouse working you're
definitely losing this one oops
so i i can never
step i don't think the g file i don't
think you can do that
okay rook h5 is on the board
and he's done it and we're expecting
king f6 by the way king f6 is the only
hypnotic drawing move and he played it
instantly
well
these legends know what they're doing
they do
at times and then again it's that energy
so we're expecting a perpetual
here
uh in this game
any remaining games did andrew what
happened in the game of andrew hung i
mean i know this is pedro pedro is
pouring in the finishing touches on
andrew
oh pedro espinosa might be winning his
second game of the tournament the lowest
rated player in the field and for andrew
this would be a very
painful loss i i dare say because he
nearly fought himself
into a playoff
pedro espinosa rook to b8 and this seems
to be
pretty good absolutely a7 is on tap
it could be a correlation beautiful
b-pawn but that's
just caught with this move to be
truly
knighted
where is that oh that knight is trying
to give
sneaky sneaky
all right how do we deal with this
rook to a5 right rook to a5 i let your
queen you can take you can take my rook
with
uh b1
but you can't catch
the a pawn the express uh never mind i i
i i'm on the analysis board we just
focused on the um
uh just to mention that the girls
section is over
elisa
lisa alice alice lee did win her game
exactly so um in about 20 minutes the
playoffs will be starting for the ladies
okay and by the way
i just picked up the engine rook 285 is
losing for a while get out really it's
because of rook d3
rook a5 rook d3 check
there's tricks oh my goodness and knight
to b3 and you cannot catch anything and
i will checkmate you with the queen and
the rook
knight to be you get a queen as well
you're not allowed to make a queen
pardon me you're not allowed to just to
stop the queen
oh my god has some more tests to uh he's
still handled right now
being thrown at him by andrew hunk
wow you know coming in that's crazy i'm
not i was not ready for all these pawns
flying to become queens
but what if i just go rook cb5
yes just uh maybe that's the easiest way
what did he do
a7
a7
a7 a7 well
in the immortal words of somebody why
not a7 all right so i go rook oh
he has to play it okay rook a4
if you take my pawn i do still have this
fork
night shag
but perhaps after rook 284 you go
through c8 right
rook to c8
and now you take on a7 i take on b2
your queen i take and then i get uh
a8 as well
well i mean is this it's not that easy
no no no no no no this is not that easy
anymore i mean we might be in table
based territory soon let me chuck
take take wow
unknown
so we are in table based but this
this database doesn't have it okay and
uh a game
because it didn't actually affect our
standings uh in terms of the podium
david brosky is black is up against
mishra this is
again one of those things where it's not
about material it's about king position
and whose king is safer
and it looks to me like
david brodsky's king is about to get
checkmated
i'm seeing this move queen g4 and i'm
looking i'm zoning in on
this check
can you avoid it with rook d8
because uh queen g6 is a shish kebab
right rook h8 and rook g8 rook d8 dorsa
do we have a
do we have a queen of five right
can we pick up that rook or what are we
doing i'm going to keep checking right
can i no
no it's
it must be losing roxy seven coming up i
don't feel sorry exactly
i feel uh that uh
that mishra
pardon me that mishra is winning i was
about to say that david brodsky is
losing and then i lost my train of
thought
long long days um
wow uh interesting game and again andrew
this we already have crown christopher
you that's it but this game
with andrew uh some cheapos uh still
remaining uh between these two i think
that all three remaining games in the
senior seems to be
as dry as once again shabbat i think
might be forcing right now finally a
draw let's take a look at that okay
there has been one repetition on the
board okay he did play after h6 king b2
rook
a5 rook ha king g7 richie
yes
there we have it g7 and we are expecting
this this is the second six yes rocket
g8 king f602h8 has been seen already and
i think we're going to see that again
rook d8 by chance no rook to g8 was
played okay sorry
the bird side view
and now max slim
is teasing a potential escape from this
repetition i don't think we're going to
see that exactly
i mean even if king you have six i'll
just do the same with king h7 i'll just
bring her to the other side of the board
i don't think there's any way to improve
this position some sort of a
psychological play going on exactly
these two seniors right now exactly
getting ready for the tie breaks they
know that they're going to go and face
each other once again
i think i think there should at times in
chess be acting awards you know i really
have suffered i didn't want to allow a
draw but
three-time reputation
is wonderful
okay so
it's all about larry christensen now can
larry
pull it out i don't
think he's
he's got a win but uh there's always a
possibility of a blunder there is indeed
i think uh dimitri is making his life a
little bit more difficult than it should
be yeah so what did he do with c6 he
played instead of taking that pawn on
g5
yeah that's that was our line knight
takes g5 he started with knight takes f2
and then knight c6 he started with
knight c6 it's all about the time right
now so how much time does he have to
solve all his problems eight minutes and
35 seconds it seems like okay
all right
let's try to do this without an engine
show me show me how do you make a draw
here yes sir i think it was the same
position we had only i believe we had
these pawns traded and that's important
that's important i think so why do you
play okay
um okay well
let me just try the obvious check king
e6
and let me just come back
you do have a comeback are you sure i
take on f2 and take on e3
that's two pawns
i don't have eight
oh just no but i still have
okay king d5 let's see d5
check king d4
oh don't tell me it's one of those
yes yes i
and i have knight h3 at the end that's
beautiful beautiful how was that pawn
and game
which planet games after knights
oh maybe not i was just thinking if um
after whoops uh can we go forward a
little bit
so king d5 knight c7 k6
let's go back you're not getting a good
pawn end game though that's that
let's take that
let's take that
but i have an idea at the end i have a
trick ah king d5 that's the problem yep
king d5 king takes c3 and now knight g4
i see
and that's a draw
draw what a hard-fought battle and for
gregory
yes he's just stumbling at the very very
end gosh what a
what a sick feeling that is ah
that's that that's harsh sorry uh
i had kind of put this
game aside for some time
he took
on
f4
what what a way of
play
i mean it it's really really weird
what dima is doing well maybe they're
they're trying to avoid a five-way tie
well deema is gonna get beat up i mean
there'll be a there'll be a gang waiting
right outside the the chess club
okay so once again let's i'll give you
the task
uh we take him with the pond dorset
let's go for it
okay um the first thing i want to think
about is can i eat the chick
yeah knight takes f2 check can get four
king f4 i guess king d you have to go
king d5 now g6 and now it's about
if my knight
can make it back or not king e3
give me three
oh no k3 is losing knight t5 knight g4
that's what i wanted to ask
can i get in back in time
so king e3 no king e3 no that's losing
right so i guess i have to go king of
five but now my intended e3 by the way
will lose as well or
wait you might actually be losing this
one yeah uh
my my knight
didn't get uh back
uh
sorry knight c6 this is bizarre play i
i
mean this is
is ugly just
especially in the sixth and seventh hour
you know
you're making
you're making everybody's life miserable
here which one is he going for he's
going for f2
and again you don't see the hover
there you just you play the move of
course
and
knight takes f2 check on the board
but can't i just simply
no but if you take on g5 wait a minute
can you taste g5 loses because i'll just
pick up cc because that's it
so you have to go king g3
king g3
king g3 the only move in the position
but the problem seems to be king g3 even
if i do pawn take spawn king takes uh
pawn king takes d6 king e3 you don't
have knight g4 yeah oh that's so that's
that that that the opponent game will be
that's scary man i know i i think this
is like that's so scary i just don't
know what dimitri is even thinking i
mean this is and king g3 and he even
took some time
king g3 was the only move right
everything else loses like there's just
nothing to to talk about king of five
would have lost king takes g5 would have
lost so
he's making his life so difficult that
he has to now find only moves
maybe it's enough though but that's the
thing maybe it is
so what if i
okay
okay you're thinking about it right
so if you play king here i'll take
[Music]
i don't know
okay i think
i'm getting tired i just
i can't believe what dimitri is doing
he's giving larry
maybe the title
is he i don't know but he's doing his
best so knight h1 let's go with king g4
knight h1 let's go with king g4
easy for you to say i'll take
now i take on g5 with the pawn okay
and
whatever you do
king push
can i get queen and knight versus
no i don't think so no i can't get
king d5
g6
yeah
you're just in time to
lasso
the last pawn
wow
he's playing with fire i have to say
he's truly playing with fire truly
but it might be enough
if he comes in and he says yes i
calculated this is
this is very very simple uh we should
have a result in oh yeah we do the
mishra game mishra did win yes we we
thought that
white's active major pieces were going
to overcome black's king i see the final
position nice one yeah right
and um
spinoza game i think he kind of um
shot himself in the foot i guess that's
the expression oh yes we do have that
expression
i mean he he's the exchange up but he
he's still fighting but it wasn't it's
not as clear as it was
but we have to stay with that game guys
which game
uh
yeah no no we're just looking at the
remaining games uh
christian we're just looking at the
remaining games uh this game does appear
draw despite again the best efforts of
uh dimitri to give us all a heart attack
a collective heart attack
um
and i wonder what larry
is thinking about right now you lucky
sobs
i'll tell you exactly what he's thinking
i've been there you know exactly what
he's made i know larry yeah yeah i know
i know them both well uh
great competitors great competitors at
the board and i must say
again with these two players most
especially larry
and dimitri gervais all of our u.s
championships all of our
competitive
competitions that we played and never
never
did did either of them try to distract
me or in any way
uh create
a controversy they were
at the board
outstanding and as all of these players
are and that's why i'm a little bit
annoyed by the junior players i mean
they should
you know
learn from their elders and
be correct no hovering no kicking no
hovering no biting oh well biting okay
i mean
you gotta give a little allowance uh now
and then uh biting i get you know huh
scratching
i've seen people chew their pieces
oh
chewing them at the board no no no no
not but i know that's the thing
literally they chewing the actual chest
pieces i'm like ah
right are we are you guys saying that we
should get some cheerleaders for chess
yes yes
yes
i think the message sounded the mizzou
cheerleading squad the mizzou golden
girls the golden girls
yes
uh who introduced the tigers the golden
[Laughter]
is that actually what they're called yes
that's how they're called
right
it's their special name here we go larry
oh
did you just see what i i can't believe
what i just had just
reached it don't worry about it that
don't happen
jeez
uh by the way also uh when we play blitz
chess with
each other and
uh
we don't hover we just like play bang
bang bang bang bang bang bang
larry's looking at knight h1 uh
only move king g4 but it's good enough
right uh
christian after knight to h1 yes
yes king g4 is definitely good enough uh
he played it knight to h1 and expecting
well it's always nice to test your
opponent kg4 knight f2 check
question right
so
let's go to christian uh who is with
guests let's go for it
thank you guys uh abimanu first of all
congratulations on a last round victory
it's always uh good to finish on a
strong note uh how do you feel about the
tournament overall yeah this tournament
uh of course uh first of all
congratulations to christopher for
winning this event he played
tremendously throughout the whole event
making a lot of good victories
throughout this whole event i feel like
i haven't been playing my best like even
the two games i won against a wonder and
pedro i mean they weren't the cleanest
games and yeah i i definitely i wasn't
playing my best in the last
two three rounds i've been paying for it
what's uh
the process right now to get over this
let's say unsuccessful tournament to
your standards according to your
standards what's the process right now
so as of now i mean this game this game
i thought okay i mean david i knew that
he was 24.99 if i'm correct he gained
like three points he was 24.96 he needed
one point for to become grandmaster oh
wow so he needed a draw on this game
okay i mean my tournament hasn't been
going so great i mean i was just playing
to go play a game and just try whatever
i can and play my best because
whatever happens happens but if you
don't play your best you just can't
learn anything from the game i'll be
wondering you have so many fans all over
the world here in the united states as
well what's next for you my next
tournament is i think it's full clap
fall classic in another two and a half
three months but yeah before that i
don't have anything planned as of now
any uh plans uh to train are you going
to train here in the united states are
you going to be traveling anywhere what
what are you going to do for the next
couple of months for the next couple of
months yeah definitely i mean
probably take a bit of a time off but
after that of course i'm gonna start
preparing seri start preparing for the
next event and yeah
i'll i'll do whatever i can i mean i
need to fix this
i'll be money congratulations on a
strong finish always a pleasure to see
you play here at the uh at the st louis
chess club congratulations thank you
to which we add our own on behalf of
dorset and i uh congratulations good
luck much success
in your career again echoing the words
of christian lots and lots of fans and
uh we'll keep our eye on you
yeah i'm young man very 12
13
right 13 13 13. yes
exactly young man
and too young
he's too young
i know isn't it remarkable i mean at 13
i just was my first year in chess
and
trying to get a b player
to become a b player
i was so overrated
for me sorry i was 1998 so 13 would have
been
2011.
okay
what was i doing i don't know
i'm still admiring how difficult oh
and we are underway with the ladies
playoffs let me
let me where
where is this play-off happening right
that's a good question let me let me
look on the official website while we
keep our eye on
the game
i guess this is going to be a new
tournament
that's what i'm thinking too but
still should be somewhere in leeches
yeah i got the u.s girls championship
playoff number one there it is it is a
new tournament by the way
oh nathan playoff
yes cool it's the playoff tournament and
sophie
against jennifer's english went with the
uh early fee and shadow of the queen
side uh b6 and c5 we remember earlier in
the tournament um
uh sophie also was playing a
oh
gosh darn it hedgehog that's what i
wanted to say
she
she played a bunch of hedgehogs yes
actually i think her latest victory
wasted against rue yang yeah yes that's
exactly right yes
that was a big victory uh that proposed
her to six out of six in fact and that's
what she's going for right now right
and by the way check her time spencer
right now
well 10 minutes she started off with 10
minutes and she hasn't spent a single
second on it
she is blitzing right away now again
what we're seeing just to make sure
everybody's up to date we have a three
player tie
and they will be playing around robin
that is to say
jennifer will be playing sophie and then
talia
and whoever wins the round robin will be
our winner our champion full stop but if
it's tied then the players who are tied
will continue to play uh blitz
absolutely and with f2 f3 if i need the
bottom e4 let me just
bishop to e7
and sophie is just blitzing out her move
she actually knows this variation she
played it before just a couple of days
ago against rue yang and she shows her
stuff right now and i'm having a hard
time getting the relay on my board it's
not updating unfortunately for me
[Music]
i'm frozen now it does seem like well
she's building a very nice time
advantage i have to say and this
10 minute games they're so crucial those
last few seconds where everything is
happening on the board and whoever has
more time and it does seem like sophie
mori suzuki right now is building up a
very nice time differential in this game
whoever has more time in those critical
moments will win the game
exactly
exactly and you're right
sophie
sophie
is showing her
familiarity with the position she played
this game before yes
jennifer is behaving like every move is
a surprise are those lemons or bananas
or mangoes or mangoes
on her shirt i don't think they're
bananas to be honest yeah that doesn't
look like bananas everything else is
kumquats
it sounds like caramel it looks good
looks like
i like my tongue
i think that's going to be our first
question
nice
let's see
is she jennifer bishop
okay this goes to this tells me
immediately jennifer's clueless she's
playing
what she's doing and bishop f2 why would
you play bishop f2
like just why
the bishop is great on e3 oftentimes it
hits the pawn on h6 that's a good
question and what was her move rookie
very quickly
knight to c2
but now you have to start wondering
another work another uh
weird move you you would think
that the bishop would go back to f1 and
the knight is good on d4
it's a good knight i think she's trying
to stop sophie from playing bishop to d8
bishop to c7
because bishop to d8 queen takes d6 and
bishop to c7
well i don't think she calculated or i
it after this point and it's a draw
we are going to see uh
five five armageddon five player
armageddon player versus player five of
them now they're gonna need a break guys
because they just play they can't play
right away so you should be did you say
five player armageddon
sorry another
tie bricks so how would that work
because
if they keep playing each other we're
gonna be here all night yes why not
well that's actually a very good
question because five player
round robin that's going to be taking
two tables at the same time it will
still be uh
like playing one game at a time so that
we can really
enjoy
[Music]
enjoy two players at the same time but
that's like
whoa whoa
wait a minute did sophie hang upon
that is a pond sack on d6
that's not a pond sack that's a pawn
blunder that could be a palm blunder
well bishop to c7 is coming followed by
knight to h5 maybe it's not that easy i
i don't think it's necessarily
blundering i mean bishop c7 okay i'll
just bring back the queen let's say
queen d2 blunder
magic yasser you don't believe in magic
i trust
i don't even miss mistakes
first of all uh this queen this bishop
sorry are piled up on the diagonal if i
play f4
followed by e5 i'm shutting down by that
diagonal but you don't i don't no why
not what do you play now f4
knight takes g3 h takes g3
i just shut down your diagonal i'm upon
up
i don't believe it yes sir i mean look i
understand reality does say that you
have a pawn up but i don't have the two
bishops and i really like
your compensation i'm looking for
compensation
she played the four
four is on the board
f4 is on the board and by the way what
if i go no i cannot go knight g6 because
you pick up my knight on h5 correct so
now i'm forced to take on g no choice
about it whatsoever knight takes g3 is
as we say forced
or box
box forced
knight takes g3 h takes g3 and i don't
have to shut you down right away you go
knight g6 i might play a move like
bishop f3
or
i like bishop f3 instead of moving the
knights first can can there be a rook
to d8 yes that's a tempo
cool
but
i don't believe this bomb sacrifice i
really i really don't not when the queen
and the two bishops are huddled yes if
your pawn was already on b5 and you were
making some pretense but the problem is
with b5 you might just get hit by c5 and
get shut down so something like bishop
f3 you know
i like your bishop f3 but i also don't
like that rip d8 can just come and
tickle my queen can i just play queen e3
let it be where it is
sure but why can't you do that after
bishop f3 rook d a queen e3
but then what if b5
well i shut it down c you'll play c5
yeah all right
she played bishop f3 now
i was trying to see if i can do some
tickling with knight except for
you can sacrifice but you're already
down 93 at the end yeah you're you
you're sacrificing uh
[Music]
already down material yeah
i think she just blundered
the pawn uh did
uh sophie and she's scrambling focus on
something along the lines of b5
she's yeah she's scrambling for her
compensation
and
she played f6 to stop
e5
x
i can get behind that move
queen e2
um again i think white's taking over
here oh b5 you cannot take because of
bishop to b6 but b
but c4 c5 yes that might be a problem
it's game uh that i agree protected i'm
going to go c5 and b4 she might be going
she is reaching
yup
c5
that's just a huge advantage now
jennifer has a very very big grip
on the queen cider extra pawn has become
a protected pass pawn i didn't like this
move b5
by sophie maybe bishop d6 would have
been a
try but no uh now jennifer
extra material
and she's got
and she still has four minutes on the
clock four minutes to
how much that should be more than enough
seven and a half
okay
um if you don't have the move b5 b4 you
know you got to do something to stop
white from playing b3 b4 herself
oh pardon me um any e5 is going to be
met by f5 please don't i'm just
since we said round robin do they still
play
like is there going to be another game
after this
for these two there's going to be three
games
jennifer or sophie will stand down after
this game yeah and talia will step in
to play so i thought that jennifer was
playing sophie as white and then they
were switching colors and playing again
that would be a double round robin uh i
think this is a single it's a single
round yes yes
so we have one more game after this one
i'm not 100 who's sitting i'm thinking
the position has become so desperate for
sophie at this moment i start thinking
about knight takes f4 and bishop takes
f4 and takes c5 the board she doesn't
realize she's just slipping away after
b4
to me
the game is virtually
a done deal like sealed
sealed and wrapped and now we see knight
coming to c6 and immediately i will be
playing
[Laughter]
a4
uh get your queen to c4
i'm comfortable with a3 as well
a4 queen c4 bishop g5 would have been
special bishop g4 now
yeah but if your queen was on c4 or
it would be splat okay uh
very very nice it's all about the clock
now can uh jennifer hold her nerves
she's got a win winning position can she
hold her nerves and play well with her
clock
two minutes behind on the titan two
minutes behind yes
two and a half minutes actually three
minutes and 31 seconds for jenny for six
minutes for sophie maybe try to go queen
to eight put some more pressure on the
long diagonal
but you you're you're hitting me
on the e4 pawn where i've got it
defended
it doesn't improve my case
too much
okay wait uh but you got to do something
my define is kind of winking at me
well again she's desperate she's trying
if i go f5 the desirable f5 just shut
everything down she wants to play knight
d4 and hope
that white will be kind enough to open
up the long okay okay no this this move
has been
pretty decent
ask your opponent to spend some time i
mean you're in the description right
exactly that's what you got to do i i
agree
at this moment i don't think
anything could hurt uh your lost
position there are some there's some
tactics for example if you go knight d5
knight d5 now right now i take on f4 you
take back with the pawn
yeah let's go 95. i don't want to put it
on the board because i want to
leave the for the audience so yeah just
oh got it got it yeah and then rook
takes d5 at the end and you cannot take
with the e pawn because
the pawn is pinned how about you take
with a rook then bishop takes f4 how
about jennifer tossing in a trade of the
rooks first that's probably the best
rook takes rook takes and eight dropping
in on d5 that might be the best way
forward yes
we have talia cervantes they're rather
interested uh participants yeah i'm
curious would she uh play
like with what color
we're gonna ask our production oh she
played knight d5 right away jennifer
wait a minute that made it a little
spicy wait a minute eight days four yeah
i'm gonna have that root takes d5 that's
exactly right that was why we needed to
trade up i think that's gonna hook and
she took immediately but now rook takes
d5 is a serious question
no doubt about it does that completely
change the assessment of the position
she's got queen b3
we got queen b3 oh queen to b3 what a
beautiful move what a beautiful story
setting up a discovered check still if
i'm in sophie's
i'm going to play rook d takes to eat
i'm going to take on f4
take on f4 and i'm going to play rook
and she's done it she's took it on f4
and rook takes d5 and queen b3 and force
my opponent to find that hidden resource
queen b3 so you're praying that she
doesn't see queen b3
yes
and i would play king h8 of course after
queen d3 i've got a dark square bishop
hitting the rook and
[Music]
no i'm losing but okay but what else am
i supposed to do 97
well she's gonna take the bishop and
there goes the two bishops at the same
time at least she's playing against her
opponents only two minutes on the clock
and they're not getting any increment
it's a two second delay by the way
what it's delayed i apologize i i
misread that i also thought it was a
plus it is delayed 94. very very good
move by jennifer she's setting up for
queen check and knight e6 and she's
looking at that possibility
knight
to g6
guys tickling it's that easy no i get it
she's winning but i don't think it's
that easy no no i agree uh
i'm starting to
think about the move c6 but i love the
fact that i have a protected passport i
don't want to spoil it i'll play g3
style g3 is really good it's just you
know chill puts a little salt in the
wood exactly if you don't like g3 but
how about 92 allows me to go bishop c6
and at least i'm not going to see that
pawn land on c6 anytime so how about
knight f5 knight d6 ideas
yes
queen between the first three characters
she throws in a check so there is a
knight e6 sighting that's what she's
looking for and
how did you know
she's playing with white she's wearing
white sneakers
i'm interviewing her quite often ah
that is the part we don't see
we you you had inside information on us
uh nice
below a minute
seven seconds left wait a minute rook
takes d1 all right rook takes d1
ah and then she no but if she solidifies
her knight with f5
then knight comes to e5 i don't like
that no that's not good
she she said look i don't have to trade
rooks and give you the
the d file now the move i was thinking
that jennifer might want to consider is
bishop at h5
bishop h5 there's a back rank mate no
she played f5 at five very quickly i
don't know if this is the right i don't
know with that knight landing on e5
that's a compensation getting this is
getting difficult right now
44 seconds left in the game she lost
she ended up with a bad bishop
she ended up and what she just did this
move f5 she could end up with a bad
bishop on
f3
there's one trick in the
position don't take on d1 if you go 95
nightmares or
what
wow
what are
they are blitzing out some moves here
they're throwing the paddies what's
going on christian they certainly are
throwing the patties and it does seem
like jennifer is still completely
winning she still completely wins yes
but it doesn't matter she has 40 seconds
on the clock there's a move bishop takes
e4 that's a crazy move there's a knight
e2 check and a knight takes c1 yes
bishop takes e4 just to that's a move
just to throw in some something crazy
absolutely and you have to do it you
have to go for it very upsetting when
you have no time on your clock
you have to go for it she needs to find
something and she needs to find it quick
because her only chance right now is
jennifer's time
and she's done it she's done it
she's seizing her moment
jennifer did not see this when she
played rook d6 i probably 35 seconds
35 seconds oh man oh man oh my gosh
seconds because we're getting close
queen e3 oh girl no you got 25 seconds
she's done three she played it ooh and
d8 is hanging so you may have to sophie
may have to stop and play rook takes d6
because
knight takes d eight okay
six and then bishop takes f5 wait a
minute maybe rick takes c6 what are we
looking at right now i have no idea
and bishop takes f5 and the position is
it it's crazy that's why maybe rook
takes c6
maybe white can start with queen takes
tonight that's
that's a decision that you should ask
your opponent to make here we go it
happened very fast rook d6 takes takes
takes on evil this is not looking as
easy whoa sophie is
uh
the excitement uh deserves a good sneeze
i must say uh ten seconds smooth no it's
delayed she's not gonna win there's
delay guys oh this is getting so close
queen takes e6 or bishop takes e6
i was trying to sidestep rook c7
you like queen take c6 okay yeah i was
trying and she likes it too
rook c7 jennifer
well the problem is there's only one
check right no i don't have much more
after that i don't see the check queen
takes two e1 and then king to h2 queen
takes d6 oh what am i saying no no no no
the rook is on e8
oh my and now it's on d8 okay and
jennifer's reaching
six seconds rook three seven this is
nice what a move oh my goodness there's
a back rank mate queen to c8 the only
move right
f6 after that you will have to contend
with that worst end game i don't think
you want to see that on the board
queensland bishop to b7 that's a
question as well and then defend the
bishop from c2 that's one way queen c4
is another way better than that
she checked
that's a piece she missed that she
missed the piece she was looking for the
perpet no but now queen to f4 queen to
g3 this is it guys pipette right there's
no problem five seconds queen h6 there's
no way this is
queen c1 rookie one that's it
queen c1 rookie one rookie one rookie
one
lucky one jenny for three seconds
no
she's not gonna and the pieces are not
on the proper squares that c1 queen is
on d2 c2 c1 rook d1 that's what seconds
on the clock for jenny for you to finish
this game with no increments only
queen b6s on tape almost pre-moved queen
b6
come on
oh jennifer you cannot take on d6
because a queen takes easy says
mate that same background mate
keeps rearing its head queenie said
queen 7 is coming queen e7 is a pre move
for jen
how many seconds two seconds
oh and the u.s
girls championship is on the line
in 12 seconds not yet on the line but
definitely taking a big step forward
with the victory okay where is that
still two seconds is that e4 or e3 e4
okay thank you for that queen b7 is
jennifer's intent you have to make a
luft queen
queen c66 e6 has to be played sidestep
the queen trade d7 let's go push push
push push push one no
two seconds check go check king to f1
hides
okay queen c7 and queen c8
guys everything is protected
oh bishop to d5 and that's it yes
oh mate with two seconds
oh
sophie is like oh my gosh two seconds
how did you checkmate me in two seconds
oh my goodness i have a feeling we just
saw
the women's champion the girls
championship pardon me um
outstanding
i mean uh thrilling thrilling chess at
the very end as jennifer takes the first
win and do we know
when the seniors start
this either way should be on their way
guys oh my gosh
no rest for the weary well it's a great
time to take a 50-minute break i want
you guys i i agree there is no break for
the weekend guys we have four rounds in
the senior section actually everybody's
going to play each other
i still vote coin toss but i think it's
too late for me too
did i tell you
oh i don't have
i've i'm at the playoffs
yeah it's there it is okay round one
nope yep
no this is the actual tournament keep
keep scrolling all the way down gosh
i'm sorry i'm not playing oh my gosh it
looks terrible i gotta go all the way
down again all the way to the playoffs
oh
and i
that's how i got to it
it's not showing up on my
screen
it's a good thing we have a big board in
france
oh boy okay uh sorry everybody as we
will just watch the games
for the moment yeah i'm not saying it's
on my board you just have to refresh
but yes you're right uh the playoff in
the seniors is actually not yet there
and there is the board position so cool
but i think we should probably just
leave it with the actual bird's eye view
since we don't have um
we don't have the board on yours yes
there's something wrong
i don't have it either um
f10
where's my refresh after
that guy
still nothing
no uh i don't have it i'm sorry so
the game unfortunately is not live uh
relaying right now i see i see there
playoff number one but unfortunately
it's not there
beautiful
and that is the current position we have
there we go the bird's-eye view
and where was this from what uh opening
are we seeing here that's a good
question
maybe a scandinavian as well okay max
said it wasn't a one-hit wonder i'm
willing to play it
as well and maybe come up with some
improvements along the way and it seems
like he did
how do we assess this position right now
it definitely seems like white still has
some pressure a lot of space advantage
on the queen side but outside of that
does he have anything else in the
position
they're spending so much time thinking
no no i mean we need to make some kind
of a transfer
of the knight on c3 to some wonderful
square
if i put the knight i don't know on b6
i might try to etch
somehow but no i don't think i think
has defended
the opening very very well and by the
way that is not the only game we have we
also have dmitri grevich versus larry
christensen which is uh right now
exploding really it is exploding indeed
okay so they play the same colors
as dimitri versus larry and it's a pawn
storm wicked
wicked looking pawn storm
almost from the pillsbury attack my
goodness black has a pawn out but there
is a pawn storm brewing
right g5 a lot of compensation but
is it enough is the question
you know with this time control i'm just
going to say
the initiative is worth so much
i wouldn't want to be in larry's shoes
you were taking the initiative yeah
facing this very very fearsome looking
strikes
against the king side take on h6 f4 f5
and
it's so much easier to play the
attacking the attacker's role
in these uh
in this time control and the time is
right now it seems like dmitry 6 minutes
and 22 seconds larry dropping down to
his 6 minutes and 15 seconds
wonderful wonderful
we got this
we got this i know we got this done
you guys are doing great
i'm trying to figure out when does the
other for the girls
and by the way i think it's talia versus
jennifer will be uh our second matchup
bishop takes age three what
he he he's feeling the pressure
and he
didn't want to open up his king so he
went for some sacrifice
take take on f6 take on f6 and rook to
d1
correct to save the bishop so you've got
but larry will have three pawns
but is that enough
mathematically yes
thank you thank you thank you for the
experience you're welcome coach i did
you know
ivy yeah you're gonna get a bill
i know i'll expect it
so we've got three
playoffs going
simultaneous
check that last move out knight to d5
this one is going to be explosive but we
are hearing that chabalov is actually
dominating
what did it happen
because we kind of thought that max was
doing oh max overlooked a cheapo knight
b5 tactic
and
was forced to exchange the light square
bishop for the knight but also damage
his pawn structure and that's more
exactly in the process exactly and we do
have this current position there was a
knight b5 there was a black bishop on d3
hanging
whoa
everybody's pawn structure is spoiled
yes
is such a target in this position
true um
so i see rook to b8 as pretty much the
only move that actually defends that
pawn
right
i mean take the passive approach but
then you have to contend with even ideas
that's what he played with the idea of
rook takes that is exactly what he
played right
so i want to play
for the dark squares which means my
queen
should be hitting
e3 and g3 so an ideal spot will be c7 or
e5 you and maxime are two tacticians
i don't know about that i i'm more of a
survivor
but rook takes d4 i mean
shabbat will instantly recognize this
hover hover f1 well that attacks two
pawns at the same time and maybe a move
that was missed queen to e5 immediately
played creating some more attacks on g3
oh wow so heating up everywhere guys let
me just jump sorry and i do apologize to
every every fan out there as i jump back
to the larry versus dimitri gervais game
because guess what dimitri said you can
have an exchange he could have taken and
played rook d1
no
he said i want the two bishops you can
have three pawns
and
um
this is i don't know it's for dimitri
right yeah larry's king
again one of their elements a couple of
moves away from getting checkmated right
something like
that how about just you know who's the
king
h2 exactly very good move yep i think
that's the right approach in this
position h2 and
open for the rook on the g line right
that is the right approach in this
position who
and he went with
my initial thought no but i i don't you
know the more i looked at king h2 the
more i i warmed up to it king h2 right
now what if just check
and then king h2 i got no choice but but
i don't have the rook to bring anymore
but there's bishop takes f5 coming this
is what he's got that is the problem but
she wrote d8 as the only move in the
position right
rook
cd8 but after that what if i just simply
take on f5 with the rock with the rook
yeah well how about the queen g6 you
move the king queen g4
and trade queens
that looks like
i think it's a very good option to try
to get the e2 square under control
and he
larry
forward
with the same idea he went queen hunting
the queen queen to g3 is going to be met
by g4 makes sense
but in that case i could pick up the f5
phone with the tempo against the rook
that is absolutely right
that is a dorsa that's absolutely right
but i'm learning my pawn meeting
uh i
okay once again sorry
everybody our apologies because we've
got so many games
uh going on right now we're gonna just
jump once again to shibala because he
might be crashing through whoa whoa whoa
that's a white pawn on his head there
he's a white i thought that was i
thought it was a black
honest engine
the pawn on b7 when i left this game was
black
and there was two targets
and now it's it's through the magic of
transformation it's become a white pawn
okay uh
times please dorsey uh maxine has four
minutes and
chabal of 3 41.
oh boy oh boy well that bond on b7 that
says it all for me
i think that that's sufficient for
victory but
with these times
rook
to b8
kind of
queen to f4 i like that move okay
that's going to force the trade of
queens but it does indeed and then rook
the c1 followed by rook to c8 how do you
stop that
uh nothing i'm gonna defend the rook
with the knight and then you'll go
bishop c6 but then all you're going to
do is pick up a knight is that
sufficient i see what you're saying yes
sir well
so they're going to answer our questions
queen takes f4 i don't think there's any
other way around bishop takes b4 rook to
c1
there's queen c3 right now but i don't
think you want to do that queen c3 queen
c3 queen takes b8 queen takes c1 king
2h2 and that seems to finish the game
that might be a coronation
97 check on tap in that variation you
just mentioned
as well as queen takes f8 and queen
um so i think
we're partying with the ladies here
queen takes f4 bishop takes b4
uh seems to be no knight to d7
to d7
wow
okay so what if i continue with my plan
take oh so this is what he's trying to
do he's trying to stop the invasion of
the rook via the c file with knight to
c4
but still take take you can go via the a
file
there's
another way
of getting a rook to the eighth rank and
that is rook not oh i could go rook c1
and then rook a1 i like that yes and
then knight to b6 though
okay i still go rook to a8
correct and how is that end game how
easy is that in games bishops of
opposite color so long as i'm picking up
b5 right away i don't think you are
well we may be heading right to those
waters
as he has played the move rook c1
inviting knight c4 rook a1 i don't think
you are i mean and he seems to have to
go knight to c4 because
bishop to b4 rook to c8 is a resignation
that's a check you don't have to
actually go to d7 you have to yeah
he played rook a1 right away
now knight to b6 is forced all right
okay
and then once again rook to a8
you gotta you could go knight d7 with
bishop c6 oh by the way i took b6 rook
to a6 oh
i wanted to eat ponds
i was thinking you're okay if i just
pick up the beef one
no i can't take the rock i don't know oh
i mean after knife p6 after night yeah
okay that one i can get behind
definitely
uh because you you'll do it with the
tempo
that's very nice i i like that and by
the way just give you an update on talia
versus jennifer talia is crushing right
really oh no you mean i gotta pick up
all right let's stay with this one
because that one just started so they
still have a lot of time left when you
say it just started you mean italia is
winning it right out of the opening they
started like
maybe five minutes ago five six minutes
ago okay so
they still have six and a half minutes
and six minutes for talia this is where
you were i like rookie eight but uh
the move rook
i don't see you taking that b5 pawn rook
a5
right now ah rook 35 first yeah
doris is saying she's a pawn grubber too
i'm trying
she wants some membership i see
something else brewing i mean this is
the same
four
okay he's saying rook a8 is not going
away excuse me bishop takes b4 now
knight takes b5
well
can i go just on ic6 case
what a7 he's getting ready to go knight
to c6 right to c6 banking everything on
this idea of just picking up the rook by
itself correct
that's what he's hoping for no rook a8
we're not exchanging anything i'm not
allowing you to get back in the game in
any way shape or form
i'm going to get a full rook in this
position well are you though i go bishop
c5 bishop c5 knight
c6
night moves ninth war moves knight d7
then you take the rook i take your rook
you take my knight that's not good no
that is not good
but it's the only way else is the only
way to continue the game he has to go
for it
50 something seconds 55 50 seconds and
shabala right now dominating the game
wow
how is it
we get a five
player playoff and i don't have a horse
in the race
seriously right i
said joel
oh you're so close i was
amazingly enough larry christensen did
draw his game with dimitri gurvich and
by the way excuse me but what's
happening right now why the knight c6
came out of the blue but bishop to d6
doesn't that cover yes it does and won't
the knight on b6 if you he played it so
confidently but what is the follow-up
right now
what do you mean what is the follow-up
for white precisely
we were confused
he shook his head
so he missed it yeah rook and knight to
d7 and
the game get the knight there's a new
what is shabbat doing he's messing it up
he is indeed well at least the other
pawn might be rook to a8 perhaps what is
he doing
what this just doesn't feel right i see
rook to b6 followed by knight to c6 but
then
rook to d6 is going to come on the board
you cannot do that
okay okay now
so you play king h7 get the king in
and any knight c6 any knight say six is
going to be met by rook to d6 20 seconds
for maxine lugia and let's not forget
there's no increment
wow he has to make a move right now oh
rook d5 let's go rook d5 let's go oh
he's running out of ideas no he let him
queen
and resigns
he could have played rook to d6
and max is shaking his head
and uh
shibalov has one by the way draw
in the larry christensen dimitri game
and i want to go immediately
to the girls where let's go for it
talia seems to be having a wow
that means that sophie has one more
chance at tying this thai bricks i don't
know if she wins with white pieces
against talia right in the next round
where is
the playoffs
where am i
if jennifer makes a draw right now
yes
well she has at least eight tie breaks
in her pocket against aliyah exactly who
will be facing sophie next round exactly
if she wins if jennifer wins she
clinches exactly
that is exactly the situation and
jennifer has black against talia but
jennifer is getting her pieces all
pinned up that rook on h8 is
oh my goodness that is monstrous it's
not looking good
and okay so how do you get rid of this
pin that's
nice to see you gotta go like f6 king f7
knight c5 i kind of like
let's go knight c5
there's no blocking the the the the
check the problem is that after that you
have to go knight d7 back if you want to
get off that oh yeah you cannot write d3
it's a checkmate oh my goodness so
because this
this
pin is so very unpleasant i was looking
to play f6
and king f7
knight c5 king d7
how did we get out of the spin knight c5
let's go queen d2 right that's why
don't allow the king to go one two she
went knight c5 she liked your move that
is a good move
if you do say of course
how do you feel about
not good not good not good i i'm i'm
thinking that if i'm in jennifer's shoes
i want to play a5 right here right now
if it was my turn i would play a5 if you
took the pawn then i'd sink my knight
queen three
[Music]
wow but this perhaps allows me to go
queen to d6 right whoa
what queen to david says where are you
going with that queen she's going to d3
i i want to try to find some uh some
checks as well so you take on g7 then i
go queen d3 and well
oh boy
oh boy
you can see she's been her wheels are
spinning and she's thinking to herself i
should have done this i should have done
that don't beat yourself up after a loss
don't do it it's just
you don't deserve it first of all you've
made it to the championship playoff give
yourself some slack
she's she's played well but she is super
nervous
queen c3 threatens queen takes g7 once
again
f6 maybe runs into queen a3 i also just
realized yes if jen if jennifer wins
this yes she's done correct that's it
she's a champion that's what we just
said i i think i zoned out for a second
it's a really good show
i was i was still under the impression
that there will be more and more and
more no she wins that's 26 best movie in
the position guys you got you called it
queen
it's not easy anymore
it is not easy anymore because
that queen finally gets in play
how do you continue as white uh queen
takes
i don't even think that i really don't
think you want to take that one is queen
d3 is
is a would win actually because there's
a hidden yeah knight b3 check oh that's
painful queen
that is pain it might be
beautiful
yes
c1 knight to b3 a takes b3 c takes b3
check and also queen to c2 coming on the
board mate
that's a mate a forced mate and she
could easily fall for that right right
well she played the move queen c3 eyeing
that long diagonal and looking at that
g7 pawn now we'll tell you recognize
that queen d3
is too powerful a counter and do
something
a little bit more steady like maybe a3
and king a2 or maybe queen a3
and just say
bishop to a shield g4 targeting that's a
crafty move oh i also uh wanted to
mention that i got a message from tony
rich saying
uh first place is not split prize money
nope not a split right you win you win
you
by the way
can't we do the same thing now queen no
queen takes f4 bishop h8
no i don't have any eight you have a
check
but then i cover with queen to c1 i
think that should be enough exactly
queenie one also comes wisely and
no rook c7 rook d8
jennifer what is the clock very crappy
oh by the way i have to say
one below one minutes 30 for jennifer
and what's the situation if jennifer
goes for rook to d8 which makes a lot of
sense never exactly queen to e5 does
that finish the game
rook to d8 queen e5 we exchange the
queens and how do you defend the bishop
on the knight on c5 that's a monstrous
pin i have to go back you cannot the
rook because my
[Music]
d8 loses after queen to e5
so i'm thinking in that case i may have
to play rook to
c6
i'm feeling uh feeling a little squeezed
here but i'm also feeling three seconds
40 seconds for jennifer the clock rook
to c6 was played
nice two minutes and 10 seconds you can
feel the nervousness there's jen i don't
know if we have a shot of the feet the
shaking the shaking of the the feet but
boy that rook kind of slid up to c6
30
9 seconds 39 seconds is it time to make
a looft for that's what i was thinking
a3 king a2 get your king out of dodge
maybe a4 maybe just to mess with them
spicy
it's not like your pot is gonna take it
no but or you're nice throw your pawns
all the way up uh i wanted to give a
shout out to the club because one of the
things when i was doing the gm and res
is i love the fact that they were having
these weekly blitz nights oh yes thank
you
talia
was in there throwing the paddy she's a
very good blitz player
and uh yeah so
uh
talia's probably feeling like as far as
the playoffs concerned she likes the
format
and charot
good job look i'm sure tony rich right
now he's in croatia getting ready for
the grand chest tour is two o'clock in
the morning
so he's still watching the show that's
dedication right there that's right
by the way tony don't forget send me my
check
[Laughter]
whatever you do
and he is also reminding us that there
is
a ten thousand dollar scholarship for
the soul winner absolutely absolutely oh
and by the way wait what's happening ten
seconds what is happening in jennifer
f6
g7 okay and maybe queen e5 check guys
but king a2 again on king a2 seconds
play king a2 absolutely you played with
three follow it up
out of danger e5 she's going for the
kill she's going for the immediate kill
right wait a minute there is queen you
can go quickly three check
where did that queen fly i
thought it slid all the way it did too
he did it
how many seconds two seconds
oh oh a replay
one second one second on the clock she's
not gonna no no
time okay maybe not no time yet no time
yet
one second now remember they're playing
delay
oh that's it that's it that's it that's
it
talia cervantes
has fought her way
back and now
one more
draw guarantees talia the the the the
championship sophie
situation
[Laughter]
wait wait wait wait wait wait
talia does have drawers let me think
about this so if
sophie wins
i like that she's dance walking let her
have fun
i like it
it will be a tie and they will have
another
let's jump to the scene oh my gosh
i'll i'll i'll put that dance move in
our training regimen
let's go for it i'm ready oh my goodness
my goodness all right what's happening
in the and by the way let's not forget
the seniors are playing four rounds
of rapid chess we're gonna be here until
midnight guys
we will be here for quite a while i
would go ahead
attack me in
yes yes yes yes yes yes what do we have
there akopian versus shabbat so shabalo
playing his
consecutive game right now and a copy
i'm playing his first game ah yes that
is correct
and he was the odd man out sitting the
first round
and max delugey
versus dimitri
i don't know but this london system it
sure looks like
i don't know how he does it
but
max sure looks like he has a nice
advantage
who do you want yeah no i'm sorry i was
on the wrong game apologies
uh i'm switching i am now on the
vladimir okobian alex shabalov game in
the last move
by shabbalaf was b7b5
what did we think of those apples i like
that move i like that move c takes b5 is
on the board right now and after luke
takes p5 how are we going to answer that
change of pace in the position
are we going to go knight to c3 is that
what he's looking at well i'm looking at
this bishop frankly and i'm thinking
that's your best piece so after rook
takes b5 the move i would like to play
is rook to b
he did so i can play b3 and bishop b2
which he goes for
i like it trade off your opponent's best
pieces one thing about the copion he is
a definitely a very classical player he
understands this type of strategical
play very well oh bishop to g4 that was
a surprise
uh that's
doing a switch sure this is a very
strategic game i do believe that
vladimir is for choice but not too much
going on let's just switch
over to the max delugey dimitri
holy smokes
this is exciting uh
what just happened we saw a fork
followed by c3 takes check
wow
one two how many pieces are on the board
four pieces for what
four pieces for black but it's an extra
exchange but there's two twelve points
of response
um
one thing about fields he plays so
calmly
he just
look at max yeah max is like
speeding through his moves right well
that move oh i was about to say bishop
c4
would have been my very first choice i
would probably grab that bishop and said
go ahead take my pawn and
invite you to capture on f3
and then
i've got my development complete once
the play will takes a1 rook to d8 was
played i like this move bishop to e2
but isn't this pretty much over for the
knight on a1 and if that's the case then
if you lose that knight i think it's
just over
that's
i i don't think you're getting that
knight out
bishop to e2 was a very crafty move
bishop to d3 was what dmitry wanted to
see on the board and then
knight b3 would have right i'm on the
board but bishop to e2 just kills the
game right now
something quite interesting about the
girls uh today italia beat sophie in the
classical the the the
longer time control right
in that game sophia needed a draw to
secure heroin exactly in this case
italian is a job to secure heroin right
the earlier victory in the classical
game
uh which uh and you just mentioned
six was played pawn takes and again v7
this knight is lost just completely lost
it's not because i go rook c8 knight c2
wow what rook to c8 followed by knight
to c2
um
bishop to b7 is on the board right now
yeah the
wow
he's getting up
yes my board is up to date yes by the
way the transmission there there has
been rook takes b6 pawn takes b6 bishop
to b7 on the board
and again i i'm thinking that max should
not have captured this pawn on e4 that
he should have played bishop c4 uh does
the engine agree with me christian
uh i haven't been watching oh sorry
sorry i don't know oh okay i thought
that you keep an eye on the engine sorry
no no no these games are too fun without
the engine
you guys have too
too much heart right agreed
i'd be
i'd be eyeballing the engine and be
saying this is advantage bishop to c4
was indeed the right move but even here
right now knight f3 and played with a
little i would want to say a little bit
extra emphasis
rook c8 you're still opponent as white
right dimas trying to save his knight
and bring it out of purgatory
shaq and knight c2
you could almost pre-move knight c2
and the lugi needs this win
he fell
he because he lost to shabbat in the
first round
he needs to win this one if not he's
almost out of this tournament
then the fight for first yes yes from
the side breaks
three minutes and 21 seconds for dimitri
guravage six minutes for maxim lugi
and by the way instead of knight to f3 i
think
maybe king to b2 would have been an
easier choice
just to pick up tonight exactly
um but he did not small news from the
latest section bishop to c4 inviting
knight c2 sorry what's your smallness
well sophie does have
advantage yeah okay
and the time if you uh bring me back to
that game uh will lead the scene
to the other
yeah one more one more ah
one more actually go yep
yes yes let's switch over
and
again because the seniors are having
too much fun well there's there's a lot
more playoff games than the seniors and
then a lot fewer in uh the girls and
wait what do we have she doesn't have to
give up her bishop here it was an
advanced gambit that i think talia
misplayed and
i'm quite surprised sophie had that
upper sleeve very nicely done well a5
she could have played bishop c5 she
doesn't have to keep up the full piece
in this case that was a mistake and so
somebody has full time
once again her style huge mistake by
talia
she overlooked bishop c5 and the fact
that it's bishops of opposite colors
this bishop was coming to a3
and the pawn on c7 was hanging as well
big advantage it looks like to my eyes i
i hate to be the
bad news
[Music]
i'm just
i'm
i'm going to talk to my agent
i agree
no more broadcast that's a german you
got
have a nice life everybody
knight c6 now i'm taking that i'm taking
that if you take with the queen i'm
trading queens
that's so pretty i mean that's just
still a piece
what what do you mean a piece i mean
white wins a piece i'm sorry why did i
think there was a
oh you know what never mind guys we have
to move back to the seniors because they
have way less time than our ladies and
i'm sure we will be able to get back to
this one ready for
flip yeah
let's do it one more
there we go and by the way it does seem
like gravity has fought his way back
into this game remarkable remarkable i
am on the game between a vladimir
okobian
versus alexander shabalov shabalov
having won
his first game
with white against dalugi
he's thinking
okay
just make some nice draw here with black
and he's got an active position as
queen's on e5 he's got these bonds
maybe they're hanging maybe they're weak
he's looking really good doesn't he
a5 right now i'm thinking black is fine
black is for choice i think for choice
yes even for choice
that would be
a stretch
but oh but what if i go c4 now
c4 in this this moment why not
okay i don't have to do it but what if i
did bishop f1
bishop to f1 maybe
if there was e4 would be uh to
too aggressive
so bishop c4 bishop f1 rook c5 rook d4
somehow i don't like this last move uh
a4 he decides to give up the pawn oh
i think that's a good
choice a4 i'm assuming take
well before before there's also
something to something to be said for
considering
but before can't i just take b4 c4
well if you take with the rook i'll take
the pawn on c5 deal i'll take that
trades
you take with queen i'll give you a
little dirty check from the back i gotta
go up and by the way h2 can anything be
said about bishop to f1
oh and now if you go rook a5 then i go
b4 the bishop f1 allows a yep
four takes b that's okay and i take back
on b3
uh
very clever
draw offered there by uh
shabala
and let's move to the lugi versus
gravity game because once again lugi is
having some difficulties right now he
might be even worse in this position
for sure why not one two three four it's
a lot of pawns that's a lot of pawns
but that'd be pawnee you just gotta make
sure that b-bond doesn't run run home
right now i'm seeing a thread of rook to
d8 and rook takes d5 that's a big one
right
that's a big one and i'm still picking
up that h7 pawn
so maybe you have it's time to hide the
bishop right let's go to each one let's
hide it right through
and oh also
dmitry is reaching and
almost all the way almost
by the way 42 seconds for dimitri by the
way g2 is better than h1 it stops knight
h3 well can i eat that pawn on each side
yes but then you're king it
whoa look at this he he wants to attack
the bishop that was great bishop g2
bishop
bishop h1 or all the way back
and slowly that's that's what worries me
about this game slowly dimitri doesn't
have the fastest hand repeating
yeah bishop to d5 to different i
guarantee you
this one takes the fun lookie plays for
a win because dmitry is playing very
slowly correct there is no increment
knight to f8 rook to d7 is a big threat
right now he did it and he's losing his
he's going to take the bishop wait a
minute who's first
he's good it is first rook 37 is going
to be met by rook to e4 that's a problem
rook to e7 rookie i thought he was going
to take him
take b7 e2 i queen
and then i go rook f3 check
b7
x
but you have to play it fast immediately
23 seconds and count you cannot play
this so slowly dima all right it's great
for good move
faster
sometimes 18 seconds
and
it's suddenly the e pawn is the big deal
thank you very much i'll take that one
e2 and king to see if he goes up knight
to d7
don't go king d3 why not
actually that's a good question you
can't even he saw he saw the check and
so but now this allows the king to get
back no it doesn't not quite so fast
rook to e king to f2 right now
right now
rook to e5
eight seconds for demon though and
take the night
take the knight
i don't think seven seconds
right now knight to d3 rook to e4
check
that's it that's lost this might be it
but he has seven seconds let's not
forget that two second
delay man i don't like this delay system
i hate my heart i think this is over i
hate it but
this might be over for max it's all
about the clock and demon as well
if he can make the moves in time he wins
but max is a
fantastic blitz player six seconds one
of the best i've ever seen
takes takes
and we go rook to h1
we take that guy as fast as we can so
that means this yeah
g5
no
no man the king is getting close no
oh
oh amazing oh
okay that's
that
that that i oh goodness oh just at the
very end uh
he had just no time let's switch to
uh the ladies uh
wow uh what to say uh
i don't like what i see here for italia
for
sophie for talia
hurt's a little those pawns are
those threatening pawns
that pawn on e6 looks like bishop b2
and talia is just
she's getting overwhelmed
she has a problem with her time as well
two minutes and 46 seconds and six
minutes for
sophie sophie has the central
preponderance that is just
well domination dominating the position
all right do you have an update on the
seniors
this is our situation with two games
played
or
more
alex tribalov is leading uh the
tiebreaks right now one and a half
points dimitri gurvish closely behind
and tied for third but with one game
less that is vladimir kopian larry
christensen and maxine doogie only half
that's an awkward graphic because some
people have played two games and some
people have played one yes that is
vladimir accopion is the only player
that actually played only one game okay
but you so larry lost larry lost the
first round
to
dimitri
wait a minute no no somebody had to sit
out in the second round because did
larry lose the first one no larry didn't
play the second round
he truly yeah he so he was another
player who only has one game that is
correct right
you misinformation
fake news
nice good one
we'll get out uh this one's at the same
louisiana group
by the way
bishop to a3
yeah that's what i'm thinking too i mean
she just put her rook on the same
diagonal the darks were diagonal as the
bishop
and that is like a visual you you
immediately zone in and you go bishop oh
she didn't a three no she's going for
queen takes f6 but
rook to you well
why would you ever
this queen is so completely out why
would you ever allow queen e2 bishop a3
still st
is on tap is she thinking about queen
takes f6 i i hope not
i have really hope maybe that might be
winning no it's not i have queen eight
at the end there's no way now no i take
and i go f6 i i i'm sorry
i don't have a bishop anymore i take
with the pawn
no
queen
oh i see what you're saying yes yes yes
yes i see what you're saying maybe
that that actually maybe yeah queen of
six maybe it wasn't a winning but
with the rook on f3
okay go ahead take this pawn i
understand bishop takes c5 but why would
you ever allow your opponent the rook
was on f3 right
now well there you go
sophie is giving her opponent a chance
to climb back into the into the game
with this active move that's still we
need to though
it might even be two pawns are very it
might even be two oh that's a very good
point there is an access that might be a
problem as well right
we do have on the board rook f88 you
don't have to pay attention to c6 after
queen takes c7 so maybe you don't want
to trade that
allow the trade of the c6 and d5 pawns
but even if c6 can i just
bring back i just think you have more
than that that's fair
no argument no it's not well
take the rook
take the rook can i be tricky and play
rook to b3 so i wanna i i like that eat
a little here eat a little in the back
i like uh b3 rook to b8 is a nice threat
nice i was thinking queen takes e7
uh rook b3 and
lady after my own heart i was thinking
if you play c6
i take your no
please
no you take you're going to do that go
d6
it's okay and i get e8
rooked it to a i got d7 er d8 exactly i
go rook
where
to
be
three by the way
but in this case i can
join my king and try and it's too fancy
too faster that's the fastest place
syndrome fancy play you don't want to do
that no we're looking right queen c
defend the pawn
right again at the moment sophie
needs a win
she wins this game
the tournament flares anew
talia is really thinking about it talia
on the other hand she's thinking if i
can just get this draw i win the
competition all right we need three good
moves i'm not sure about that
take on d5 and i go rook to g to d3 and
it's okay g6 g4
ah
g4 i'm gonna
as soon as i win the pawn on d5 i have
two pawns i'm nervous when i'm only one
pawn up g4 is a critical move let's see
if she plays it g4 and the times again
uh one minute 22 for talia two minutes
50. i i gotta tell you guys sophie
is saving her best for last this is a
great
game by who is this
sophie morris suzuki gal she is playing
her heart out
wow
and h5 but that doesn't help hold on
there's a g5 sighting g4 g5 oh my g5 i
take on f5 i take on it oh six and then
i take one take on e6 you're right
you're absolutely interested upon and
she did it she did it very calmly too
tyler is running out of pawns she sure
is
and opening up the g file
or g7 that's a check
king try to create some counter player
of the v8
right she's done that too
this is nerve-wracking stuff everybody i
mean
if i'm in
uh sophie's shoes i want to trade a pair
of rooks i want to play what she's going
for rook to d1 that's a good move and i
want to play rook d8 shack and rook to
d7 and rook to b2 is going to be met
with rook to d2 precisely that's a
really good move rook to d1
beautiful beautiful
so what are the by the way the senior
games started if you wanted to not right
now
we're not going anywhere
we're not going anywhere on this one
dorset this is it this is the big one if
if
if uh
pardon me if sophie can win she's gonna
force yet another
playoff and it's
this is for the title the other guys are
still playing check check let's go e7
the game is over
check exchange rooks e7
and
here it comes
17 seconds
g7 e7 it takes f5 go to g3 go to the h
file and that's it
five four
three
she's done it
so
rook d5 is the lazy man approach e7
requires calculation but e7 is the best
move yeah yeah this is it and that's
game
and one second
and
can you believe
guys we'll never get out of here
this is the longest we've had
all tied up oh yeah yeah
[Applause]
i guess this should be dorsal the
juniors aren't doing that
thank goodness christopher it's always
the street service guys
wow
all right this feels
this feels delicious let's go for it
like the gangsters are in town something
is going on yeah
uh up again
that's good that's good
okay we're bringing up the
playoff number three right
at this point i'm going to agree to
everything we got a bononi so perhaps we
can see the tie breaks graphic right now
so that we know what to expect from the
ladies section
because right now i think they are going
into a blitz tybridge is that correct
right a blitz tiebreak round robin i
believe it's three plus two meaning the
increment but last time they didn't
distinguish
whether or not
um they
were increment or delay
will this be increment that is actually
a very good question because this
graphic was misleading on the round rock
when you go plus two it's i want my
pluses i got
the increment not the delay
so we we will ask about that but uh
wow
uh
wonderful and the seniors still have two
rounds to go
before this part of the tie breaks is
going to be over and then if we don't
have a clear winner then they're going
to move on to another set of tie breaks
all right so it's official everything is
two second delay which is terrible i
completely agree no not just because
it's
it's not increment it's because nobody
plays delay
nobody
not in the grand chess tour
not in the field very american world
championships
not in the world cups
nobody plays delay so nobody has
experience
if we want to think about it like that
then the games won't actually go on
forever and ever and ever
yeah
okay i am going to go with the larry
christensen
versus max delugey position
and
whoa larry's got this monster knight on
the c6 square
ooh
that's a pretty nice that is a beauty
so
this looks like a queen's
gambit accepted where white got a lot
more than he usually does
knight b8 trying to
yeah larry just needed to get one more
move in like a rook to c1 kind of move
and he could have maintained his knight
right takes e7 he knew it
takes e7 queen takes c7 right d5
d5 of course what if i take that rook to
d rook to e1 oh my goodness yes sir
you're right you're enjoying yourself
remember i'm sacrificing larry's pieces
all right i'm not sacrificing mine but
knight takes e7 d5 that is my spidey
sense
wow
um yup i mean he's going for that bishop
and then this move d5 and max he must
not be very happy with the start for
this tie break for himself
larry is no match for max in
uh five minute chass
but in this weird time control where
it's double
the usual blitz by the way i like this
move rook that you want now d5 is a real
threat
for sure you go rook v8 i go rook d1 i
reinforce that threat
rook d8
why don't you play d5
rook d8 d5 if you take with the rook oh
i wanted to take the rook with the queen
queen takes d5 very nice yeah and he's
pl he's a loud d5 d5 is like
screaming
and larry yep here he goes things are
really heating up
it's red hot
i think he missed that home d5
e5 queen maybe to f5 pawn to d6
uh max on the back foot this is starting
to look really good and larry's sitting
back like i got this yes sir
what what did i call it with nick
california cool
he's showcasing that right right
larry e5 has to be played by the way i
don't think you can do anything else no
for sure you don't have to keep things
close to make a a massive weakness on
the e6 pawn max shaking his head not a
happy camper i have to say going into
these tie breaks if you would have asked
me who is the favorite i probably would
have picked max exactly just because he
plays
so much rapid and bliss chess online
where is that
well he's basically saying take my pawn
i don't know i don't want to have to
defend the position i'm looking for some
active piece plate now all right
question is
does he got any compensation i take take
and take with the rook
i just asked the question and then
knight to d5
now remember my bishop on h4 is
protecting f2
so i could go
like queen h5 for example that is
unfortunate that's a strong bishop
actually right this is oh wait a minute
no no no no you cannot take on e6
because i have queen d4 at the end
that's an attack on the bishop on h4 and
the rook on a1
so you cannot take that point
yeah
okay so it means we take on e6 and then
we start with queen h3 bishop g3
well we started with the e6 maybe d1
right why not rook d1 but queen h3 uh
christian
uh his bishop of jesus christ
thank you thank you
looking at that d6 square did you i
think i did i don't have a horse in the
race he's terrible it's not too late
well look i mean there's five players i
mean
i got half the field and i got it wrong
i mean
jeez uh bishop g3 okay what do we think
of this move
bishop to d6 is coming nightwing
all right
yeah this is right bishop to g3 somehow
it didn't feel like it's the right
direction right but queen to e3 we
exchanged that i take on g3 then i put
the knight on c5 i feel like i'm finally
having some chances okay that's why he
played queen e2 but he lost
his bishop
which was fortifying f2
to the max
pardon me that was not a pun
r-r-r
be very clever i i caught that i caught
up
okay now i like your rook d1
yes we have to go for it right larry you
have to play this and you have to play
fast and if you play rook d1 you've got
this nice little cheapo of knight d6
exactly and knight e4
so if you go knight to b6 for example
like a6 just finishes the game exactly
so rook d1 and this move larry should
not be thinking a long time about no
come on larry
let's go same move but faster correct
[Laughter]
was better
rook to d1
now rook to c7 seems to be one of ooh
knight to bc 96
he said for the cheapo he sure did
knight to d6 and knight to e4 and that
takes him immediately recognized
that he is
but look what he just did against dmitry
he forked demetrius king and rook
and he's falling for a night fork guys
max doesn't miss this type of tactics
that's why he's not used to that that's
why you see these faces because he
doesn't miss he's an expert in bliss
chess oh he's so formidable he doesn't
miss this type of tactics
yeah well the other thing though is he's
used to playing it on a 2d board
on a 3d board you know because he can
make 100 moves in
in under a minute max's uh when he's
playing online
but here and once again larry a little
california cool i got this i got this
knight e4 okay it do you ever uh
you it's time to go you never get along
at your opponents if they start doing
that if they look relaxed i like that
that's okay i can deal with that a lot
better than
the
he wants to take on e6 that was a good
move i like that move that was
oh that's the stylist
yes
and unless larry has under three minutes
there's no reason for max to play on
meyer has four larry's got it oh well
then it's just it's too easy knight
takes and queen takes e6 the rooks have
open files
and uh
did the girls game start yes
maybe we can move to this to that one i
think this one is going to be more or
less over okay just a second before we
move to the girls let me just
dimitri and
vladimir
oh that's crazy game
oh geez so larry and let's move to the
girls and the girls are playing blitz so
they're playing very fast-paced chess 38
seconds actually for jenny for you one
hour one minute and 45 seconds for
sophie mori suzuki and let's not forget
there's no increment no anger oh no
also wait a minute rook takes g5 uh
it's not no increment it's a it's a
delay right there's a delay yes there's
no increment yeah right
now regular hd5 there's a queen on d1
you would expect it to be a king on d1
and a queen on d2 it's actually reversed
knight takes f6 knight takes f6 check
on the board
and i've got the
h6
no you cannot rook h6 invites rook takes
g5 that is that is the threat right now
so
queen a4 check perhaps what is my king
doing i think she's going for it
yep
yeah and
not with confidence jennifer you know
his time is low again not as long as
usual 30 seconds that's pretty low yeah
sophie's move queen a4 check was not
played with a great deal of confidence
guys seven probably has to be pretty
nicely done jennifer
does black still have the right to
castle
that was question number one well
aston answered
yes
yes you were
rook takes g5 that's a winner rook takes
g5
rook takes g5 knight takes chief right
to e4 first
what what is happening right rook takes
g5 knight takes g5 knight g4 there's g2
a rook takes g2 sighting on yes bishop
takes d8 rook takes g2
jennifer but jennifer had a win on the
spot i think that's true with rook g5
knight g5 knight g4 i think
so what do we have right now no rook
takes g5 wins on the spot right now if
she finds it
no queen takes e4 no recognition
that's a check exactly knight takes g5
queen takes g2 and that picks the knight
as well got it and this the clock times
again nine seconds for jennifer 40
seconds
no jennifer is going to have two seconds
again get out of here i think so i mean
she's playing a little faster now bishop
g4 is a big threat bishop b4 is a big
threat as well rook takes d5 it's bishop
b4 i know we gotta go bishop a4 and then
i pick up the rook
nobody's talking to you christian this
is a private conversation go please go
away
she sees it she's oh that's what she
said
rook to e8 bishop to g4 so many tempting
wins seven seconds come on jeff six
seconds left for jennifer
queen to e6 keep the queens on the board
i like that
and you see when they don't have the
increments that the pieces slide a3
that's a good move square five seconds
down to five seconds okay
king d2 followed
that's it you take on e3 that's too easy
e2 what's five seconds
e2 queen to e4 let's go
and she's following your lead yes sir
bishop is coming to f4
h1 bishop to f4 oh sorry bishop to g3 on
the board and that's a queen
right five seconds ooh
and flying pieces and then we see a
resignation oh
there is
oh the same scenario guys saw this movie
before we did indeed
jennifer takes the first game and right
now she will be facing talia but with
reversed colors now she will be playing
with the white pieces against aliyah
okay uh bring me back to the uh seniors
for a moment something going on oh
that's that's it
larry is up in exchange
and how many pawns two parts somehow it
seems like max has survived up to this
point which is
not surviving that much longer king
takes g4
and again with a minute and change on
the clock knight to f1 check and h
a7 yes this one is not going anywhere
this is all shot
rook check f4
knight e3 check king
f3 and the queen is coming
the lady is making an appearance on the
board
true that
now this one is over there's just no
there's no even if you got rook g3 check
it wouldn't be mate
i'd have king h4 so no no
no
cheapos
he's trying
queen let's go
one check first
and now let's make the queen
nice good oh
chris berg makes an appearance that is a
legal legal move
so max will get two minutes of bonus
yeah you have to put the queen on the
board before you press the clock
he did he did push his pawn to a8
press the clock and then put the queen
this is the
this is the wrecked sink field
way to lose a game
but the rules have changed recently and
even in a blitz game they don't give you
a lost game no you get offense
you get a warning right so the idea is
he goes a a a8 you see he puts the pawn
but now
he should put the queen exactly before
he presses the clock instead he puts the
queen he presses the claw take it
anyways
no no no we're just talking about the
rules the game is over he resigned yeah
i mean i agree he resigned he got the
two minutes and then he resigned
he didn't get the ten minutes
he didn't get the committee that's
alright all right okay uh we are going
to jump to
uh the uh
demon versus vladimir gaming oh look how
stressful this must be the hands are
shaking well vladimir is down
two pots
one two three four five yeah sure looks
like two pawns
but
the bishop on d4 is fantastic it's
protecting a7
and it's hitting f2 where's the
if i were in demon shoes i would have
tried to put the bishop
on the e8 square
queen to a1 trying to checkmate from h1
yeah i would be
trying to play bishop to
e8
so that i
making way for
e5 and queen e4 i would like to see the
bishop on c5 i just don't like it on d4s
you would like it to be anchored right
understood understood
so some move like oops okay
that's okay by the way 11 seconds for
akopian
g4 are you kidding that makes a lot of
sense oh okay sorry
bishop takes g4 h5
by the way
and we go h5 is that the other why not
let's go for it oh first he decides to
defend that one our pawn
naked
this is where i want it and now you go
h5 wait are we going to see a repetition
no no way right
oh my goodness
wait bishop to g4 but that's a pawn
he did it in the very poor style he
could have had his bishop seven seconds
for a copy on he needs to make a
decision oh
that opens up the king it sure does
both
and quickly two seconds for a of
two seconds two seconds for a copy on
right now and there's another pawn that
drops okay another check
and
oh my god
is not gonna be able to make this happen
is this a draw i think it's a draw king
to d6 no
well maybe it's okay
because once we play like
it's okay
but i was about to say i thought king on
d6
oh it's a draw
wow goodness queen g3 was the mistake he
should have went to his website and we
we we've got the girls going i'm sorry
to
interrupt the pain the decisive
game now all she needs
actually no never mind
jennifer you if she makes a draw still
gives talia cervantes a chance to catch
up with her correct if she wins it's
over tournament is over no okay yes i
think
we we we've been here before
with the reverse scholarship with the
reverse cut now then in that moment
talia won and she
was in the situation that all she needed
was a draw and then sophie said no
tournament keeps going i i refuse
what
what a contest uh
seriously
you can play a career
of tournaments and not have
such an exciting playoff as we're
witnessing between these young ladies
my hat is often because i would be
nervous by the way isn't it better right
now
after the move c4
no
my hearts won't allow b3 e3
break up the team that pawn structure of
blacks on the queen side is really good
i like this move b3 just challenging so
let's go c3
c3 rook to t sorry and she's done it
and then we're gonna go rook to the e4
i apologize for even asking that
question of course you want to take that
with every fiber of my being knight a5
is a good move by the way bishop takes
d5 followed by knight takes b3 is a
threat correct so i love this move
knight to a5 okay well let's break it
down if i go b4
queen two c2 okay i like this move
that's a good move as well keeping the
knight um
offsides at the moment and b4 is a
threat
b4 right now is a threat
because followed by queen takes c3
exactly
and any bishop takes i i really wanted
to recapture with the rook she did play
rook c8 inviting
b4 right
knight to c4 right and then i take on c3
i take on e3 and i hope that i have some
sort of uh compensation which i probably
thought
rook
to d3 did jennifer
and uh we have to go for b4 now
defend that pawn on c3 right or bishop
f6 is a oh inviting no e5 pardon me
there is a queen on c7
by the way 57 seconds for jenny for one
minute for talia
i think
and just to remind everybody if jennifer
wins
she's the champion it's that simple if
talia wins
it they're all flares anew again
d4 bishop d4 we've seen a trade the
knight is headed towards f5 and the rule
sure is going to go swing to g3 and
create some serious mating threats maybe
it's time but not only that
but i'm thinking knight e2
and gift meet upon that's
that's a good idea
that c3 pawn is really bothersome i got
to tell you i i would really love
uh to get rid of it with the move knight
d4 to e2 will jennifer do it no
wow
knight to c4996
exactly jennifer
and the
game perhaps i can go knight to e5 at
that point
times third second third thirty three
thirty nine to see four and knight to c6
knight to e5
is the saving grace 33 24. call the game
who's going to win come on dorset
jennifer probably her her position is
better her time i mean her time right
now
if she's knight c6 95 is key if she
doesn't see it i think she's much worse
knight e5 95 right now she needs to pay
10
seconds knight e5 is a tough one
look at that boss move
queen takes and she says that fawn oh no
that's a problem she didn't i didn't see
it she didn't see it think
and queen takes the coronation of a
champion right now if jennifer wins she
wins
this is it guys queen to f5 seven
seconds for talia 27 seconds for
jennifer in an exchange and a winning
position six five
four a four the knight on c4 is tickling
the pawn on a3
get trade it off trade off your weak
pawn
jennifer 20 seconds
jennifer thinking still
pondering her options
jeez i don't
want to see two two seconds king h2
let's go
move
too slow too slow
move
queen f6 i don't even know who i'm
rooting for anymore
queen f6 seven seconds six seconds right
now
five seconds for jennifer you
that's a check
nice
that does not help you queen f7 queen f4
h4 h4 that's a mate
she saw the mate
and that's the game
[Music]
wonderful beautifully done by jennifer
you
that was one way of describing it
so she is a sole winner she does have a
secured place in the
2022 woman championship
she's got a bunch of money six thousand
and ten thousand you should go take your
shoes and i think she's ready for face
plants i just thought i was gonna say
just like oh
my goodness and in the meanwhile we have
more chess we do indeed as we see in the
background there
are our great congratulations to
um jennifer we'll get her in studio in
time but first let's go
to
the
seniors
we still have two rounds going the
seniors it's amazing
right now how do we uh stand in terms of
standings maybe do we have a graphic for
uh that i don't after two rounds of play
well three
three three rounds of play yeah that's
right oh we played three rounds we do
have the game between ocobian and larry
christensen looks like it's coming from
a petrov defense
so larry
only two games and he has one and a half
out of two
correct that is
that's a good score i think a good score
and do we have anybody on a perfect
score i don't think we do
right oh
it's a good question um no we don't have
anybody how does that mean
sorry blunder alert did larry just allow
queen a4 check
uh
excuse me queen a4 knight c6 d5 knight
takes c4
pawn takes
c6 that's beautiful calculation knight
to b6 and you take on b7 all right
let's take a quick look at
where we're at after four
max is out
he's played three games and he only has
one draw absolutely vladimir is in he's
played two games he has one point dima
is at 50 as well but larry leads along
with shybala
both larry and shabalov have won and
drawn so they are currently tied for
first but this game i'm thinking larry
finger failed
with the move knight d6 he was supposed
to castle you could also go on b5 queen
a4 check is on the board and larry's
gonna have to cough up material
because of this bad move so now he has
to go b5 and c6
uh well you're going to go bishop takes
b5 knight takes b5 queen takes b5 bishop
dc oh there's the bishop on e7 defending
yeah yes
but okay vladimir is going to win a pawn
for the two bishops
but larry's very fortunate he didn't
blunder a piece therefore maybe maybe he
saw it
you think he
maybe he set a trap and maybe he just
wants to play with two bishops and
control over the light squares okay well
that would there's a case to be made
that you have enough compensation you
know understood bishop takes b5 knight
takes b5
queen takes b5
c6
light squared bishop control castle
i'll say compensation i would say it's
not just a clean
extra pawn
absolutely there's definitely
compensation and by the way
i think another game that is going on
let me just check
and
vladimir did take the pawn uh let me
just check in with the game between uh
shabbalov
and dimitri it looks like a open
sicilian
dare i say dragon
intriguing
that looks like
looks like some sort of a dragon
will talia and sophie still play no no
so like no i'm
i'm just curious like how would they
know who gets second or third
there you go maybe they will have to
play to just because i do think
first is first yes but second and third
may be split i'm not sure so i just
and it's quite interesting because we
had this situation in the granchester in
romania and what the arbiters were
saying was that they will actually play
just for rating purposes oh oh
because you know when you input a
tournament in chess results
tony rich is telling uh the rest is a
split no player for second or third
so that's it for our ladies section
right second and third that that's fair
i mean after
playing so hard for first place all day
you know
also what time it is
i think three in the morning yeah good
well thank you but he's a diet hard he's
dedicated i mean he wants to know
what's going on at the club 24
you know
uh hours a day e6
knight before what is nema doing
he's getting himself into a a whole
world of hurt suddenly well i think
yeah actually this might be a big
problem i think oh yeah what he expected
was that he has d5 but that's nowhere
around the board right now because
knight takes e6 would come
rook rook c7 bishop to b6 that's it
that's an exchange i mean i may be able
to play on but it's not pleasant i'm
down material but he's losing
material regardless he has to go for it
he has to go for it just because of the
fact that you have to vanquish your dark
square bishop
for shabala if he wins that would
pull himself up to play too many people
ahead of larry christensen
ahead of larry christensen very much
defensively is this the last round guys
we still have one more right yeah
two more we had
four
this is round four so we have at least
nobody nope that's it round five that's
it five people round robin because they
play each other
everybody gets one round off i think
this is the last round wait
five people
i'm thinking there's one more after this
yeah all right
you're like okay okay
our producers are i'm like i mean i'm
like looking by watching
like you know eight hours of
broadcast yeah
well we'll we'll tell you when you can
leave it
things are starting
moving today
to the early morning because i don't
think
i can
make the drive and rook c7 inviting
bishop b6 another possibility is just to
capture on d6 and enjoy the pin but i
think bishop b6 i would take it
yeah i think you have well
actually you take on the six do you can
you take back on d6 how do you defend
after queen to d3
exactly that was my question uh
can you take advantage of this bin or
not
he's not worried about that he doesn't
want to calculate
that makes the most sense that you're
making a very good point there uh oh but
not queen d7
this also allows the exchange of the e5
and d6 pawns this should help white
right
yep yep yep yep yep we're seeing queen
take c7 right now
perhaps it doesn't because it does open
up the dark square bishop on g7 so
there's a case to be made about that
okay how do we keep control of the
position as white you have the advantage
all you have to do is stabilize the
position how do we stabilize the
position
is rook to e1 perhaps the best move
just yeah i like that move i i truly do
just keeping the pawn on e5
this knight on e8 it's out of the game
if you take on d6 knight takes d6 you
open up the bishop the knight could
swing
into the game with tempo
rook e1
that's the stabilizing move i like it
very very much
rook e1
and by the way i just realized christian
that ever since we've gone into playoffs
we've never come to you
at the board
because we don't have time guys
everything is moving so fast
it's incredible i mean so nobody's seen
your face in like three hours
i'm okay with that you're this
disembodied voice
[Laughter]
does he exist is he real
is it alexa
[Laughter]
knight to d3 i like that move
also the b very good by the way what if
i if i take on c2 now you take on b7
that's one that is a trade that he's
looking to get out of this position
exactly
i like it i like this move knight to d3
well what i really like is that white
shabba is doing his utmost to maintain
the pawn on e5 as long as that pawn's on
e5 the knight on e8 is crying
and the bishop on g7 is also crying so
knight d3 as well as rook e1 sure had my
seal of
approval
knight to d3 we expect do we expect d5
or do we expect dmitry to maintain the
tension no d takes e5 well f takes e5
for me as an automatic i agree
kill the knight on e8 absolutely at
least make it lose some time to get to
c7
and then to d5 but that score d5 is
going to be easily controlled by my pawn
right because i'm going to go c4
if you don't take on c2 bingo exactly
but we are expecting f4 takes e5
nonetheless by the way i apologize that
i have to pull those away from this game
but there is also another game vladimir
versus larry
larry again is in a tie for first at the
moment as we speak with shibalov he is a
pawn down
with bishops of opposite colors
and
i don't know uh vladimir's for choice
but uh
still kind of feeling like this is a
three result game
uh for vladimir and larry more
interesting is the chabaloff game i'm
gonna go back to alex shabalov
and he took wednesday he took on c2
inviting
queen takes b7
he had to do it he had to do it to take
the bull by the horns take on c
get the knight to c7 if you can
do not allow the pawn to get to c4
because if that one would have landed on
c4 the knight would have been dead
shabala does not allow his opponent to
have active pieces so he says you want
very technical yeah you can have my pond
but that night on e8 is
horrible i'm not going to uh
let you do that how do we exchange the
queens right now for shibalov i was king
to h1 his
styling right now i have to say
i really like the way he's playing this
game
just avoiding a future knight c7 rook
takes c7 queen b6
check the times are so close too exactly
three minutes to three minutes or four
to four
yeah i forgot they were they're still on
the ten minute
with the two two-second delay so let's
get them to five minutes for the next
round
how do you say soft
with this move so
slowly reminds me of jeffrey shong
exactly this leisurely
let me play here well how about we
double up right now right q5 followed by
rook to c1 i love rook c5 let's go count
me on on that one that one is 100 kind
of a move
b4 e4
i love the pawn on b2
it was protected
it's all about
not allowing the knight at least not in
good fashion to get back into the game
but in hindsight rook c5 and russia
clear
by that he still has a very serious grip
on the position the question b6 to stop
roxy if i i think dmitry when he played
queen b5 saw it well can i play your c6
now if you want should be a really fancy
queen to c6 i like it
i like it i love it thank you
actually guys rook to c6 bishop takes e5
right but then you have a4 oh
man
he's getting ready to do that look to f3
three what is that maybe i thought you
were going to invade down the c file
rook to c6 rook to c1
you know or even maybe rook to c8 and
rook to c1 but rook f3 where's that rook
going
uh it's getting off the diagonal off uh
the a6 f1 it's crude so that's it
exactly it's protected
queen c6 is what he's intending i like
it no
i can never guess his moves
i like this shivalov i thought you
played rook f3 to protect the night
night i like this move actually because
now if you take back with the pawn i
will go a4 and i will uh cement that
weakness how about your c5 stuff
i will get there i will get the rook c5
but first i want to cement your weakness
on a5
how can that's why he takes with a queen
how could you not play queen c6 there
today
i mean if you really want queen trades
can i go queen before now
yeah you certainly can
but i wanted
i wanted to keep the pawns on the queen
side
uh
if queen c6 and we trade queens i take
the pawn so he played this move a4 but
what if i go b5 now
he he gets to trade off the queen side
isn't that helping black very much so in
my opinion this is a dream come true for
black to play b5 no play b5 oh my gosh
we can't guess bishop to h6 he wants to
get the knight c7 yeah
okay that's not a bad move actually
right until you see rook b1 and rook b5
and then you kind of regret the fact
that you didn't play b5 and just trade
off your weakness
yeah i'm not sure why he didn't play b5
i have to say
this surprise
me quite a lot once again shabbat
playing in such a way as to keep his
opponents pieces
tied up also this move rook c8 if you
play b5 now
rook a8 that's a problem
so right now you have to start
calculating knight to g7 the problem is
rook takes f8 take on f8 and now i have
the option of trading the queens with
queen to b4
that might be decisive that would be a
check you're right
bishop to g5 what does that move do it's
a pass
it's just a pass i didn't
it says i don't know what i should be
doing maybe i should play h5 before
can we just go queens somewhere attack
stuff i'm not sure you can't afford to
pass queen to c6 yeah thank you he's
done it
knight to g7 only move oh never mind
resignation wow wow
that puts a bolo from two and a half out
of the three games that he's that's a
commanding lead right now for chapala
what is larry christiansen if larry wins
larry will catch shibalov but larry is a
pawn down
yep he's upon down in the bishops of the
opposite color middle game position so
his chances of winning are not great
bishop e2
uh oh i spoke too soon
bishop to e2 queen to g3 i don't think
you did
no it's a it's a pawn up
i think there's anything big happening
at least not in the next few moves g5
g5 wait a minute first of all g5 doesn't
threaten anything right but the idea is
to to get to play after knight f3 so
what if i go f4 which is just played on
the board which was
a huge move because larry lifted his
kimono with this uh that was that was a
box well now let's lift a little more
let's go to g4
what what yeah why not
you can't take what the queen you have
to take with the pawn take with the pawn
that's fine still
that
your g-pawn is about to fall probably
you have to go yes yes i mean either
that or knight to f5
i don't like this if g5 didn't provo if
the king had been on h8 g5 would have
provoked knight f3
and now larry realizes this is an issue
and
well what i didn't like from copion is
that it feels like he relaxed for a
second there he was just looking around
saying okay i got this i secured the win
it's not yet over you have 34 seconds on
the clock
shoot
what happened nothing black feels better
now
what wait a minute takes e3 whoa
rook takes e3 what a shot but that's a
bad com yes look the rook
look look
oh
another double attack night for his
winning right now is it so clear though
because rookie won his message should be
fine naughty knights today terrible
terrible naughty nights
17 seconds and counting 15 seconds and
counting right now for a copy vladimir
can capture on h6 and what's the pond
count in that case man is that three
four five to two yes that is five
two seconds one second one second on the
clock
and there's a 97 shack and a knight
takes d5
still one second what are you gonna do
with one second
knight you move faster three you move
fast right now f6 f6 f6 exchange all the
pawns if possible bishop to g6 bishop to
g6
or bishop let's go
larry as long as he has larry has a
minute oh yes i thought i'm seeing 16.
no and vladimir putin get the knight get
the ninth race
all right well i i like that as well
knight b5
let's try to take on c4 and take
condition
or take on d4 yes or just take on h4
first is to check thank
you that's the crucial pawn that he
needs
larry's converting in a very very
professional way
bishop to e4 get the knight to d6
why bishop to b7 there was no reason to
go there wow f5 why would you do f5 yeah
that doesn't look like the right
movement okay i to c7
knight to c7 winning or knight c3 i like
it
we have a two-way tie for first
wait okay we're gonna have to see what
the pairings are gonna say
what we're setting up but it looks like
larry or shabba
are going to be playing for first and
it's ironic because a round or two ago
their classical game larry
was in first place yeah and a shabbat
tied with him
and here we go okay
dorsa do the honors
playoffs chabot has played three games
he has two and a half larry has played
three games he has two one half
those two are the ones we're gonna have
to keep an eye on right the others are
all out of it pretty much
okay but what's our remaining
round four for me my round four pairings
there's oh yes so actually gorgeous is
done gorice has played his four games
he's going home to take a nap before
closing ceremony very good
uh
but uh in the meanwhile let's jump to
christian who has a very special guest a
champion
we are here with a 2022 us junior girls
champion jennifer you jenny for you
simply pulled a miracle and uh with
three rounds to go you are two points
behind how did you feel about your
chances at that point
well i mean i knew it was theoretically
possible but like the likelihood of it
actually happening like i don't know
what the chances are i was just kind of
mad at myself throughout the tournament
because i just felt like i had a lot of
missed opportunities and i was just
playing kind of just strange chess
overall because i all know some of the
moves i was making um but yeah i just
there i like i knew it was possible but
generally they could happen and then
going into the last round you got one
point behind your faith was not in your
hands how did you approach today's game
i kind of um i didn't really think too
much going to this game i don't think i
played that well to be honest um i just
uh like i knew my opponent was kind of
also not too sharp this tournament so i
was just kind of waiting for her to make
a mistake but i don't think like i play
like the best i could but i was just
like oh you know it's not really in my
hands let's just do whatever and then um
when i found out there was a playoff i
was like oh i actually have a chance
here now one thing about today's game is
that we were looking on the camera and
we couldn't see you walking around the
playing hall almost at all it felt like
you were in the zone
is that how you felt as well i think in
the beginning i definitely was because
um i have that great position out of the
opening i mean this opening is just not
too good for black objectively but i
just wanted to get to a complicated
position um and i wasn't
i didn't really want to play like some
drawish like e45 line and then um so i
was for a bit and also like that game i
was a little bit um i think i was just
tired um and a little bit sleepy because
like it took a nap after just
before the playoffs just so i think that
was probably why were you keeping an eye
at all on that game between talia and
sophie yeah i checked up like
um at some point during the rounds but
um i mean yeah because it is pretty
important to me
and then the playoffs started and you
win the first game but then you lose to
talia how did you deal psychologically
with that situation
i mean i was just really upset about the
way i played um i'm not i think they
both play a lot more blitz than me at
least from like online like i just don't
play blitz and then the fact that it was
like delay instead of increment it was
really tripping me up so i think i was
just too slow in the beginning um
and then i just i
completely lost like the third position
against talia
um so i was not too happy and i was like
oh you know if she drops this game it's
pretty much over i mean it is over um
and then sophie with another miraculous
comeback and then i had like another
shot which was it was just i just kind
of like pretended like none of this
happened was the bit uh surreal at that
point you were looking at that game you
were hoping but not really hoping how
did you feel uh during that game
watching that game was so stressful
because i kept seeing like i think it
was at one point so we could have won an
exchange um and then i was just like oh
no just like so i was just like every
time like there was a little bit of
something i was like oh we can play this
move but um
yeah so it was pretty stressful but um
i have like played playoffs kind of
before not like this with three people
but i'm al so i'm like i i think i was
like level-headed now and then he won in
the blitz section the first game then
once again a huge battle with uh talia
did you feel any nerves at that point at
any point in the game or how did you
approach that
i was actually really comfortable with
that game um i messed up the opening
that was not what i was planning on
playing
um but i wasn't really concerned you
know i have like maybe the computer
valuations are good but i feel like it's
pretty comfortable for me to play
especially in a quick time control like
pretty natural moves and then um
i think at some point she started
hanging uh the c3 pawn was getting a
little bit weak and
um i mean i it was just very like clear
to me like oh i have some easy moves
here so i was
pretty happy with the position i got
jennifer congratulations you have a lot
of us around the world as well as your
in the united states your family any
words for them
um well i guess thank you everyone
[Laughter]
this is like my last time playing this
tournament getting too old so
um i guess it's like a nice way to
finish it off
a nice way uh to say goodbye to the u.s
junior girls congratulations jennifer
you are the champion and ourselves as
well dorsa and i congratulate you as
well jennifer you you are the 2022 u.s
junior girls champion
beautiful beautifully done and she does
go that's a big ticket once again
six thousand in prize money yeah
and uh october for the women's
championships that's the big she'll be
back and the seniors round
four
games
round five games i should say
two games are underway right now so
dmitry guravich and guess what
this is fantastic this is the
championship game between larry and
shybala who wrote the script the script
who writes the script dream
and they're they're underway the winner
of this game will be our senior champion
the other game doesn't really count that
uh
much for our uh
uh
perhaps it's mainly for the the price
money yes replacement exactly exactly i
do apologize because i don't have um
the games transmitted we'll use the
bird's eye view
and what we've got
oh we do i just came up
oops sorry
it's quite a lot of fun right right
okay there we go i've got it yay thank
you dorset of course i mean
between you and alejandro i would
i would be
hopeless no bishop a6 targeting this
pawn on c4
okay
knight to b fight no knight to d2 sorry
just defending the pawn and
intimating that in the very near future
he will have to move b2 b3 to reinforce
this pawn on c4
the c8 if you're going to reinforce the
pawn now would be a good time to do some
pressure on that justifies that justify
the devil's advocates please so if these
gentlemen draw
then they would go into blitz
[Music]
but nobody else can catch them no they
they'll be playing just between
themselves so no more three-way ties or
no more five ways
that's it that's it
this is it
the game that decides
the champion the irony of the ooh this
invites 95 and 93. the irony is that
larry last year
was in a playoff with gregory kaidanov
yep and he finds himself in yet another
playoff uh i was advocating right here
for the move b2b3 symptoms that is an
invitation that shabalov immediately
accepts but with this move rook e1 what
i don't like is
the very move that was played 95 and now
knight d3 yeah and wait a minute
uninvited guests i don't like i mean
they just show up guys i mean that is
there anything that's a big piece is
there any sacrifices on f2
knight to d3 thinking about f one knight
knight takes f2 yep that looks pretty
there's no knight g4 at the end though
no i understand i have bishop c5
i mean i would be thinking about this
yeah d5 and let's go but i don't know
i'll just take the dark square bishop if
you really want to do this before all
right
which is a bit strange right because now
what if i go queen to c2
well maybe that oh then your queen is in
front of my rook maybe i can do funny
business with d5 or b5 or e well we're
about to see it he's probably going to
go for it but if you do that then a3
will come on the board exactly oh and by
the way i think we have b5 but doesn't
that invite a3 yes it does
isn't that a problem as well yes it is i
think that's a problem because if you
take on c3 i take with the queen and
that targets the knight on e5
yeah can we just pull the bishop back or
to d6
to just protect the knights too it feels
like
i'm the one making the right moves well
i don't know you again you have put your
your queen
vis-a-vis uh the rook in
so you're saying the queen on c2 doesn't
actually help me right i've kind of
tricked you if you will into playing the
move uh queen to c2 because
basically
a move ago you know you you you play the
moroccy bind why
why is the pawn on c4 and e4 good i'm
stopping d5 yes
but if i don't stop b5 as well
then i'm ending up just
not having the meroxy bind and if you
take on b5 d3 is weak
one thing that might be
tempting at this point is f4 but i think
after knight g4 you might be in deep
trouble right you're asking for real
issues with queen b6 check maybe even
queen b6 first and then
g4 yeah this is not not the way to play
don't think you have pawn so the knight
on e5 is annoying and f4 i assume you
want to kick that knight away
so and the c4 pawn seems to be a little
bit of a gonzo so can we just go knight
f3 and get rid of that knight well then
you're going to sacrifice upon it
exactly i mean i feel like i'm losing
that pond anyways this way i might be
able to at least get rid of well thank
you
by the way
the situation knight takes yes my math
is correct uh not only that this is for
the championship but this is also a 7
000
swing rapid game
again first place i always remember the
first praise
five twenty twenty a lot more than i
remember the second prize what was the
second prize i guess it was thirteen
eighteen so that's your seven that's
right let me actually confirm that for
you
that was uh well calculated
that is a
well calculated
we got a 7 000 up for grabs here
and
shabalak has just played this new bishop
b7
which is an indication he's ready to
play the move d5 as well as a5
and he's cruising right now
uh larry has really butchered his
opening
with this rook e1 move i mean extra pawn
i understand you're going to do you
should be to try to get something on the
long diagonal but safe king safe king
not even
playing f4 he goes
bishop f4 okay just simply d6 right well
rook t1 and then queen
b6 or queen to c7 even no queen to c7
knight to b5 so i cannot do that the
move that has my attention
is a5 i want to create a weakness on the
a3 pawn d6 was played on the d7 d6
inviting rook d1 so we're being told
that this is even worse actually because
second place through the fifth actually
share everything so this is actually an
eleven thousand dollar game
oh
wait wait misinformation this
so the
the playoff is for first place yes stuff
stuff and that's it for free yes yes yes
whoever wins twenty thousand walks home
with twenty thousand and everybody else
shares everybody else gets second
through fourth
eleven thousand dollar
game right here and larry christensen is
upon
big big trouble right now everybody else
is gonna get nine thousand dollars yes
so dimitri gets nine thousand
and so on and so on and uh
the loser of this game will likewise get
9 000 seems a little unfair since both
of these guys are playing more
wow
they're working harder than the guys who
are in the clubhouse
nice
they're actually uh kopion is still
playing against maxwell oh that's true
pardon me they're not in their own play
they're going at each other you fight
hard in that game as well we're not
going to look at that but they are going
at each other
i
bespoke their badly yeah your queen b6
was played too
i don't know if that was mine oh well
christian actually on a very very rare
occasion
does occasionally occasionally
come up with something really good one
more occasion yeah one more occasion um
queen a6 looks a little awkward
queen is
i'm worried about the a7 pawn
that was why i wanted to play a5
earlier just so you saw you saw five
steps ahead when we were really but i
just like the idea of playing for a
weakness on a3
and now we're going to have a3a4 on
before he's on the board i i don't know
about that queen on a6 it looks
very peculiar this is a great impression
on me 97 is on the board exactly b5 okay
we're going to see
a5 queen a5
why why why did he play b5 right right
knight b5 i understood you'd be hitting
oh
it doesn't queen have to go all the way
back to some place but that's okay i go
queen sees that one that's actually the
sleeve right
no the move b5 gave up the c5 square
gave up the a5 square i despised that
move i i agree
knight
boy showing oh pardon me knight 35
there's a bishop bishop there's a bishop
hanging he's eyeballing the d3 square
but it was actually the bishop on
the same knight who we were talking
about knight d3 going to c7 bishop to e3
is on the board right now into c7 bishop
to e3 targeting that one on a7 but now
just simply bishop to a8
a6 any takers a6 b6 i don't know okay
good point
i like it
bishop a8 yep
you were right just because you don't
have a5 right now well you do but that
exchange is another part at some moment
i do believe the move d6 d5 i was
looking at f5
oh
open up the long diagonal the queen
landing on b7 it's good to be do you
like them apples oh very much
crunchy
bishop f4 one of the things i'm never
afraid of in a hedgehog is
bishop f4 takes e5 it's like go ahead
make my day take that knight and open up
the bishop on e7
um i think this is all
all shabbal off at this moment yeah it
feels in the past
f5 is on the board beautifully done
opening up that long diagonal queen b7
would be a hallelujah
something i feel like
oh larry
larry is getting it's getting worse and
worse
i i'm not 100 sure about that for
shabala for for larry i think larry's
position is toast yeah yeah bishop c5 is
coming those two bishops are so strong
right now and he played rook f1
bishop to f1
he's trying to get the bishop to g2 oh
can i just act with my other bishop f4
f4 bishop c5 hinting at bishop c5 next
followed by bishop to d4 so f4 is on the
board bishop to h3 tackling that pawn on
e6 okay i can defend with rook f6 which
hit it that is that's an easy one
and by the way uh intimating it's time
to double the rooks on the
on the f file at some point you will
have to go g4 as white well i'm thinking
bishop c5 when it lands
you're right you're to have to play g4
and uh well that's position right now a
threat is to actually take on g3 first
and then go bishop to c5 agreed agreed
so that is it might be the time to go g4
he goes on f3
i can't i'll just go bishop c5 check
just for the
well
i mean i take on g3 and i go group f8
right that's probably how do you deal
with
g2 is the only way out bishop to g2 but
then the g3 pawn
is tender also bishop to c5 and rook to
h6 wait a minute
are you slowly getting checked no
actually
g2 is game over after bishop c5 yeah
it's not so how do you defend f3 you
don't good
how did he play what did he do he he
tries with rook to f1 but
inviting oh this is
i've got
that's okay you can take only six
even though i can even start with queen
to b6 first right
queen b6 king g2
you haven't made a
winning impression yet
what is their times
larry has three minutes and four seconds
chabot is four minutes 34 seconds and
what about rook g6 just immediately oh
he pardoned me uh the idea is if you go
king to h
two i could go rook h king g2 was played
all right
bishop h4 bishop h4 bishop g4 maybe and
then
h5
he's going for it he's done it he's done
it oh knight to e2 after bishop to h4 oh
of course much stronger wait a minute
okay that that the pieces are starting
to look a little right they're kind of
drifting to discombobulated yes i'm so
afraid of that word by the way but
it's just kind of related
you you say discombobulated i say
discombobulated right which one is the
correct one discombobulated means messed
up
you're all messed up so when i say out
of harmony that's kind of the same thing
yeah yeah we'll give you a pass over
thank you
[Laughter]
87866 i think this is an indication that
shabala isn't
fully
go a little yeah
a5 whoa
larry if there's an active move in the
position
he'll do it a5
that would have been on my radar
my goodness bishop e3
i'm a little bit worried with the bishop
on g4 that there's going to be a rook
takes g4
and a bishop takes e4 sighting
careful spiny senses are tingling it's
because the queen moved away from c2
right spidey senses are tingling there's
something in the air right queen to c5
okay he's getting ready to take on g4
that's the problem how do we deal with
ready
he knows it too larry knows that rook g4
is on
shabba's agenda the bishop away
what is the difference between these two
players
everything to play for right now and
this it does seem like shabbat has this
one in the back right now right
he only needs to maintain precision
and he will take home the championship
and now he's reaching for his bishop
bishop h3
and look back bishop back larry says
draw
you know what i would do oh i was gonna
say i would bring rook to g6 bishop h3
h5 just to take away that g4 square he
wants to make sure it hurts
he wants your h5 but he's just going g6
h5 g6
now the problem is
for
larry uh these rooks
specifically the rook on d1
needs
needs a role and b5 is hanging and
is this game over guys uh
why the time
the time one minute and 35 seconds for
larry three minutes and 40 for shimalov
is it time for a move like queen b2 just
quickly done what does that do it passes
just says go ahead hit me with h5 i'll
go bishop h3 and then i take on f3
exactly and and that is the breakthrough
because e6 is hanging with a check
h
well that doesn't fight h5 that helps
that does invite h5 it oh it invites
bishop takes e4 as well it's giving
black a lot of options i would just go
for h5 just keep things nice steady
just just kick that bishop away yeah
this is a way h5 this is completely a
good impression and larry realizes the
moment he sees bishop e4 and i think he
saw it he just kind of like
uh the other game just finished in the
draw so
and you can also just start with h5 and
then take on e4 just so that you have
this extra h6 square for the king
yep nice
yup you're right that's just useful it's
it in case you give some tracks bishop
take c6 and then i can go king g7 or g7
king h6 and escape exactly
he's done it just as you prescribed the
ship takes if he follows up with bishop
takes c4
technical
g7 but is that too much because now you
have bishop to g2 finally king h2 had a
purpose exactly
exactly well oh geez
he's really trying to create a
masterpiece with this one okay g5 are we
going g4 h4 rook h6
everything everything you said
he's got to go g4 f4 h4 that's okay
g6 my goodness i was sure we were going
to hide ourselves on h6 i thought so too
or rook to f7 wow
b6 let's go oh
he's
he's erring a little bit right now
[Music]
okay the threat of b7 kind of provokes
bishop to be bishop to c6 yes but then i
go back
what do you mean back to d1
still number b7
i'll take that
excuse me sorry bishop to c6 i go rook
c7 what do you think exactly i'm
thinking i'm playing for g4 actually
guys
rook to c7 what do you play it's getting
maybe queen takes b6 rook takes c6 oh
exactly so okay maybe okay
then it's bishop to d4 right up to d4
that's a tempo on the queen good move
great move by shabalov
whoa and
exchange sacrifice
and i don't know guys how easy is this
right now oh e5 if queen takes bye bye
b6 i guess that's okay then i go f4 i
and then i try to push like that i i
like my position
this is much better than it was five
moves ago believe it's 40 seconds for
larry and two minutes for chapala and
larry is feeling awake
larry is feeling it right oh he's in
exchange now look how far that's okay
queen to d6 are you sure he's feeling it
right now i'm telling you
queen to d6 he's much happier than what
he had a couple sure i think what he had
a couple of moves ago was terrible but
queen d6 i take it and go rook d4
perhaps
he's still losing yes he has some
chances right now agreed
agreed
no question i thought he's completely
deaf
so i like that rook on f4
i love this
one not that happy but the queen but yes
i was saying rook be d8 but i guess i
mean if you eat palms yeah we're happy
exactly now c3 nice you you you kind of
pull
that was a check
things are getting slippery oh
larry with okay rook h4 could shut down
the activity down to h or rook f5
the other way rook to f5 okay
i like that too
no bishop to h3 or takes e5 you kind of
induce the rook maybe to a better square
on
f5 because it is hitting the pawn on e5
now
oh
oh look at this mate that's a check
mating threat queen takes h4 oh queen h4
check me
wow
those long moves huh
oh wow wow i got made what a clincher
that was i i think the arbiter came and
asked and larry said i got made it oh
no
queen h4 one of the longest moves you'll
ever see
an emotional moment beautifully done
right now for alex shabalov who
came out of nowhere in this tournament i
have to tell you he started off slowly
but
look what he did in the last few rounds
one on demand against larry yesterday
one on demand once again against larry
today
this is just incredible just by alex
chavalo our congratulations to the 2022
seniors championship and if anybody ever
asks you
do you
care
about your tournament chess the answer
is yes look at his reactions twenty
thousand dollars for the retirement our
congratulations to alexander cheval of
our new season such a wonderful event
retirement at this age no yasser he's
playing chess every single month he's
one of the most active players actually
on the roster true shabalov that is he
loves this game and he proves it with
every single game look at what he did in
the last couple of days i'm mightily
impressed i have to say
heartbroken for larry because larry last
year fell
yeah so close now he was so close he
went into the last round one point ahead
of at the pack and he lost against
somalia this is just incredible what
we've seen for from alexander i'm
mightily impressed with him
so
so much heartbreak in this event then
there she is she is heartbroken as well
she doesn't show it
she doesn't show it she's ready to dance
this was her facing uh sophia morris
suzuki pacing during those playoff games
she played yes
yeah she's getting off the butterflies
but that was a heartbreak for her as
well i have to say for for me watching
the seniors play and especially these
playoffs i mean it's it really felt to
me like
shabbat was pouring his soul yeah to
each move into each moment and like just
at the very end at this moment when he
you know he could take on b6 he could
take on e5 he saw
out of the corner of his eye that queen
a4 he could play queen h4 check the
predictions right quickly yesterday i
got lucky done look i i was so far off
shame on me
uh i think you did get lucky
he didn't get lucky
and who picked chavalla
well
i'm
i don't give it too often to alejandro
but
he made a good prediction on this one he
really felt like that christopher used
to get any of the sections right
welcome to the show there's always good
to have you on on the show with
christian and i we love the competition
especially when you're around
wow uh
guys i'm not kidding but i i think this
i told you i got a an invitation to go
to the opening ceremony that started
90 minutes ago i agree yeah
oh my goodness
and christian with our champion and that
closing ceremony definitely did not
start without our champion
congratulations alex just an incredible
finish to the tournament and an
incredible tie breaks what are your
initial feelings after this roller
coaster of the day um
i mean obviously a relief
everything that i did
last six weeks
paid off in the end well
so
uh what did you do in the last six years
okay
i started this trip uh from
um
now north carolina open so i went there
uh four and a half out of five and
then i
went a lot to visiting my parents for
five days
and after that i played non-stop
our world
team seniors in italy
were
us took a silver behind
england
and world open
nine rounds here and the playoffs
that's a lot of games
now a player half or less than that of
your age would probably feel exhausted
at that point how did you feel coming
into the event was that maybe the reason
why you started off slowly
um
maybe i don't know uh no actually the
that game that uh i was bitten by uh
lady maricopa and it just uh
was a display of the high class i mean
he was a
much higher uh class player than
everyone else in the tournament
and uh it's just like uh
and usually the first time player uh
wins this thing so he was he came really
close so
uh he will be a formidable force in a
way
uh in the years to come and uh of course
all kudos goes to laurier i mean what a
fighter what a what a guy i mean
uh
just
again had a terrific play of and i don't
know what what's why it should be me you
know who ruined his day you know uh just
for a second time uh around so
um
yeah well well alex i have to say uh
during the tie breaks uh it just felt
like you had more energy you had more
ideas you were just bringing the
creative touch to the game did you feel
that way how did you get ready for this
tie breaks did you have any time to get
ready for the thai breaks uh no
absolutely not we just finished the game
with maxim i didn't know and go back to
my room i think we started like what 20
minutes after that
so
no i mean it's a good thing that i
didn't have any time to think it over so
just had to sit down and play
and no of course it's the lottery and
it's um
well sort of lottery you would expect
that uh maxime and
dmitry would do really well because
there are notorious
speed players and they play in a lot of
online and
they didn't yeah just
i mean larry you know people who do not
play online basically alex this is a big
title for you what does it mean to you
and how important it is that it was so
hotly contested
uh
yeah frankly uh this year i thought like
many times i thought it's not going to
be my year i mean there was
so many people who deserve it more than
i did and uh
but
i mean it feels sweeter than you know my
first title back in 19
just because of this such a dramatic
fashion that it was
i mean what can i say
i still i'm still in the playoffs so
alex have any
particular moments in the games that uh
could have gone the other way oh i don't
think so we're not going to yeah
right now alex i know you're still in
play mode uh we just wanted to hear your
thoughts and your emotions uh very happy
for you congratulations once again alex
and you are the 2022 u.s seniors chess
champion thank you our congratulations
uh shabba go to the world chess hall of
fame across the street pick up your 20
000
prize money you deserve it
and our congratulations sum it up for us
here we've got three champions let's
take a quick look at the old friends
well start with the girls
final standing jennifer you did win the
tournaments after a lot of ups and downs
she got six thousand dollars and natalya
and sophie shared a prize on the second
place and our juniors christopher you
had a wonderful event yes he did
congratulations to him yeah he got
twelve thousand dollars
and
andrew hung eight 000
mishra and balaji each with 4 500 and in
the senior section
we know one player got twenty thousand
yeah a lot of players got nine and
dimitri larry
vladimir and maxime all got nine
thousand dollars and tied for second our
congratulations to each and everyone but
before we go away
have you had enough chess well upcoming
events include just next week
we pick up the grand chester
croatia rapid and blitz followed by
saint louis rapid and bliss in august
and the
granddaddy of them all
think filled cup don't miss that one and
immediately following we have the chess
9lx that's the bobby fischer chess 960
if you will
and then finally
us
women
and men and open
championship
and christian uh sum up this
extraordinarily long day for everybody
three champions long day long tournament
but what three tournaments this were
just incredible fight in absolutely
every single section we've seen the
juniors christopher yu is just having a
breakout year right now he's closing in
on 2600 feet and he's just playing
brilliant chess at only 15 years of age
we might be seeing the next fabiano
caruana of the world wesley sews of the
world maybe even the next bobby fishers
of the world right now this is history
in the making and of course what we've
seen in the seniors as well as the
junior girls championship the tenacity
that these ladies and seniors have
showed is just remarkable i have to say
i had a lot of fun and i had a lot of
fun calling the action with you two guys
as well as with alejandro hello
alejandro i know you're probably
sleeping right now in croatia but it was
a lot of fun we've had a lot of fun and
we will be back in just less than a week
so i'm looking forward to that
absolutely
as we wrap up very quickly big shout out
to our host the st louis chess club at
scholastic center all of you you know
who you are thank you thank you thank
you our production team that works so
hard that makes us look good
thank you thank you thank you dorsa
thank you for coming in and
covering for aleandro
thank you everyone for staying with us
it's been quite a day good night
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited